later today of course as this process
unfolds uh the pictures are up from the
uh tv folks over at the uh senate so the
session is about to begin there's
senator lott going in we're going to
hear an announcement from him as we
often do as we always do at the start of
the session and hopefully he'll lay out
exactly what's going to happen and if
there is a recess we will
continue to do more programming
including perhaps your calls here's the
senate
so
one
so
so
okay
bring it back
god
oh
good
here
please
when the senators
return to the desks
the senate will convene as a court of
impeachment the chaplain will offer a
prayer
dear god we are moved by your
accessibility to us
and our accountability to you
we hear your promise sounding in our
souls be not afraid
i am with you
we place our trust in your
problem-solving power
your conflict resolving presence
and your anxiety dissolving peace
so we report in to you for duty
what you desire you inspire
what you guide you provide
this is your nation
we are here to serve you
just as daniel webster said that the
greatest conviction of his life
was that he was accountable to you
we press on with a heightened awareness
that you are the unseen lord of this
chamber
the silent listener to every word that
is spoken
the judge of our deliberations and
decisions
bless the senators with the assurance
that your work
done with total trust in you and respect
for each other
will not lack for your resources
surpass
any impasse
with divinely inspired solutions
you are our lord
and savior
amen amen
[Music]
the sergeant-at-arms will make the
sergeant arms will make the proclamation
hear ye hear ye hear ye
all persons are commanded to keep silent
on pain of imprisonment while the senate
of the united states is sitting for the
trial of the articles of impeachment
exhibited by the house of
representatives against william
jefferson clinton
president of the united states
if there's no objection the journal of
proceedings of the trial are approved to
date personal to the provision of senate
resolution 16 there are six hours and 33
minutes remaining during which senators
may submit questions in writing directed
to either the managers on the part of
the house of representatives or the
council for the president
the majority leader is recognized thank
you mr chief justice as is obvious by
the absence of the the managers and the
council and a number of the senators the
two uh uh parties are still meeting in
conference at this time
i believe we're close to reaching an
agreement uh which would outline today's
uh impeachment proceedings but will
probably be an hour or so before we can
complete that because we need to explain
it uh in detail to our respective uh
conference and
conferences
and uh i'll also make sure we've reduced
it to writing where we understand
exactly what we're we're agreeing to
i will in a moment ask that the senate
stand in recess until 2 pm i apologize
for any inconvenience to
senators or the chief justice but i
think that what we're discussing
in the long run would save some time and
lead us to a fair procedure through the
balance of the day and how we begin even
tomorrow therefore now i ask unanimous
consent the senate stand in recess until
2 pm
without objection
senator from new hampshire
mr chief justice i have a parliamentary
inquiry i'd like to submit to the chair
uh it requires you now the
parliamentarian says it takes
unanimously well i would ask you to ask
consent to ask
reserving the right to object uh i
believe that that
is going to be made mr chief justice
uh something that does require unanimous
consent
that it would be wise if they could be
done at a time when both leaders are on
the floor well the
democratic leader i would
without objection then the senate stands
at recess until 2 pm
i have moved forward with this after the
november elections because of the way
the elections went the american people
spoke we want this the senate will be in
order
mr chief justice chair recognize the
majority leader the chief justice uh
it's my understanding that the question
and answer period is now completed in a
moment i will propound a unanimous
consent agreement that will outline the
next steps in this process
in the meantime
i would ask unanimous consent that
senators be allowed to submit statements
and introduce legislation at the desk
today i further ask consent that when
the senate completes its business today
is standing in germany until 1 pm on
tuesday to resume the articles of
impeachment
without objection
i note that the democratic leader isn't
on the floor may i inquire has this been
clear
and i just want to observe mr chief
justice that
uh there are still some discussions
underway uh you'll note that senator
daschle is not here and uh unless
there's an objection of what i just did
i'm prepared to move uh or uh observe
the absence of a question so that we can
have
time for the senators to return to the
point of clarification to the majority
leader did you say that we would come in
tomorrow at one i did there had been uh
if i might respond mr chief justice
there had been some discussion about
coming in earlier
but
because of a number of conflicts that i
understand from the house managers and
concerns that we would need that time to
continue to have discussions
we thought we'd go ahead and come in at
one but let me add that if uh during the
process of the day
there's a decision we'd need to change
that either earlier or later we could
revise that request this is just to
get to move the process forward as we
have announced each day would come in at
one except on saturday but if there's a
need to change the time we'll certainly
uh be
very considerate of that request mr
chief justice i thank the majority
leader
mr chief justice i
suggest the absence of court the clerk
will call the roll
mr abraham
um
mr allard
mr ashcroft
mr bacchus
um
mr bennett
mr biden
mr bingaman
mr bond
mrs boxer on this ninth day of the
impeachment trial of the president of
the united states the senate was in
session briefly at one o'clock as they
had said they would do last friday but
they quickly went back out said they
would be back at two they came back in
session at two o'clock but have now gone
to a quorum call and as this quorum call
continues
we're interested in your thoughts on
what you've seen and whether or not
you've reached an opinion whether you're
for acquittal for conviction or
undecided the area codes 202 and 624 11
11 is for acquittal for conviction is
624 11 15 undecided
737-6734 we will take your calls as long
as the quorum call continues when it's
over we'll be back to the senate floor
and corning california is up first
um yeah okay um i think it's kind of
ridiculous the uh
okay the republicans they uh they keep
getting uh monica lewinsky up there
and she's i don't know how many times
she's been testified and she said the
same thing over and over again mr bunny
and uh every time she you know she gets
up there they keep hoping that just one
more time she's going to change her
story so they can nail the president on
perjury
and
you know we we put them in office and if
if we're the ones that can put them in
office there should be some sort of way
we can pull them out of office um you
know there it's the day one that he's
been in office they've uh they've been
after him trying to get him out
you know they think it's a little bit
ridiculous they should just
quit this crap and work together instead
of
working against each other
thanks that call on the line for
acquittal was from corning california
the line for conviction is oceanside
california good morning good morning
i'm promotion side
uh i just want to say that intelligent
people that are elected to the senate
and try to follow the
rules the regulations of the things that
are written
about misdemeanors be eligible for
a conviction
or for removing from office
i can't understand why perjury which is
a much
greater
offense than a misdemeanor
why they are arguing at all about going
ahead with a conviction i listen to
these
absolutely ignorant illiterate people
that call in and say that they think
that four women
uh were conspiring against
the president to get him out of office
monica lewinsky and paula jones and all
of these
i can't understand that he was he was
bad enough as a governor
12 years having an affair with jennifer
flowers i can't understand at all how
any senator can sit there
in that uh in the well or wherever it is
they are in congress and go ahead and
say
that they they don't think that perjury
is enough to impeach that presidency
on the undecided line is washington d.c
uh yes um well um i just like to say
that um i think the house republicans
have brought a pretty good case against
clinton although i don't want to render
judgment until all the
information is in yet and i think
there's a good need um on both sides so
some of the republicans said there was
the white house made a good case for
calling witnesses i think i'd like to
hear at least a couple of them to pull
i i certainly think that they would sway
uh the democrats and republicans one way
or another uh
even more decisively i'd like to see
like a 90 to 10 vote or something either
way and i think the witness could uh
certainly uh pull them over the top and
also a uh one of your earlier callers
mentioned that uh
we did just have a recent election so um
we have reelected the congress just as
much as uh the president is elected
twice and uh that certainly um we both
select both branches and they both have
a
big save uh what the people should say
and they both have to follow the
constitution and they it's they're both
constitutional duty certainly uh 535
members of congress elected by the
people is a lot more
than that single president that we've
elected and they may have a better mind
saw the constitution than he does thank
you
thank you for the call bedford texas
good afternoon
i just called to vote for acquittal
well tell us why
can you tell us why
yes
please do
did i call you live is that what you
said no i want you to tell us why you're
for acquittal
oh i'm against this whole thing that's
going on up there in washington for the
last five years
i've resigned from the democratic party
and the republican party
and i belong right now i'm supporting
the reform party
and i'll never go for anything like this
again
i'm very disgusted with the whole border
dash that's been going on
greenville pennsylvania is undecided
yes i'm i'm my name is dorsey glancing
the only reason i'm undecided because
i don't believe that we should have seen
as church and state and
turn the volume down on your tv we'll be
able to hear you just a little bit
better because that's what the
republicans were yelling about because
we got it right here in greenville
pennsylvania and that's why it's on our
computers and the people want to look it
up and see what it's all about and
that's why they're trying to evict our
president because he he did not he
vetoed the bill
monteca california
hello hi garage please
hi i'm for acquittal
and the reason being is i'm a
retired california state employee
and this really brings back a lot of bad
memories to me because in the state of
california when you are accused whether
you are guilty or innocent
you must prove your innocence you are
guilty
before you ever have a chance to go to
court and i would like to know
a jury what jury can you serve on where
you can go and discuss the case like
i mean what's going on right now these
senators are talking back and forth and
everything else and when you serve on a
jury which i've served on you are not
supposed to discuss the case with anyone
and i don't believe in this world there
is one man
that has committed adultery or woman
that would not lie to protect their
family and i believe this is what this
man has done
vancouver washington on the line for
conviction good afternoon hello hi
say you know what i what i want to know
is is what about our our service as
americans in in our duty to god
you know
if
we're reaching a real turning point as
far as i'm concerned in this country
on what happens here if we don't do
something about it now it's just going
to pave the way way for others and every
to do bad in public office
and everyone is confusing the issue it
doesn't matter what bill clinton did
it doesn't matter
what he did it was the vehicle he chose
to to do that
what he did was lie about it later
and the democrats
and some republicans i you know i mean
on both sides are trying to confuse the
issue
with a bunch of smoke and hocus pocus
just i don't know if it's just to get
you know to
prolong their jobs or whatever but it's
just so in your face what needs to
happen
and so i'm for conviction
edgefield south carolina you're
undecided
south carolina didn't hold for us we go
to diamond bar california good morning
good morning how are you
good tell us why you're for acquittal
i'm for acquittal because
i'm 64 years old and i
have practiced medicine for
34 years mr graham
this whole thing
from my vantage point
is based on chicanery
on the part
of the prosecutors
first of all
paula jones just didn't show up
without a lot of help and the help of
linda trippsters and the fact
that
the case and the definition of a sexual
relation
was defined
by
the prosecution
and they knew exactly what they were
doing
now i can assure you that
if you leave out oral sex from the
definition of a sexual relation or
sexual intercourse
um that's what it's supposed to do
because
many many of my patients and many many
of people in this country
will tell you that
that oral
genital contact is not sexual
intercourse and it's not a sexual
relationship
and therefore
the president did not commit perjury i
think that
the republicans have yelled pear perjury
perjury perjury rule of law and they
want to keep saying that until
they believe themselves but by the
definition of perjury as a legal term
it doesn't reach that level
and houston texas good afternoon
johnson
go right ahead please uh yes um uh i do
believe
for conviction
tell us why
because
i just don't believe that william
jefferson clinton is the best man that
we have to run this great nation
i always vote republican and always have
in the past and always will in the
future but i would not be opposed to
having a democrat in office if it could
be a democrat that i could actually
respect and i find that the shallowness
of people whether they are republican or
democrat and saying that um
that that honor and being trustworthy
does not matter anymore it's just it's
actually it's bewildering to me
last call on the line for a conviction
was from houston on the line for
acquittal is from tyler texas good
afternoon hi good afternoon uh
my problem is is that the whole the
whole system seems to have problems and
holes in it uh the house didn't call
witnesses
uh now the now the senate would like to
call witnesses
uh
it just doesn't seem like it's a very uh
it's not equal
it's not equally now uh at all i believe
that the man probably lied
uh
i know he did
in my heart
uh but if i was in that situation
you know i probably would have lied to
uh let's put all you know all the house
all the senate
put their hands up let them swear and
then ask them the same questions and see
what happens
thanks texas toledo ohio
yeah hi um i'm just calling to say uh
first of all
uh the president purges himself it
doesn't matter what he lied about
or it has nothing to do with sex the
fact is he lied and that's all there is
to it
secondly
uh i keep hearing about bipartisanship
on the part of the republicans how
they're all one-sided well the democrats
themselves are all one-sided too
another thing is it was a total reckless
behavior
on the part of the president to do what
he done knowing
the investigation was going on knowing
what would happen if he was caught
and it just doesn't make any sense why
he would do that thanks ohio berryville
virginia undecided
hello
well uh
you have to be undecided because
in this country you have a
judicial system where
you are
not guilty until proven guilty uranus
until proven guilty i don't understand
though
every one of these senators
has sworn an oath
to listen to this uh hearing or trial if
you will
without objection mr chief justice i had
uh earlier asked for a couple of
unanimous consent requests uh but uh the
democratic leader was not on the floor
and it was not officially objected to or
officially ruled as not having been
objected to so i'm going to assume that
that was all null and boyd we're going
to start over again
the requests are withdrawn
now uh to uh repeat what we had earlier
uh discussed and make sure that members
understand it uh it is our stand
understanding and our agreement that the
question and answer period is now
completed
and i will now compound a unanimous
consent request that would allow
senators to submit statements and
introduce legislation at the desk today
without objection it's so ordered with
regard to the uh time
that will
be involved today and the time we will
come in
on tuesday we will have further
discussions on that and we'll have a
consent request on that
later on in the day or at the close of
business now i have a unanimous consent
request that would allow us to have a
clear understanding
and an orderly procedure
for the balance of the day
i have
discussed this with my counterpart on
the other side of the aisle both
conferences have had a chance to talk
about it i think it's a fair
way to proceed where we would have a
chance to
discuss the issues that are before us
and get us to a conclusion of this part
of the impeachment proceedings in a
logical way
first mr chief justice i ask unanimous
consent that following the conclusion of
the arguments by the managers and the
council today on the motion to dismiss
and i note that the next order business
is two hours equally divided one hour on
each side
on a motion to dismiss uh when if it is
filed uh by any senator and after that
it'd be in order for senator harkin to
make a motion to open all debate
pursuant to his motion timely filed
and that the senate proceed immediately
to the vote pursuant to the impeachment
rules i further ask that following that
vote if defeated it be in order to move
to close the session for deliberations
on the motion to dismiss as provided
under the rule impeachment rules and the
senate proceed to an immediate vote
i further ask that if the senate votes
to proceed too closed session that those
deliberations must conclude by the close
of business today notwithstanding the
10-minute rule allocated under the
impeachment rule
mr
objection mr chief senator from iowa
reserving the right to object
mr chief justice is does he reserve the
right to object or did he object
the parliamentarian tells me the senator
does not have the right to reserve the
right to object
mr chief justice i i just have a
modification that i would like to
discuss with the leaders just a brief
modification of that that would not
engender an objection is that mr chief
justice uh so that we can uh consider
this an appropriate manner i would
suggest absence reform
the clerk will call the role mr abraham
mr akaka
mr allard
mr ashcroft
mr bacchus
mr bye
mr bennett
mr biden
mr bingaman
mr bond
this is boxer
mr bro
mr brownback
mr brian
mr bunny
mr burns
mr bird
mr campbell
mr chafee
mr cleland
mr cochran
is colin
mr conrad
mr coverdell
mr craig
mr crapo
mr daschle
the wine
mr died
stir them energy
mr dorgan
sister durbin
mr edwards
mr feingold
this is feinstein
mr fitzgerald
mr frist
mr gorton
mr graham of florida
mr graham of texas
mr grahams of minnesota
mr grassley
mr greg
mr hegel
i thought you
thought you took it
i like that you said you were doing it
mr harkin
mr hatch
[Music]
this is hutchinson of taxes
a stir in half
mr noah
mr jeffords
mr johnson
mr kennedy
mr carey of nebraska
mr carey of massachusetts
mr cole
mr kyle
there's andrew
mr lautenberg
mr leahy
mr levin
mr lieberman
this is lincoln
let's stir a lot
[Music]
mr luger
mr mack
mr mccain
as you've learned nothing is certain mr
mcconnell
ms mikulski
mr moynihan
mr murkowski
this is murray
mr nickel
mr reed of rhode island
mr reed of nevada
mr roberts
mr rockefeller
[Music]
mr roth
mr santorum
mr sarbanes
mr schumer
mr sessions
thanks
mr shelby
she said to go slower
[Music]
[Music]
now
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
very well
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
foreign
so
[Music]
the chair recognizes the majority leader
mr chief justice i ask the senators
return to their desks
and uh after a great deal of
conversation i would like to amend my
unanimous consent a quorum call is in
privacy the quorum call be dispensed
with
without objection it's so ordered and i
renew my request
uh as previously outlined with one
change and that is
uh
that it's say in the first sentence
unanimous consent that following the
conclusion of the arguments by the
managers and the council today on the
motion to dismiss that it be in order
for senator harkin to make a motion to
open that debate instead of all the word
is that debate with that no other
changes and i renew uh the request mr
chief justice is there objection mr
chief senator from iowa
mr chief justice the preservation is
withdrawn
okay in the
the senator from wisconsin mr chief
justice i object
objection is heard
mr chief justice uh
i would like to suggest a quorum
again
the clerk will call the role mr abraham
mr akaka
yes sir
mr allard we normally do
mr chief justice
the chair recognizes the majority leader
welcome to the operations of the united
states senate
i observe the absence of a quarrel
i ask that it be dispensed with mr chief
is there is without objection it's so
ordered
uh and uh mr chief justice was the
unanimous consent agreement agreed to
not yet i renew my request
mr chief justice
objection is heard chief justice i ask
i and senator collins the junior senator
from maine
ask unanimous consent
that when the senate considers the
anticipated motion to dismiss
that it shall vote on two separate
questions first whether to dismiss
article one
of the articles of impeachment and
second whether to dismiss article two
there's a pending uh request for
unanimous consent by the majority leader
who has not surrendered the floor
mr chief justice uh under his
reservation if the senator would yield
to me
i believe that if we can get this
agreed to
you could make your request and then it
could be ruled on
mr chief justice i would yield the floor
the senator would like to proceed in
that fashion simply mr chief justice
i renew my request uh then for the
unanimous consent requests as outlined
earlier objection is there objection
in the absence of the j of objection is
so ordered mr chief justice
the senator from wisconsin simply renew
my request along with the junior senator
from maine unanimous consent request
that when the senate proceeds to vote on
the anticipated motion to dismiss that
the question be divided
into a separate vote on article one of
the articles of impeachment and then a
separate vote on article two of the
articles
is there objection
objection is heard
this chief justice now if i could
outline uh the results of our efforts
there and i i want to thank senator
daschle and and my colleagues on his
side of the aisle on this side of the
aisle to try to come up with a process
that's that's fair that would give us an
opportunity to debate
today this important issue it's never uh
easy to get 100 senators to agree on a
method to proceed so i i i think this
was a good accomplishment i i think won
it all
i understand now that senator byrd will
offer the motion to dismiss
the information of all members once that
motion is offered there will then be two
hours for debate the house managers will
be recognized to open the debate and
then following the that the white house
arguments the house managers will be
recognized again for closing remarks at
that point the consent agreement would
apply i would anticipate taking our
first break at the conclusion of the
first two hours of arguments by the
managers unless there's an urgent need
to do so earlier
and of course the arguments by the
managers and the white house and then we
would go forward with this agreement
which would require the vote on the
harkin
motion to open the debate the vote on
the um
amendment to close for debate on the
motion to dismiss
and then uh the debate which would uh uh
go on a 10-minute rule notwithstanding
until the close of business today i
yield the former chief justice
the chair recognizes the senator from
west virginia mr chief justice
i send a motion in writing to the desk
the clerk will read the motion
the senator from west virginia mr burr
moves that the impeachment proceedings
against william jefferson clinton
president of the united states
be
and the same are duly dismissed
first one to rule 21 of the senate rules
on impeachment the managers on the part
of house of representatives of the house
of representatives and the council for
the president each have up to one hour
to argue the motion the chair recognizes
the house managers
mr chief justice
members of the senate
on behalf of the house of
representatives
i rise to speak in opposition to the
motion to dismiss
during the hour allotted to the managers
i will offer a few introductory comments
concerning why adoption of the motion
would be inconsistent with
constitutional standards
and harmful to the institutions of our
government
mr hutchinson mr graham and mr geekus
will present argument concerning
the facts in the law
then mr hyde will close
at the outset i must urge you to
consider the fact that this motion to
dismiss is without precedent
the senate has never
not once in the more than 200 year
history of our constitution
dismissed a proceeding against an
official who remained in office
after impeachment by the house of
representatives
i humbly urge you
not to depart from the senate's
well-established
practice of fully considering cases of
impeachment and rendering the judgment
of either conviction or acquittal
in the midst of the great differences
between the president's council and the
house managers
there actually is at least a little
common ground
both sides agree
that the impeachment and removal power
is designed to protect the well-being of
the institutions of our government
but there is a critical difference
that divides us as is obvious from
the argument that has gone before
the managers have argued that this power
the power of impeachment and removal is
a positive power granted by the
constitution to maintain the integrity
of government
a power to preserve
protect and strengthen our
constitutional system against the
misconduct of officials that would
subvert undermine or weaken the
institutions of our government
the president's lawyers on the other
hand advance a much narrower view of the
role of the impeachment power in
protecting our institutions
their case rests on the argument that it
is a power to use only in response to
conduct
threatening devastating harm to the
system of government
at least
when it is used against a president
but i would submit to you
that alexander hamilton did not
contemplate that the impeachment process
would be so restricted when he spoke of
it as a method of national inquest
into the conduct of public men
and james arendelle did not have such a
narrow view in mind when he spoke of the
accountability through impeachment of
anyone who willfully abuses his trust
arendelle did not have such a limited
view when he spoke of the impeachment of
a president who as he said acted from
some corrupt motive or other
now under the standards urged by the
president's lawyers the misdeeds of
richard nixon would not meet the
threshold for impeachment and removal
what he did was corrupt
the legal rights of citizens were
treated with contempt
president nixon showed an egregious lack
of respect for the law
but all these misdeeds did not threaten
the sort of ruinous harm to the system
of government that the president's
lawyers
argue
would be required to justify
conviction and removal
after all the court charges against
president nixon related to the cover-up
of a third-rate burglary
members of the senate as you consider
the motion to dismiss
i ask you to pause and to reflect on the
consequences of the standard advocated
by the president's lawyers consider the
consequences for the system of justice
of allowing the president's dangerous
example of lawlessness to stand
consider the consequences for the
presidency itself
i respectfully submit to you
the standard advocated by president
clinton's lawyers will debase and
degrade the institution of the
presidency i know that is not the
intention of the president's lawyers but
it is the necessary consequence of their
position
only 42 men have held the office of
president of the united states
some of them have been ordinary men of
limited talent
a handful of our presidents have been
great men
most have been capable men who brought
special skills to the office
no matter what our individual judgments
may be concerning president clinton it
is clear that he is one of the most
intellectually gifted and politically
skilled men to hold the office of
president
he was raised to this great eminence the
most powerful office in the greatest
nation in the history of the world
an unparalleled opportunity
honor and privilege
and in this position of eminence and
honor and in this position of trust what
did he do
he made a series of choices that has
brought us to this day
he made the choice to violate the law
and he made that choice repeatedly
he knew what he was doing
he reflected on it
perhaps he struggled with his conscience
but when the time came to decide he
deliberately and willfully chose to
violate the laws of this land
he chose to turn his back
on the very law he was sworn to uphold
he chose to turn his back on his solemn
oath of office he chose to turn his back
on his constitutional duty
as you deliberate on this motion i ask
you to consider what william jefferson
clinton has done to the integrity of the
great office he holds as a trust i ask
you to consider the harm he has caused
the indignity he has brought to the
institution of the presidency
some have asked
of us where is the compassion where is
the spirit of forgiveness
now let me say that i for one believe in
forgiveness
without forgiveness what hope would
there be for any of us
but forgiveness requires repentance
it requires contrition
and so i must ask
where is the repentance
where is the contrition
it is true the president has expressed
regret for his personal misconduct but
he has never
he has never accepted responsibility for
breaking the law
he has never taken that essential step
as the
argument advanced so vigorously by his
counsel makes clear
he has refused to accept responsibility
for breaking the law
he has stubbornly
resisted any effort to be held
accountable for his violation of the law
for his violation of his constitutional
oath and his violation of his duty as
president
to this day he remains adamantly
unrepentant
and of course under our system of
justice even sincere repentance which is
so lacking here does not eliminate all
accountability
now in the discussion thus far the
debate
has
brought the concept of proportionality
to the fore from time to time you have
been urged to reject your own precedence
the clear precedence establishing that
crimes such as lying under oath justify
conviction and removal the principle of
proportionality it has been urged
requires that the rule you have applied
to federal judges
not be applied to the president of the
united states
i will be the first to concede
that removing a president of the united
states is without doubt
a more momentous decision than removing
one of the hundreds of federal judges
that hold office in this country when
the chief executive is removed the
gravity of the matter undeniably reaches
a higher level but it is also true
and it must not be forgotten that when
the president engages in a calculated
and sustained course of conduct
involving obstruction of justice and
perjury
the gravity of the consequences for the
nation also
reaches
a far higher level
such lawless conduct by the president
does immeasurably more to subvert public
respect for the law than does the
misconduct of any federal judge or any
other federal official
as has been pointed out more than once
the constitution contains a single
standard for impeachment and removal of
all civil officers there is not one
standard for the president and another
standard for everyone else there is
nothing in the constitution that
requires you or allows you
to set a lower standard of integrity for
the president than the standard you have
set for other officials who have been
convicted and removed by your solemn
action
now although they can point to nothing
in the constitution the president's
lawyers assert that the president is
simply different because he is elected
to that let me say this
the senate itself has established a
standard of integrity for its own
elected members
that president clinton could not meet
as recently as 1995
an elected senator resigned under
imminent threat of expulsion for
offenses that included acts similar to
the acts of obstruction of justice
committed by president clinton
senator robert packwood was elected
yet he was on his way to certain
expulsion
listen to what the committee
the senate select committee on ethics
had to say about senator packwood's
conduct
he was guilty the committee found
of withholding altering and destroying
relevant evidence conduct which is
expressly prohibited by 18 united states
code section 1505. senator packwood's
illegal acts they said constitute a
violation of his duty of trust to the
senate
and an abuse of his position as a united
states senator reflecting discredit upon
the united states senate
the statute referred to by the committee
in the packwood case is closely
analogous to the obstruction of justice
statute the president has violated
senator packwood unlawfully sought to
impede the discovery of evidence
president clinton has done the same
thing
for his violation of the law senator
packwood an elected senator was judged
worthy of expulsion from the senate
but the president's lawyers argued the
president should be held to a lower
standard of integrity
than the standard you have set
for yourselves as members of the senate
according to them the constitution
establishes a lower standard of
integrity for the president than the
standard for senators a lower standard
than the standard for federal judges
and a lower standard than the standard
for members of the armed forces of the
united states ladies and gentlemen of
the senate i submit to you that the
president's lawyers
honorable as they are
are simply wrong
they advocate an arbitrary standard that
would insulate the president from the
proper accountability for his misconduct
under our constitution
our constitution does not establish a
lower standard of integrity for the
president of the united states the
senate
i respectfully submit to you should
follow
the well-established president of the
senate the senate should reject the
motion to dismiss
mr hutchins
the chair recognized mr hutchinson
mr chief justice how much time has
expired
12 minutes 12 minutes
mr chief justice
ladies and gentlemen the senate
in my former life when i tried cases the
defense counsel would routinely offer a
motion to dismiss and my clients would
get excited and ask how they could argue
to dismiss a case before we've had a
chance to present evidence
i would always explain that there's more
more than sufficient evidence to get
this case to a jury and you don't have
to worry
we all know that granting a motion to
dismiss
is a weapon that is rarely used in court
it is a severe remedy that cuts off an
individual's right to seek justice in
court
for that reason a motion to dismiss must
fail if there's any substantial evidence
to support the case
in addition as you evaluate evidence
under a motion to dismiss the facts are
to be considered in a way that's most
favorable
to the respondents in that case the
house managers for example if there's a
dispute between the testimony of miss
lewinsky and the president and
consideration of this i would urge you
and believe that under
proper rules that you should consider
that in the favor
of the theory of the articles of
impeachment
now it has been explained to me
many times that standard courtroom rules
do not apply in the united states senate
but still granting a motion to dismiss
by the senate has the same effect to cut
short the trial and avoid the
development of the facts as it would in
any state court case
and in this case of impeachment the
house of representatives found that
there was substantial evidence to
support these articles and the senate
should not summarily dismiss the charges
and i might add that despite mr ruff's
references that the house standard for
the article's impeachment was not simply
probable cause my colleagues judiciary
committee looked at a much higher
standard of clear and convincing
evidence but coming back to the senate
to dismiss the case would be
unprecedented from a historical
standpoint because it's never been done
before it would be damaging to the
constitution because the constit the
senate would fail to try the case
it would be harmful to the body politic
because there is no resolution of the
issues of the case but most importantly
it would show willful blindness to the
evidentiary record that has thus far
been presented
now
an appropriate question that you might
ask is how should you decide whether
this motion should be granted i would
contend that you should decide this
issue based upon the facts that you have
before you and the record and not on any
other criteria a motion to dismiss
should not be granted because you do not
think there are presently enough votes
for conviction
now
let me assure you that i want this over
as bruce lindsey sitting over here will
probably attest this is bad for me
politically i'm from arkansas
the state bill clinton dominated
politically for years and certainly our
most influential politician but we do
have our responsibilities and i happen
to believe that we should follow the
process which is dictated by the
constitution and the facts i know i'm
making legal arguments to this court of
impeachment which i understand you make
your own rules and i respect that but as
opposing counsel as i pointed out on
many occasions there are reasons for
these rules of procedure and they have
relevance to your deliberation today
again your decision should be based upon
the facts and so let's discuss the facts
does the record
support
the charges of obstruction of justice
and perjury to look at this from a
different angle because we've talked
about it at length let's examine how the
president responded to critical
developments in the federal civil rights
case in which he was a defendant
first how did he handle those people he
knew to be witnesses
the president did not want them to
testify and if they did
testify he did not want them to testify
truthfully
two of those witnesses were monica
lewinsky and betty curry
clearly he did not want them to testify
in the federal civil rights case and
likewise his lawyers today do not want
those witnesses to testify before this
body
now let's look at what happened when the
president learned that monica lewinsky
was on the witness list
very quickly it was december 5 that the
witness list came in
he learned about it probably the next
day december 6.
monica lewinsky visited with him said
vernon jordan was not doing very much on
the job front the president response is
okay i'll talk to him i'll get on it
now miss lewinsky assumed that was a
brush off but he was serious about it
because
he later learned that day
that at the latest he learned later that
day that monica was on the witness list
when he met with the lawyers
after that the next day he meets with
vernon jordan at the white house and
even though mr jordan says he thinks it
was unlikely that the job situation was
discussed mr jordan makes it clear that
he ultimately went to work to get miss
lewinsky a job at the direction of the
president
according to mr jordan's grand jury
testimony on june 9 he testified the
president asked me to get monica
lewinsky a job that is undisputed he
testified in the same grand jury he
referring to the president is the source
of it coming to my attention in the
first place
and so as the result of the president's
request vernon jordan got to work met
with miss lewinsky assisted her in
securing key job interviews and kept the
president informed the job search became
critical when she was put on the witness
list on december 5 and the december 11
order of judge wright served to
reinforce the urgency of the matter
now all of this was happening when the
president knew she was a witness in the
civil rights case but the individuals
affected by the president's unlawful
scheme of obstruction may not have been
privy to his plans he can't miss lindsky
miss lewinsky in the dark about her
being a witness until
he had the job search well underway
and mr jordan indicates that he was
simply trying to get miss lewinsky a job
at the direction of the president
without any clue that she was a witness
until she got the subpoena on december
19th
now the president kept this information
about miss lewinsky on the list
away from her
until he called her at 2 a.m in the
morning on december 17 and to let her
know the news
so how does the president handle
witnesses in the judicial system that
are a danger to him he wanted to make
sure that they were taken care of and
cooperative and concealing the truth
from the courts the next critical step
for the president to assure that miss
lewinsky sticks with the her
pre-designed cover stories
was that she would not deviate from that
even though they were now in the court
system
vernon jordan testified
in the grand jury that it didn't take an
einstein to know that when she was under
subpoena the circumstances changed and
of course that is clear
when miss lewinsky was placed on the
witness list the truth became a threat
to the president he tried to avoid the
truth at all cost and was willing to
obstruct the legal processes of the
judicial system in order to protect
himself
the obstruction started with the job
favors and then continued through the
december 17th conversation with the
president
when the president encouraged her to
keep using the cover stories even though
she would be under oath as a witness
encourage her to sign a false affidavit
and then on december 28th according to
the testimony of miss lewinsky the
president
sent betty curry to retrieve items of
evidence for the purpose of concealment
and with the obvious effect of
obstructing the truth
despite the concerted effort of the
president in keeping monica lewinsky
from being a truthful witness the
president was not yet home free he still
had to go through the hurdle of his own
deposition on january 17th
and even though he knew that there were
going to be questions about monica
lewinsky he was hopeful that the false
affidavit the representations of his
attorney robert bennett and the
president's own affirmation of the false
affidavit would be sufficient to prevent
questioning about ms lewinsky
but it didn't work
despite this effort the federal district
court judge ordered the president to
respond to the questions at that point
he had a choice
he could tell the truth under oath or he
could provide false statements he chose
the latter and that decision forced a
continued pattern of obstruction
during the deposition he asserted the
name of betty curry at least six times
and by so doing so he dared the
plaintiff's lawyers to question ms curry
as a witness
they knew it
and he knew it
when the jones lawyers returned from the
deposition they immediately set about
issuing a subpoena for betty curry and
what the president did do
he immediately set about attempting to
assure that betty curry would not state
the truth when called as a witness
they defended this that was she wasn't a
witness she wasn't a prospective witness
but yet we produced the subpoena that
she was
a prospective witness and they wanted
her to testify and everyone knew it the
president called her at home arranged
for her to come in the next day put her
through the questioning
he was never alone with monica trying to
establish that that she that monica was
the aggressor and that the president did
nothing wrong that was what he was
trying to accomplish through his
questioning of betty curry can you
imagine how uncomfortable
betty curry was must have felt on that
occasion
being called in to see her boss
then having the president recreate a
fictional account in order to prevent
the truth from coming out in a court of
law
but once was not enough and two days
later miss betty curry was brought in
for the same series of questions the
message was clear
you've got to cover for the president
even though the purpose was unlawful
and so we see a pattern develop
when it comes to a witness whether it's
monica lewinsky or betty curry the
choices made the president encouraged
the witness to lie and the president
chose to impede the administration of
justice
rather than assuring that the laws be
faithfully executed
but the president had one final choice
and that was in his grand jury testimony
in august at this point the
embarrassment of the relationship was
public and that could no longer serve as
an excuse not to tell the truth
but once again the president chose not
to abide by his oath but to evade the
truth and provide false statements not
to protect his family not to preserve
the dignity of the presidency but to
prevent the grand jury from knowing the
truth in their investigation and to
continue the cover-up began during the
true seeking process in the civil rights
case
i do not have time to cover all the
facts but they are more than substantial
they are compelling and they are
convicting
let me leave you with some questions
first of all
who asked vernon jordan to get monica
lewinsky a job
the answer it was the president
secondly who suggested that monica
lewinsky sign an affidavit to avoid
testifying in the civil rights case
which by its nature had to be false the
answer
it was the president
who obstructed the truth when monica
lewinsky was subpoenaed as the witness
it was the president who impeded the
gathering of evidence when the federal
court subpoenaed called for the
production of gifts
the answer it was the president
who tampered with the testimony of betty
curry when it was clear she was a
witness in the case it was the president
who took an oath and failed to tell the
truth before the courts of our land
it was the president
i state these facts with sadness
but these facts are true
the motion should be defeated
i thank the senate
and behalf of the managers mr chief
justice i reserve the balance of the
time very well
the chair recognizes counsel for the
president
mr chief justice ladies and gentlemen of
the senate distinguished house managers
good afternoon
my name is nicole seligman i'm a member
of the law firm of williams and connolly
here in washington d.c
i've been privileged to represent
president clinton as personal counsel
since 1994.
i am honored to stand before you today
to argue in support of the motion to
dismiss the impeachment proceedings that
has been offered by the senior senator
from west virginia senator byrd
the constitution reposes in this body
and nowhere else
the sole authority to try impeachments
it has placed in your hands alone
the decision whether to dismiss now or
to go forward
there is no judicial review
there is no judicial guidance other than
that which each of you in your wisdom
may choose to apply by analogy from
judicial experience
there are no particular rules of civil
or criminal ex procedure that you must
follow the constitution has freed you
from that it has wisely placed in your
hands alone the ability to make a sound
judgment
in the manner you think best for the
reasons you think best
based on your wisdom and experience as
to what is best for this nation at this
moment in the proceedings
we submit to you that the moment has
arrived where the best interests of the
nation
the wise prescription of the framers
and the failure of the manager's proof
all point to dismissal
you have listened
you have heard
the case cannot be made
it is time to end it
without presuming to infringe on the
constitutional authority that is yours
alone
and without repeating at undue length
the arguments that you've heard over the
past few weeks i do want to set out
briefly the reasons that we believe an
early and fair disposition of this
difficult matter
on which they might rest there at least
four such grounds each one stands by
itself as sufficient reason to vote for
the motion of senator byrd
the first ground is the core
constitutional issue before you
the failure of the articles to charge
impeachable offenses
they do not do so
they do not allege conduct that if
proven violated the public trust in the
manner the framers intended when they
wrote the words treason bribery or other
high crimes and misdemeanors
for absent an element of immediate
danger to the state a danger of such
magnitude that it cannot await
resolution by the electorate in the
normal cycle
the framers intended restraint
there is no such danger to the state
here
no one has made that claim
or could
or would
a vote for the motion is a vote for
constitutional stability
impeachment was never meant to be just
another weapon in the arsenal of
partisanship
by definition a partisan split
like that which accompanied these
articles from the house of
representatives
creates doubt that makes plain the
constitutional error of the course that
we are on
as senator william pitt fessenden wrote
130 years ago on a great and decisive
historical occasion the impeachment
trial of andrew johnson
conviction upon impeachment should be
free from the taint of party
and leave no ground for suspicion upon
the motives of those who inflict the
penalty
his words echoed those of alexander
hamilton who in the much quoted
federalist 65 had warned in his words of
the greatest danger that the decision
that is the decision by the senate will
be regulated more by the comparative
strength
of the parties than by the real
demonstrations of innocence or guilt
now mr manager graham has candidly
acknowledged that reasonable people
could disagree about the propriety of
removal
he said they absolutely could
we suggest to you that there can be no
removal when even the prosecutor agrees
that such reasonable doubts exist
if reasonable people can disagree we
suggest to you that reasonable senators
should dismiss
the constitutional standard for
impeachment is not met here
the second and third grounds we offer to
you relate to the deeply flawed drafting
of the articles by the house of
representatives
they have left the house managers free
to fill what mr ruff described as an
empty vessel
to define for the house of
representatives what it really had in
mind when it impeached the president
but that is not a role that the
constitution allows to be delegated to
the house managers it is not a role that
the constitution allows them to fill
it is a role that is explicitly and
uniquely reserved to the full house of
representatives which under our
constitution has the sole power to
impeach
the articles also are unconstitutionally
defective for yet another reason
because each article combines a menu of
charges and the managers invite the
members of this body to convict on one
or more of the charges they list
the result is the deeply troubling
prospect that the president might be
convicted and removed from office
without two-thirds of the senate
agreeing on what the president actually
did
such a result would be in conflict with
the requirement that the president
cannot be convicted unless two-thirds of
this body concurs
the requirement of a two-thirds
supermajority is at the core of the
constitutional protection afforded the
president and the american people
the founding fathers were wise to
guarantee that protection and it has
protected the presidency for more than
two centuries
the house must not be allowed to erode
that protection today the articles as
drafted are unconstitutional
the fourth ground for the motion is
based on the facts
mr manager mccollum has twice asserted
that this body must first determine
whether the president committed crimes
and then move on to the question of
removal from office
recognizing that each senator
is free to choose the standard of proof
that his or her conscience dictates we
submit that if the question is as the
managers would have it whether the
president has committed a crime
that standard should be proof beyond a
reasonable doubt
and it is clear that such a standard
that is proof to the level of certainty
necessary to make the most significant
decisions you face in life
cannot possibly be met here
the presentations last week demonstrated
that the record is full of exculpatory
facts and deeply ambiguous
circumstantial evidence that will make
it impossible for the managers to meet
this standard or in fact any standard
that you might in good conscience choose
to apply here
now the managers have with great
ingenuity spun out theories of
wrongdoing that they have advanced
repeatedly persistently passionately
but mere repetition no matter how dogged
cannot create a reality where there is
none
the factual record is before you we
submit that it does not approach the
kind of case that you would need to
justify the conviction and removal of
the president from office
and calling witnesses is not the answer
all the evidence you need to make your
decision is before you
documented in thousands of pages of
testimony given under oath or to the fbi
agents and mr stars prosecutors under
penalty of law
these then are the foregrounds for the
motion to dismiss i know many of these
arguments are not new to you and i will
try to be brief as i review them
the question before this body requires
solemnity on all of our parts
it inevitably creates no small measure
of apprehension
in our nation's political history in our
legal history it is fair to say that few
decisions of such overwhelming magnitude
have been confronted by this body
there could be no matter more clearly
placed in your hands alone
by the constitution
and on its resolution rest more than the
political fate of william clinton
they arrest the course of our democracy
in the coming years of the new century
and for untold years thereafter
constitutional history confirms that the
decision decision before you was meant
to be significant
and difficult to make
it demonstrates that only the most
extraordinary of charges
warrants the most extraordinary of
outcomes
any question
any doubt
must be resolved in favor of the
electoral will
for it is the will of the people the
people who have all sovereignty in our
law that in the end is the foundation of
our democracy
and we submit that the doubt here is
pervasive
doubt about whether the charged conduct
efforts to conceal a private personal
could reasonably be deemed a violation
against the state at all let alone a
violation so severe as to compel removal
doubt about the constitutionality of the
articles as drafted
doubt about the sufficiency of the
manager's case
and that doubt upon doubt upon doubt
makes a vote to dismiss the only fair
choice
let me turn then to the fundamental
constitutional argument
the impeachment power was meant to
remove the president of the united
states from office
only for the most serious abuses of
official power or for misbehavior of
such magnitude that the collective
wisdom of the people would compel
immediate discharge
one of america's leading professors of
constitutional law professor aquila mar
of the yale law school has framed the
problem poignantly and concisely stating
the question to ask is whether president
clinton's misconduct is so serious and
malignant
as to justify undoing a national
election and cancelling the votes of
millions
we know the answer
it was provided by charles black in his
classic book on impeachment when he
wrote that and i quote impeachment and
removal should be reserved only for
offenses that so seriously threaten the
order of political society as to make
pestilent and dangerous the continuance
in power of their perpetrator
james madison made much the same point
two centuries earlier stating that an
impeachment provision of some kind was
indispensable because a president's loss
of capacity or corruption might be fatal
to the republic
the statements and writings of the
framers of our constitution and
centuries of scholarship on the meaning
of that brief but so significant phrase
high crimes and misdemeanors enable us
to establish with solid assurance that
the conduct charged against the
president does not amount to an
impeachable offense
our argument today is a simple one
ordinary civil and criminal wrongs may
be addressed through ordinary civil and
criminal processes
and ordinary political wrongs may be
addressed at the ballot box or by public
opinion
only the most serious public misconduct
aggravated abuses of executive power are
meant to be addressed through exercise
of the presidential impeachment power
the conduct here arises out of a private
lawsuit
let me talk for a moment about that
lawsuit that is the backdrop for these
proceedings
the jones case arose out of an alleged
incident that predated the president's
first term as president
the charges at issue here arise after
the out of the president's conduct in
that lawsuit no charge relates to his
official conduct as president
indeed as we know the supreme court told
president clinton that he could not
delay defending the jones lawsuit until
he was out of office and when it ruled
that way the court emphasized just this
very point
it made clear that he might have been
able to delay or avoid the lawsuit if it
had related to his official conduct
because the law provides various
immunities for such lawsuits but
precisely because it related to his
private actions
it would be allowed to go forward
in drawing that conclusion interestingly
the supreme court actually looked to the
wisdom of james wilson a framer a
supreme court justice and a
constitutional commentator and cited the
distinction he drew between a
president's acts performed in his public
character for which he might be
impeached according to justice wilson an
acts performed in his private character
to which the president is answerable as
any other citizen
in court
now we agree that there might be extreme
cases where private conduct would so
paralyze the president's ability to
govern that the impeachment power must
be exercised where the certainty of
guilt and the gravity of the charge
would leave no choice
but charges arising out of the
president's efforts to keep an
admittedly wrongful relationship secret
are by no analysis of that caliber
now some have suggested that making this
argument is the same as arguing that the
president is above the law
that simply is not so
the often
repeated statement that no man or woman
i should add is above the law is of
course true
once he leaves office the president is
as amenable to the law as any citizen
including for private conduct during his
term of office
as my colleagues mr ruff and mr craig
argued to you last week if a grand jury
should choose to consider charges
against this president his status as a
former president will not prevent that
consideration
but here's the point
impeachment is not meant to punish an
individual
it is a protection for the people
in alexander hamilton's words a remedy
for great injuries done to the society
itself
it is as your 19th century predecessor
senator garrett davis pointed out in the
andrew johnson proceedings the extreme
remedy intended for the worst political
disorders of the executive department
now the house managers appear to argue
that the president must be removed
nonetheless because to do otherwise
places him above the law
but there is one thing that can be said
with certainty about the impeachment
power
although it may have that result it is
not meant to punish the man to set an
example or to provide a cleansing of the
political process
it is meant to protect
the state
if it is punishment the house managers
seek
they are in the wrong place in the wrong
job at the wrong time and for the wrong
reasons
now a question has arisen whether as a
general matter
any violation of law demands removal
because it would be a violation of the
president's duty to take care that the
laws be faithfully executed or a breach
of the public trust
but again the history of the clause
makes clear that the framers
intentionally chose not to make all
crimes or even all felonies impeachable
i suggest we would all agree that in the
broadest possible sense a proven
violation of criminal law is a violation
of a public trust
but the framers consciously elected
not to make impeachment the remedy for
all crimes and misdemeanors when the
framers wished to address all crimes
they knew how to do it and they did it
in article 4 section 2 of the
constitution
the constitution states that and i quote
a person charged in any state with
treason felony or other crime
is susceptible to extradition
or other crime
the framers knew how to say it but they
didn't say it about impeachment because
that is not what they meant
some also have argued that the
experience of judicial impeachments in
this body undermines this argument
they claim the judges have been removed
for purely private conduct and that a
president should be treated no
differently
this argument completely misses the mark
as well
by constitutional design judges are very
different from a president
presidents are elected for a fixed term
while federal judges serve with life
tenure
presidents are elected by the people in
one of the great periodic exercises of
national will and their tenure is
blessed as the choice of the people
judges on the other hand are appointed
and confirmed by the representatives of
the people but their selection does not
represent a direct expression of the
will of the people
judges tenure is conditioned on good
behavior while that of a president is
not
and there is an obvious reason for this
distinction
life tenure
which was designed to assure judicial
independence plainly becomes a problem
in the event of a judge who is not fit
to serve
a president may be voted out by the
people a judge may not
hence the good behavior requirement and
the duty upon the congress to enforce it
in those exceptional cases where it must
be enforced
it is possible to debate forever
whether the good behavior clause
represents an independent basis for
impeachment or whether in the case of
judges it is a factor to be weighed when
this body exercises its sound judgment
to decide what constitutes a high crime
or misdemeanor
but there's no need to resolve that
that dispute here
either way it is clear as the watergate
impeachment inquiry report established
that the term high crimes and
misdemeanors is given content by the
context of the charge and the office at
issue
because of issues of legitimacy
accountability and tenure the framers
decided that federal judges needed the
additional check of the good behavior
clause
language they left out of the articles
creating congress and the presidency
and the presidency is of course
different
alexander hamilton said in federalist 79
that a judge could be impeached from
malconduct
but in the words of the watergate
impeachment inquiry report a report i
remind you that mr manager kennedy has
commended to your consideration
presidential impeachment is distinctive
the report stated and i quote because
it's an important quote because
impeachment of a president is a grave
step for the nation it is to be
predicated only upon conduct
seriously incompatible with either the
constitutional form and principles of
our government or the proper performance
of the constitutional duties of the
presidential office
the facts must be considered as a whole
in the context of the office the report
concludes the office matters
for judges the good behavior standard
comes in one way or the other for the
president the standard is different
as i mentioned mr manager graham
candidly acknowledged last saturday that
reasonable people could disagree as to
whether this president should be removed
from office
even if they believe he acted as charged
reasonable people could disagree
in this connection consider if you will
the words of senator william pitt
fessenden written 130 years ago
senator fessenden was one of the seven
brave republicans who crossed party
lines to vote against conviction of
president johnson in his 1868
impeachment trial
he wrote and i quote
the offense for which a chief magistrate
is removed from office should be of such
a character as to commend itself at once
to the minds of all right-thinking men
as beyond all question
and adequate cause
think about that phrase beyond all
question where there is room for
reasonable disagreement
there is no place for conviction
if many in this chamber and in this
nation believe that these charges do not
meet the bar of high crimes and
misdemeanors then the question must be
asked
why prolong this process
i'd like to turn briefly now to two
grounds for dismissal based on the
manner in which the house drafted these
articles
the first is that each article
each of the articles contains several
quite different charges the house
compounded its charges
it is tempting to ask i know how in a
matter of such importance we can urge
what might appear to be a procedural
highly technical argument like this one
there are several answers to that
the first is that it is neither
procedural nor highly technical it goes
to the very heart of our constitutional
protections and raises concerns about
fairness and the appearance of fairness
in this proceeding as so many senators
have so eloquently noted in the past
when the issue has arisen
as senator cole stated in the judge
nixon impeachment matter in which a
similar omnibus article was defeated and
i quote
the house is telling us it's okay to
convict judge nixon on article 3 even if
we have different visions of what he did
wrong
but that's not fair to judge nixon to
the senate or to the american people
let's say we do convict on article three
the american people to say nothing of
history would never know exactly which
of judge nixon's statements we regarded
as untrue
they'd have to guess
what's more this ambiguity would prevent
us from being totally accountable to the
voters for our decision
as the senator said
that's an unacceptable outcome one that
was quote not fair to judge nixon to the
senate or to the american people
judge nixon was acquitted on this
article
we suggest to you that the house is now
asking this senate to convict president
clinton on just such articles
and that's not fair either to president
clinton to this senate or to the
american people
the second response is that even if this
troubling problem were procedural
fair constitutional procedures go to the
heart of the rule of law
as the supreme court has stated the
history of liberty has largely been the
history of observance of procedural
safeguards it would indeed be ironic if
in the course of this proceeding in
which the vindication of the rule of law
has so often been invoked
this body were to ignore an important
procedural flaw
the legal basis for this argument is by
what now well known article 1 section 3
of the constitution provides that on
articles of impeachment no person shall
be convicted without the concurrence of
two-thirds of the members present
this requirement is plain there must be
in the language of the constitution
concurrence
which is to say genuine reliably
manifested agreement among those voting
to convict
without clarity on exactly what the
president would be convicted for there
can be no concurrence
these requirements of concurrence and a
two-thirds vote are the twin safeguards
of the framers plain intent to assure
that conviction not come easily
and let there be no doubt these articles
present textbook examples of a
prosecutorial grab bag
look at article 2 which by its terms
charges obstruction of the jones
litigation it presents six topics
related to the jones litigation and one
related to the very separate issue of
grand jury obstruction the first six
acts alleged are unrelated in time
or alleged intent to the seventh under
no conceivable theory are they part of
the same scheme and no one ever has
claimed them to be
but as it is drafted and as it must be
voted on by this body under the senate
rules the article would allow certain
senators to convict on obstruction of
the jones case
and others on grand jury obstruction
that is not concurrence
in a vote on an article as the
constitution demands it
an indictment against any american
drafted like these articles could not go
near the jury it would be dismissed and
no lesser standard should apply here
a second fatal flaw in the drafting is
their complete lack of specificity which
makes it impossible to know precisely
what the president is alleged to have
done wrong
this defect is most troublesome in the
article one perjury charges which never
simply state what the president said
that was allegedly projects
the defect is as plain and obvious a
constitutional one the house of
representatives has
unconstitutionally neglected its sole
power to impeach and delegated to the
house managers that which cannot
constitutionally be delegated the power
to decide what the house meant
the result has been what can charitably
be described as a fluid approach to the
identification of charges against the
president the house majority and its
managers have sought to add delete amend
expand and contract the list as this
matter has proceeded from mr starr to
the committee to the full house to this
body they also mystifyingly have
insisted on couching their charges as
examples
how on earth can an accused defend
against examples
where is the notice
where is the due process and no sooner
was this very concern raised here by mr
ruff then they did it again
this is quite extraordinary in response
to mr ruff's challenge the managers put
out a press release on january 19
purporting to list the allegedly
persuarious statements on which you are
to vote and what did they say they
offered more examples they said in
response
001 and i quote
here are four examples of project
statements made to the grand jury
ladies and gentlemen almost 40 years ago
the supreme court made clear that this
kind of charging is unacceptable when an
indictment leaves so much to the
imagination of individuals other than
the constitutionally designated charging
body
it must be dismissed
again
no lesser standard should apply here
our fourth ground for dismissal is based
on the facts
the evidence in the tens of thousands of
pages before you establishes that the
case against the president cannot be
proven with any acceptable degree of
certainty
the record is filled with too much that
is exculpatory
too much that is ambiguous
too much from the managers that requires
unfounded speculation
a very brief look at the articles and
the facts makes clear that in light of
the uncontested exculpatory facts such
as the direct denials from ms curry from
mr jordan and from ms lewinsky of
various alleged misconduct the managers
cannot possibly meet their burden of
proof here
look briefly at article one much of it
challenges the president's assertions of
his own state of mind his understanding
of a definition given to him his
understanding of the meaning of a word
his legal opinion of his jones testimony
his mindset during the statements of his
lawyer robert bennett the manager's
office speculation and theories about
these matters but you are not here to
try speculation and theories you are
here to try facts and the facts do not
support their theories
other claims in article 1 are so
insubstantial as to be frivolous and
unworthy of the time and attention of
this historic body
certain answers about the particulars of
the admitted intimate relationship
between the president and ms lewinsky
whether their admitted inappropriate
encounters were properly characterized
as occurring on certain occasions as but
one example could not possibly have had
any bearing on the star investigation
these answers were even irrelevant
immaterial to mr starr
remember in the grand jury the president
admitted to the relationship
admitted it was improper
admitted it occurred over time
admitted that he had sought to hide it
admitted he misled his wife his staff
his friends the country
but how it began
exactly when it began
how many intimate encounters there were
whether there were 11 or 17 or some
other number and with what frequency
these are details irrelevant to the star
investigation
and i must say irrelevant to your
decision whether he should whether to
remove the freely elected president of
the united states
there's been much discussion about the
jones deposition here and whether it too
is a part of article one the point is a
simple one the house of representatives
exercised its constitutional authority
and in a bipartisan vote defeated an
article of impeachment based on the
answers in the jones deposition
those answers are not before you
and the manager sleight of hand cannot
now put them back into article one
the article charges only the statements
made in the grand jury about that
deposition
the managers ask you to look at one
response the president's lawyerly
assertion that the jones deposition was
not legally perjurious however
frustrating or misleading and to read
that as an affirmation of every answer
he gave
but the grand jury testimony was must be
read as a whole
what did the president convey during
that testimony certainly not that he was
standing behind every word in the jones
deposition as the whole truth
he spent four hours in the grand jury
explaining that testimony adding to it
clarifying it discussing the confusing
deposition questions and answers and
pointing out his efforts to be literally
truthful if not forthcoming
explaining what he had tried to do the
line he had tried to walk however
successfully or unsuccessfully
he laid it all out he was not asked by
mr starr to reaffirm or adopt the
earlier testimony and he did not
reaffirm or adopt it
this brings us to the last issue in
article one the so-called touching issue
my colleague mr craig has talked at
length about the legal and practical
obstacles to a case based on an oath
against an oath
whether compelled by law or practice the
rule reflects the common sense
proposition that there will always be a
reasonable doubt as to the truth when a
case rests merely on an oath against an
oath
that's why seasoned prosecutors said the
house of representatives that they would
never bring such a case
that's why you need no more information
to conclude that conviction on that
basis will not be possible
the evidence also undermines the
allegations of article two
my colleagues ms mills and mr kendall
made a detailed review of the
allegations in each of the seven
subparts of article two they went over
the evidence in great detail and i'm
certainly not going to repeat that here
they pointed to the significant amount
of direct evidence in the record that
controverts the claims made in this
article most notably the consistent
statements by ms lewinsky that no one
ever asked suggested or encouraged her
to lie and that no one ever promised her
a job for her silence
they demonstrated that with regard to
the transfer of gifts the testimony of
miss lewinsky and miss curry has
consistently been inconsistent but that
even ms lewinsky has acknowledged it was
she who was concerned about the gifts
and who raised the issue with the
president
and the fact that the president gave
miss lewinsky more gifts on december 28
simply cannot be reconciled with any
theory of the manager's case
ms mills reviewed the evidence
concerning the president's conversation
with ms curry on the sunday after the
paula jones deposition
however ill-advised that conversation
might have been under the circumstances
it was not criminal
the president was motivated by his own
anxieties and by a desire to find out
what ms curry knew in anticipation of
the media storm he feared would break
as it surely did
contrary to the suggestion of mr manager
ms curry had not yet been subpoenaed at
the time of that conversation
miss curry was not on any jones case
witness list at the time of the
conversation
she testified that she felt absolutely
no pressure to change her account
during that conversation
she never testified that she felt
uncomfortable again contrary to the
suggestion of mr manager hutchinson
she was not a witness there was no
pressure there's a completely reasonable
explanation
let me be clear here there is no
evidence that the president ever asked
ms lewinsky to file a false affidavit or
told her to give false testimony if she
appeared as a witness
both believed ms lewinsky could file a
limited but true affidavit that might
might avoid a deposition in the jones
case
while the two had discussed cover
stories to explain ms lewinsky's visits
ms lewinsky never testified that they
discussed the cover stories in the
context of the possibility of her
testifying personally as article 2
alleges
now you have heard in detail from mr
craig and mr kendall about the fleeting
moment in the jones deposition when mr
bennett tried unsuccessfully to prevent
the president being questioned
about ms lewinsky by citing her
affidavit the judge immediately
overruled the objection it did not
obstruct in any way the jones lawyer's
ability to question the president
the statement had no effect
and the tape of the president cannot
disprove the president's testimony that
he wasn't paying attention he doesn't
comment concur or even nod
with a weak case at hand the managers
have tried to turn a blank stare
into a high crime
the last subpart of article 2 is flawed
in many respects the article alleges
obstruction of the jones case but the
president's misleading statements to his
white house aides about ms lewinsky had
no effect on that case at all and in any
event the effect of the president's
statements on his aids was no different
than on the millions of americans who
had heard and seen the president make
similar denials on television
and finally the subpart claims
obstruction of the grand jury whereas
the whole point of article 2 is alleged
obstruction of the jones case
as i asked before
what is it doing here
as to ms lewinsky's job search
all the managers have presented is a
theory a hypothesis in search of factual
support the direct evidence is clear and
uncontradicted ms lewinsky mr jordan the
president people at the new york city
companies ms lewinsky contacted all
testified that there was no relation of
any of the job search activity to the
jones case
none
not a single witness supports the
manager's theory
as we demonstrated their core theory
that the job assistance intensified
after the court's december 11 order
was based on plain and simple error
and without that support the theory
collapsed
no doubt the manager's response will be
that that's why witnesses are needed to
help the managers make their case
but witnesses will not fill the voids in
the evidence
first because the evidence as we have
shown is overwhelmingly uncontested
if there's no dispute why do witnesses
have to be questioned at all
house majority council shippers himself
made this point when speaking of the
very same transcripts and fbi interviews
that you all have before you
stated to the judiciary committee quote
as it stands all of the factual
witnesses are uncontradicted and amply
corroborated
second because the actual disagreements
for example what was in the president's
mind in his deposition are about
conclusions that must be drawn from the
undisputed evidence
not disputes in the evidence itself
more evidence will not inform a judgment
on the president's state of mind
and third because those witnesses with
testimony pertinent to the charges have
already repeated their testimony
again and again and again in some
instances five or ten times
over and over and over to fbi agents to
prosecute grand jurors
experienced career
trying to make their best case against
the president questioned scores of
witnesses they compiled tens of
thousands of pages of evidence they
questioned miss lewinsky on at least 22
separate occasions they questioned mr
jordan on at least five occasions they
questioned ms curry on at least eight
occasions on one day alone july 22nd
1998
prosecutors asked ms curry more than 850
questions and that was only one of her
five appearances before the grand jury
or fbi agents
and they did in fact contrary to the
suggestion of the managers question
witnesses including ms lewinsky after
the president's testimony to the grand
jury
and these witnesses whom i've mentioned
who were questioned repeatedly are not
alone
they cannot
possibly add to their testimony or amend
it in any significant way that could
alter the judgment you could make today
yet it is the hope that these witnesses
will be forced to change their testimony
to provide evidence where there now is
none that drives the current desire to
question them
let me make a few final points about
this witness issue
bring in witnesses to rehash testimony
that's already concretely in the record
would be a waste of time and serve no
purpose at all
that's our argument
but those are not my words
they are the words of mr manager gigas
spoken just last fall talking about the
same factual record you have before you
and mr manager gigas was correct
we had sixty thousand pages of testimony
from the grand jury from depositions
from statements under oath
that is testimony that we can believe
and accept
why reinterview betty curry to take
another statement when we already had
her statement
why interview monica lewinsky when we
had her statement under oath and with a
grant of immunity that if she lied she
would forfeit
again that's our argument but again
those are not my words those are the
words of chairman hyde and he too was
correct
those words apply with equal force today
the witnesses are on the record
their testimony is known
there is no need to put them through the
ordeal of testimony again
the house managers no doubt will answer
that that was then this is now
but that's not good enough
the house had a constitutional duty to
gather and assess evidence and testimony
and come to a judgment as to whether it
believed the president should be removed
from office
not to casually and passively serve as a
conveyor belt between ken starr and the
united states senate
not to ask this body to do the work the
house failed to do
the actual power to remove the president
resides here of course but the power to
take that first step rests with the
house
and the house exercised it the articles
explicitly find that certain conduct
occurred and that that conduct warrants
removal from office and disqualification
to hold and enjoy any office of honor
trust or profit under the united states
if there was any doubt about the
testimony on which they based their
judgment in reaching that conclusion
such doubts should have been resolved
before any member rose to say i to an
article of impeachment
calling for the first time in 130 years
for the senate to decide on the removal
of the president
the president did not obstruct justice
the president did not commit perjury the
president must not be removed the facts
do not permit it
now ladies and gentlemen of the senate i
hope i've outlined clearly for you
some of the many valid grounds on which
you might base a decision to vote for
the motion offered by senator byrd
on constitutional grounds the matters
simply don't meet the test of high
crimes and misdemeanors as specified by
the framers or interpreted by hundreds
of historians
as a matter of law these articles are
defective
in a court they would be dismissed in a
heartbeat for vagueness and for being
prosecutorial grab bags
the evidence itself after being gathered
in what may be one of the largest
criminal investigations in this
country's history fails to offer a
compelling case and is based largely on
weak inferences from circumstantial
evidence
each of these is reason enough to end
this trial now
without further proceedings
as senator bumper said more personally
and eloquently than i could hope to the
president has been punished
he is being punished still
as a man
as a husband
as a father as a public figure
beyond his family you have been reminded
that the criminal law
will still have jurisdiction over bill
clinton the day he leaves office
and while i am confident the case would
have no merit in a court of law
that is the venue in which justice may
be sought against an individual
so the sole question you are faced with
is the most important one
do you for the first time in 210 years
of our freedom
set aside the ultimate expression of a
free people
and exercise your power to remove the
one national leader selected by all of
us
if you don't believe this body should
remove the president
or if you believe that no amount of
re-questioning witnesses or torturing
facts will change enough minds to garner
the two-thirds majority necessary to
remove the president or if you simply
have heard enough to make up your mind
then the time to end this
is now
the president has expressed many times
how very sorry he is for what he did
and for what he said
he knows full well that his failings
have landed us in this place
and he is doing all he can to set right
what he has done wrong but the entire
nation
indeed the world
is now looking to this body
to this chamber to this floor
for sound judgment
and we are asking you
not to answer a serious personal wrong
with a grievous constitutional wrong
when we ask you to vote for senator
byrd's motion to dismiss
we do not mean that nothing ever
happened
that this is no big deal
and that's where we lawyers have done a
disservice to the language
because this is a big deal a very big
deal
punishment will be found elsewhere
judgment will be found elsewhere
legacies will be written elsewhere
none of that will be dismissed
none of that can ever be dismissed
we ask you to end this case now
so that a sense of proportionality can
be put back into a process that seems
long ago to have lost all sense of
proportionality
we also ask you to end the case now so
those family members and others who did
no wrong
can be spared further public
embarrassment
and we also ask you to end this case now
so that the poisonous arrows of
partisanship can be buried
and the will of the people can be done
allowing all of you to spend your full
days on the most pressing issues of the
country
you have heard the charges in fall
heard the defense
now is the time to define
how the national interest can best be
served
by extending this matter indefinitely
or ending it now
we submit that it is truly in the best
interests of this nation
to end this ordeal
in this chamber
at this time
and in this way
thank you
mr chief justice
the chair recognizes the majority leader
could i inquire
is there further presentation from the
white house council or uh
time be used for uh the concluding
remarks by the house manager the white
house council have six minutes remaining
and the managers have reserved 36
minutes
there will be no further presentation in
view that mr chief justice i understand
that the the white house council would
have no further presentation to make so
that what's left would be the concluding
remarks by the house managers and i'd
like for us when that's concluded to go
right into the boats in view of that i
think it'd be a good idea to take a 15
minute break at this point i asked for
that
in the absence of objection it's so
ordered
their session momentarily
the senate will be in order
the chair recognizes the majority leader
mr chief justice i believe we're ready
now for the closing part of the argument
by the house managers on the motion to
dismiss
the chair recognizes the house managers
mr hutchinson
thank you mr chief justice senators uh
my fellow manager graham has extended me
for a few minutes before he comes up
here just to allow me to respond to a
couple factual assertions
by the white house counselors during
the recent presentation i know that
there was a reference made to the
impeachment proceedings of
of
former president nixon
and
there are various articles that were
considered but one of them that i don't
believe was talked about was obstruction
of justice
and i believe that the senators in this
chamber would agree that obstruction of
justice has historically been
a basis for impeachment of public
officials because
of the impact that it has on the
administration of justice and that was
historically true
during the time of the impeachment of
president nixon
it was an issue during that time and it
should be no less of a concern
this year in 1999.
now
when i listen to
a defense attorney make a presentation
oftentimes i listen to what they didn't
cover as much as what they did cover
and you always have to go back to that
because many times that points to a big
gap of something they just can't explain
if i listen to the presentation
of course they addressed the assertion
that miss curry ms betty curry was in
fact not a witness at the time the
president called her in and went through
the questioning of her after his
deposition on january 17th but yet it's
been clearly established that she was a
known witness at the time
now they hoped they prayed they wished
they counted for the fact that that
subpoena would never be uncovered but
the subpoena was uncovered the fact was
established that she was put on the
witness list and that she was a known
witness at the time but the fact is it
does not matter she was a perspective
witness and that was what the president
did when he came back and talked to her
but what has never been addressed has
never been addressed is why in the world
did the president believe he needed to
talk to her a second time
it was one time that questioning but two
days later she was brought in
and taken through the same paces
the the answer was well he explained it
well he tried to explain why he did it
the first time he was trying to get
information there can be no explanation
for the second instance of when she was
called in and questioned she was a
witness she was a known witness and she
had to be talked to and it was done
twice
another thing that i do not recall ever
being mentioned they argue that well
there is no evidence of favors on a job
search and i believe that is not
supported by the record how many times
has the president's attorneys discussed
the description
and the report
by mr vernon jordan
to the president
mission accomplished i do not believe
they've ever discussed that particular
terminology i do not believe they've
ever discussed the terminology their
call from mr vernon jordan to mr
pearlman saying
make it happen if it can happen
and so i think that there's some gaps in
their defenses and clearly you
understand that the facts have supported
each of the allegations of obstruction
that we have set forth
they argue that well there was no
evidence of any false affidavit well
there's evidence that an affidavit was
encouraged by the president of the
united states he suggested the affidavit
and as of a necessity would have to be
false it was going to be accomplishing
the intended purpose
they're asking you
in this motion to
dismiss
to ignore the evidence that we have
presented
to ignore the testimony the documentary
evidence to ignore the common sense and
simply to accept the denials of the
president of the united states that's
not what a motion to dismiss is about we
ask that we move forward to consider
the full development of these facts i
yield to mr graham to suspend the rules
the chair recognized mr graham
thank you miss chief justice uh how much
time do we have
oh the house managers have 32 minutes
remaining thank you miss chief justice
uh to my colleagues my chairman wants
11 minutes for my own sake please let me
know when we get close
now
we meet again
to discuss
a very very important event in our
nation's history
to dismiss an impeachment trial
under these facts
and under these circumstances
would be unbelievable
in my opinion
and do a lot of damage to the law
into the ultimate decision this body has
to make whether or not bill clinton
should be our president and as i
understand
the general nature of the law the facts
and the law break our way for this
motion
what i would like to discuss with you
is whether or not
a reasonable person
could believe that bill clinton should
not be our president
and the facts
that have been presented
rise to the level of creating serious
doubts about whether he's a criminal
not just a bad man
who did bad things
for he's a good man in some ways as all
of us are
and he's done some things that everybody
in this body will condemn roundly
america needs no more lectures
about bill clinton's misconduct
about his inappropriate relationship
we need no more lectures about his sins
we all have those
we need to resolve as our president
a criminal
that's harsh
but do the facts bear out those
statements
when you dismiss the judges
for perjury and filing statements under
oath
some of you said some very harsh things
about those judges
not because you're harsh people
but because their conduct warranted it
one thing i am not going to say
and i will quit this job before i do
this
is i'm not going to run over anybody's
conscience
when they're exercising it
as they deem appropriate for the good of
this nation
my name has been brought up a couple
times
about whether or not reasonable people
can disagree with me and still be
reasonable
about what we should do in this case
i have told you the best i can there's
no doubt these are high crimes in my
opinion and this is a hard decision for
our country but when i first spoke to
you i thought we would be better off if
bill clinton left office
and i want the chance to prove to you
why
give me a chance to prove to you why i
believe that why my colleagues voted our
conscience to get this case to where it
should be not swept under or rug but in
a trial to disposition i have lost no
sleep
worrying about the fact that bill
clinton may have to be removed from
office because of his conduct i have
lost tons of sleep thinking he may get
away with what he did
but the question was
could you disagree with lindsey graham
and be a good american in essence
absolutely
you can disagree with me on abortion and
mr hyde and i am not going to trample on
who you are
because i know that the liberal wing of
the democratic party the moderate wing
of the conservative of the republican
party has different views than i do
but i didn't come up here to run you
down
i came up here to build my country up
the way i think it needs to be built up
ladies and gentlemen of the senate
if you will listen to our case if you
let us explain why we have lost no sleep
asking for this present to be removed
and while we voted to get it here and
you disagree with me at the end of the
day i will never
ever
say you don't love your country as much
as i do that's what that statement was
meant to convey and it will convey that
until i am
dead and gone
now
the idea that 130 years ago
a senator took a vote
and made a statement
that only way you can remove a president
is it's got to be unquestionable
in anybody's mind
tells me he sure thought a lot of
himself
and i'm glad to see that stopped in the
senate 130 years later we don't have
people like that anymore
what that conveyed to me
was that a person made a hard decision
and tried to create a standard that
slams somebody else who came out
differently
i hope that's not what this is all about
he goes down in history but i wouldn't
want that
as part of my epitaph that when i voted
my conscience
i reached a level that
that if you didn't go where i was
there's something wrong with you
what did bill clinton do
and why are we all here
are we here because
of ken starr because of lindsey graham
because of
why are we here
we're here because of william jefferson
clinton in my opinion
we're here because on our watch in the
house
the president of the united states
when he was a defendant in a lawsuit
instead of trusting the legal system to
get it right
did everything possible in my opinion to
undermine the rule of law
including going to a grand jury in
august of last year
and committing perjury
after people in this body and prominent
americans say said stop it
and now we're here to say
well we really didn't mean it the motion
to dismiss means we're sort of just
kidding mr president
now
if you believe he is not guilty of these
offenses
based on this stage of the trial
then you ought to grant the motion for
dismiss but you will be changing the law
as we know it today we haven't had a
chance to present our case really
and all the facts should break our way
you can believe this if you would like
they stood up here and argued that the
conversation between
president clinton and his secretary
betty curry was to find out what she
knew
to refresh his memory
if you
think that when the president goes to
betty curry and asks makes the following
statement monica wanted to have sex with
me
and i couldn't do that
that he's trying to figure out what she
knew
is trying to refresh his memory you can
do that
i would suggest
that ain't reasonable
if you believe
that he wanted to figure out whether he
was alone or not with her and he had to
ask betty
that's not reasonable
that's a crime
let me tell you the subtleties of this
case
things that really tell you a lot about
why we're here william jefferson clinton
before we get to the subtle disease of
this case
senator bumpers made a very eloquent
speech
about
the ups and the downs of this case and
about his relationship with the
president and how close it was and the
human nature of what's going on here but
here's what he said
you pick your own adjective describe the
president's conduct here's some that i
would use indefensible outrageous
unforgivable shameless
how about illegal
and he says i promise you the president
would not contest any of these or any
others
when you put the word illegal
everything's a big misunderstanding
take this case to a conclusion so
america will not be confused as to
whether or not their president committed
crimes
there will be people watching what we do
here
and they will be confused as whether or
not the conversation between president
clinton and miss curry was illegal or
not
let us know
that is so important let us know when he
went to monica lewinsky and talked about
a cover story if that's what we want to
go on here every day and a trial 20
months from now does us no good
because this happened when he was
president ladies and gentlemen
this happened when he raised the defense
you can't sue me because i'm president
and what did he do after that defense
was taken away from by the supreme court
he went back
to somebody that is very loyal to him
somebody that admires him somebody that
you and i pay our salary his secretary
and he put her in a situation
through misleading her
that she was going to pass on his lies
that's not what we pay her to do
he put her in a situation where she was
going to incur legal costs
because he cared more about himself
than he did his secretary
he put his cabinet members
he put the people at work for him
in a horrible spot
the subtleties of this case
let me tell you one of the subtleties of
this case
and this was read by the defense in this
case
the president had a follow-up
conversation with mr morris during the
evening of january 22 1998 when mr mars
was considered holding a press
conference
to blast monica lewinsky out of the
water
the president told mr morris to be
careful
according to mr morris the president
warned him not to be too hard on miss
lewinsky because there's some slight
chance that she she may not be
cooperating with star and we don't want
to alienate her about anything we're
going to put out
[Applause]
and they were trying to tell you that
ain't bad
that's a good thing
the best you can get from that statement
is the president when approached with
the idea of blasting her said let's wait
the subtleties in this case who is this
young lady his consensual lover
but this case started not about
consensual loving
this stays case started about something
far from consensual loving
this case started about something like
a senator who ran into problems with
y'all
and if you'll let us develop our case
you may have a hard time reconciling
those two decisions
but that is up to you please don't
dismiss this case for the good of this
country for the good of the law let us
get to what happened here
john podesta
the subtleties of this case
he talked to him about what happened he
said i had no relationship with her
whatever
everybody that went into that grand jury
that talked to bill clinton was lied to
and they passed those lies on to a
federal grand jury and you know what in
america that's a crime even if you're
president and you need to address
whether that happened or not don't
dismiss this case
but you know what is even more subtle
is that john podesta somebody who's very
close to him
once he said nothing happened
felt a need to ask one more question
and pardon me for saying this does that
include oral sex
that says a lot about what mr podesta
thinks about mr clinton
because he felt like he had to go one
step further
and in his grand jury testimony he tells
us the president took that behavior off
the table
and some of you are worried about the
perjury charge in this case
let me tell you right now you should
have no worries because you got a
dilemma on your hands that's easy to
resolve in terms of whether or not the
president committed purging the grand
jury
if you believe
that he said that he was truthful when
he said i never lied or i was always
truthful to my subordinates
to the people that worked for me to my
aides
then when he told john podesta our
relationship did not include oral sex
he was being truthful
if he was being truthful to john podesta
he lied through his teeth about
everything else in the grand jury when
he considered
or when he when he approached the grand
jury with the idea that our relationship
was of one kind of sex but not the other
he told john podesta it wasn't there at
all
you pick the lie
but it's there
and if you can reconcile that you're
better than i am and that's up to y'all
and does it really matter so what
i think it matters a great deal
if you're sued for sexually harassing
somebody
and they are owned to the fact that you
can't control yourself enough to stop it
four or five years after you're sued and
you're doing it in the white house with
somebody half your age i think that
would matter
maybe that's the difference between
getting bamboozled in court having to
pay 850 000
people are gonna be confused if we don't
bring this case to a conclusion
i suggest to you it matters a great deal
that if any major ceo any low-level
employee of any business in this country
would have been tossed out for something
like that but i know he's the president
electing somebody
should not distance them from common
decency and the rule of law to the point
that when it's all over with you don't
know what you got left in this country
is that what you want to do in this case
just to save this man
to ignore the facts to have a different
legal standard
to make excuses that are bleeding this
country dry
the effect of this case is hurting us
more than we will ever ever know
don't dismiss this case find out who our
president is come on come to the
conclusion not that it's just bad
behavior it was illegal behavior tell us
what's right tell us what's wrong
give us some guidance
under our constitution you don't impeach
people at the ballot box you trust the
united states senate
and i am willing to do that rise to the
occasion for the good of the nation
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
do the house managers have any
additional presentation
the chair recognizes mr hyde
thank you mr chief justice
mr ruff
council and distinguished senators
i want to be very candid with you and
that may
involve
diplomatic breaches because i am
parliamentarily illiterate
but nonetheless
i looked at this motion to dismiss and i
was astounded really
if the senate had sent something
similar to the house it would certainly
have received
such treatment as comports with comity
and i
don't know enough about comety to
wave that flag but i don't want to wave
my rights to raise that issue anyway but
i know black's law dictionary is a
resource book for all of us
but i looked in the thesaurus about
dismiss
and i came up with disregard
ignore
brush off
and
i just was surprised
that this motion is here now before
we conclude the case
some years ago when i was trying
lawsuits i appeared before a judge in
chicago with an
my opponent was an old-timer who was
just mean
it's a good lawyer but he was mean
and the judge interrupted him in one
tirade and he said council
i have a lot of respect for you
i wish you had a little respect for this
court
and
i sort of feel that way i
i sort of feel that
we have fallen short in the
respect side because of the fact that we
represent the house
the other body
kind of blue collar people and uh
we're over here trying to survive with
our
impeachment articles
the most salient
reason
for
defeating this motion
is article 1 section 3 of the
constitution which
says that the senate shall have the sole
power to try
to try
all impeachments
now a trial as i understand it
is a search for truth
and it should not
be trumped by a
search for an exit strategy
it seems to me this motion
elevates convenience over constitutional
process and by implication ratifies
an unusual extension of sovereign
immunity
if these articles are dismissed
all
inferences in support of the respondents
in support of us the managers
should be allowed
and
if you allow all reasonable inferences
in our favor what kind of a message does
it send to america to dismiss the
articles of impeachment
charges of perjury obstruction of
justice are summarily dismissed
disregarded ignored brushed off
and these are charges that send ordinary
folk to jail
every day of the week and remove federal
judges
but i can see this president is
different
but if the double standard is to
flourish on capitol hill
i don't think we've accomplished a great
deal
yes
it's cumbersome
these proceedings are archaic in many
ways the question period was
something out of
old bailey i guess i don't know
but democracy is untidy i'll stipulate
that it is untidy
but it is
also a blessing
impeachment and trial by the senate
were devised by our framers to make this
difficult process
as definitive
as possible let's get the matter behind
us that's a mantra that's a cliche we
all say it
you won't get it behind you
if you dismiss this without voting on
the articles
you guarantee contention
you will never get it behind us
vote these articles up or down that's
the only way they really get it behind
it
what this is this
motion
is a legal
way of saying so what
to the charges that we've levied here
now look at what these charges are so
what that the president violated his
oath of office and willfully corrupted
and manipulated the judicial process for
his personal gain and exoneration
so what
that president clinton willfully
provided for jurious false and
misleading testimony of the grand jury
on several topics so what that the
president corruptly encouraged to
witness
in a federal civil rights action brought
against him to execute a sworn affidavit
in that proceeding that he knew to be
perjurious false and misleading
so what that the president encouraged a
witness to lie to the grand jury and
conceal evidence
so what if the president has undermined
the integrity of his office has brought
disrepute on the presidency has betrayed
his trust as president and has acted in
a manner subversive of the rule of law
and justice to the manifest injury of
the people of the united states that's
an awful lot to dismiss with a brush off
to ignore
with the mirror so what
no uh
it may be routine we certainly don't
have enough experience in these
impeachment matters and thank god for
that
it may be routine to file a motion to
dismiss
but i take very seriously a motion to
dismiss especially
when
it
is offered by the very distinguished
senator who did that
but i hope
in a bipartisan way i would hope some
democrats would support
a rejection of this motion difficult as
it is because i don't think this whole
sad sad drama will end
we will never get it behind us until you
vote up or down
on the articles and when you do however
you vote
we'll all collect our papers
bow from the waist thank you for your
courtesy and leave
and go gently into the night
but let us finish our job thank you
mr chief justice
parliamentary inquiry mr chief justice
uh the chair recognized the majority i
believe uh under the agreement we
entered into the next order of business
then would be
the vote on
uh
the motion by senator harkin to go into
uh
open session is that correct
yeah
the the managers have used their time
the chair recognizes the senator from
iowa mr harkin
mr chief justice in accordance with rule
5 of the senate standing rules
i and mr wellstone filed a notice of
intent
to move to suspend the rules solely
regarding the debate by senators on the
motion to dismiss
so senators could have an open rather
than a close debate on this issue
my motion is at the desk however mr
chief justice i sent it corrected a copy
of my emotion the deaths there were two
typos in it i just wanted to have it
corrected
mr chief justice the the chair
recognized the majority leader uh
if it's appropriate to this uh point i
would like to
ask the senators if they would remain at
their desk so we could go through this
vote and i would ask unanimous consent
since we're all here they will reduce
the time for the boat
from 15 minutes to 10 minutes
is there objection
without objection it's so ordered
is there objection to the senator from
iowa modifying his motion
without objection it's
modified the clerk will read the motion
senator iowa mr harkin for himself and
mr wellstone moves to suspend the
following portions of the rules of
procedure and practice in the senate
when sitting on impeachment trials
in regard to debate by senators on a
motion to dismiss during the trial of
president william jefferson clinton
number one the phrase quote without
debate end quote in rule seven
number two the following portion of rule
quote unless the senate shall direct the
doors to be closed while deliberating
its decisions a motion to close the
doors may be acted upon without
objection or if objection is heard the
motion shall be voted on without debate
by the yeas and a's which shall be
entered on the record close quote
number three in rule 24 the phrases
quote without debate close quote except
when the door shall be closed for
deliberation and in that case close
quote
and quote to be had without debate close
quote
mr chief justice i asked the yeas and
ace
is there
sufficient second second
the the yeas and nays have been ordered
the clerk will call the roll
mr abraham
mr abraham no
mr akaka
mr akaka
i
mr allard
mr allard
no
mr ashcroft
mr ashcroft no
mr bacchus
mr bacchus
no
mr bai
mr bai
i mr bennett
mr bennett
no
mr biden
mr bingaman
mr bond
mr bond
no
mrs boxer
mrs boxer
i mr bro
mr bro
no
mr brownback
mr brownback
no
mr brian
mr brian
i
mr bunning
mr bunning
no
mr burns
mr burns
no
mr bird
mr bird
no
mr campbell
mr campbell
no
mr chafee
mr chafee
no
mr cleland
mr cleland
i
mr cochrane
mr cochrane
no
ms collins
ms collins i
mr conrad
mr conrad
i
mr coverdell
mr coverdell
no
mr craig
mr craig
no
mr cripo
mr crapo
no
mr daschle
mr daschle
i
mr dewine
mr dewine
no
mr dodd
mr dodd
i
mr domenici
mr domenici
no
mr dorgan
mr dorgan
i
mr durbin
mr durbin
aye
mr edwards
mr edwards
i
mr enzi
mr enzy
no
mr
feingold mr feingold
i
mrs feinstein
mrs feinstein
i
mr fitzgerald
mr fitzgerald
no
mr frist
mr frist
no
mr gordon
mr gorton
no
mr graham of florida
mr graham of florida
i
mr graham of texas
mr graham of texas
no
mr grahams of minnesota
mr grahams of minnesota
no
mr grassley
mr grassley
no
mr greg
mr greg
no
mr hegel
mr hegel
no
mr harkin
mr harkin
aye
mr hatch
mr hatch
no mr helms
mr helms
no
mr hollings
mr hollings
i
mr hutchinson of arkansas
mr hutchinson of arkansas
no
mrs hutchison of texas
mrs hutchison of texas
i
mr inhofe
mr inhofe
no
mr inouye
mr noa
aye
mr jeffords
mr jeffords
no
mr johnson
mr johnson
aye mr
kennedy mr kennedy
i mr kerry of nebraska
mr carey of nebraska
i mr carey of massachusetts
mr kerry of massachusetts
i
mr cole
mr cole
i
mr kyle
mr kyle
no
ms landrieu
ms landrieu
i
mr lautenberg
mr lautenberg
i
mr leahy
mr leahy
i mr levin
mr levin
i mr lieberman
mr lieberman
i
mrs lincoln
this is lincoln
no
mr lot
mr lot
no mr luger
mr luger
no
mr mack
mr mack
no mr mccain
mr mccain
no mr mcconnell
mr mcconnell
no ms mikulski
ms mikulski
i
mr moynihan
mr moynihan
i
mr murkowski
mr murkowski
no
mrs murray
mrs murray
i
mr nichols
mr nichols
no
mr reed of rhode island
mr reed of rhode island
i
mr reed of nevada
mr reed of nevada
i mr rob
mr rob
aye mr roberts
mr roberts
no mr rockefeller
mr rockefeller
no
mr roth
mr roth
no mr santorum
mr santorum
no
mr sarbanes
mr sarvanes
no
mr schumer
mr schumer
i mr sessions
mr sessions
no
mr shelby
mr shelby
no
mr smith of new hampshire
mr smith of new hampshire
no
mr smith of oregon
mr smith of oregon
no
ms snow
ms snow
no
mr specter
mr spector
i
mr stevens
mr stevens
no
mr thomas
mr thomas
no mr thompson
[Music]
mr thompson
no
mr thurman
mr thurman
no
mr torricelli
mr torricelli
aye
mr voynovich
mr voinovich
no
mr warner
mr warner
no
mr wellstone aye
mr wellstone
i mr wyden
mr wyden
i
mr biden
mr biden
aye mr bro
mr bro
i
are there any other senators wishing to
vote or to change their vote
if not
on this vote the yeas are 43 the nades
are 57.
two-thirds of those senators voting and
a quorum being present not having voted
in the affirmative the motion is not
agreed to
what now we move to close the door
so
so
as chief justice
air recognizes the senator from nevada
could we have order in the chamber
please
the senate will be in order
mr chief justice uh uh i move that we
now go into closed session for the
purpose of the senators debating the
motion to dismiss
all those who favor say aye
aye
all opposed nay
the eyes appear to have it the eyes do
have it
the motion is agreed to
the sergeant-at-arms will please close
the doors
mr chief this uh i ask uh consent that
we take a 10-minute break for the
purposes of closing the doors and
preparing for the debate
in the absence of objection it's so
ordered
be in session coming up next live gavel
to gavel coverage right here on c-span
2.
the senate will convene as a court of
impeachment the chaplain will offer a
prayer
gracious god
you not only guide our steps
you order our stops for quiet times of
prayer
we hear your words spoken through the
psalmist
be still and know that i am god
i will be exalted among the nations
i will be exalted in the earth
help us absorb the true meaning of these
words translating the original hebrew
you call us to let up to leave off to
let go
to truly know that you are god
you are in control
we cannot be still inside
until we reaffirm that you are in
control of us
this nation
and this senate
we exalt you el shaddai
all sufficient one
adenoid our lord
jehovah
our shepherd who guides
jehovah rapha
who heals our bodies and our
relationships
jehovah shema
god who is here
strengthen the senators
as they seek to exalt you
as these pages of american history are
written during this trial
you bless the nation
that exalts you
through him who taught us to seek first
your kingdom
and your righteousness
amen
amen
the sergeant-at-arms will make the
proclamation
hear ye hear ye hear ye
all persons are commanded to keep silent
on pain of imprisonment while the senate
of the united states is sitting for the
trial of the articles of impeachment
exhibited by the house of
representatives against william
jefferson clinton
president of the united states
if there's no objection the journal of
proceedings of the trial are approved to
date the chair recognizes the majority
leader
thank you mr chief justice now for the
information of all senators we are now
prepared to hear arguments regarding the
subpoenaing of witnesses and and the
taking of their depositions i understand
the house managers will submit the list
and begin their arguments the white
house counsel will then state their
arguments
with the house managers making the final
or closing statement this period
has been limited to four hours instead
of the six hours that had been earlier
indicated
i also expect a motion uh may be offered
again
to close the session uh with regard to
deliberations by the senators i need
some further consultation uh with
senator daschle to confirm that or not
it could be that we could work it out
without having to do the recorded vote
therefore though votes could occur this
evening
probably between 4 30 and 5 o'clock as
always uh we will expect to take a break
after about an hour and a half in the
proceedings
so that uh and it may be a little bit
longer than usual so that if senators
were not able to grab a quick bite they
might be able to grab a little something
in the in the cloak room during that
first break so it might be a little
longer than or ordinary and i expected
that would occur sometime around
1 30 approximately
before we begin uh since i see that
there are still a few senators not in
the chamber i would suggest the absence
of quorum mr chief justice the clerk
will call the roll mr abraham
okay
mr akaka
mr eller
[Music]
mr icecroft
mr baucus
mr bai
mr bennett
mr biden
mr bingaman
mr bond
this is boxer
mr bro
mr brownback
mr brian
mr money
mr chief justice
the chair recognizes the majority leader
guys that the quorum call be dispensed
with
without objection and if all senators
and uh council and managers would return
to their desks i believe we're ready to
begin
that's chief justice again just for the
information of all senators uh
what happens next is
i believe that the
manager will be recognized on behalf the
house to present a motion with regard to
the subpoenaing of witnesses and then
the presentations will begin
first by the house managers and then by
the white house council and then closed
by the house managers uh to be spread
over four hours but that at
approximately 1 30 we will take a break
so that we can
assess how we proceed the balance of the
day
and uh perhaps even get a bite to eat if
senators had not had that opportunity it
won't be an extended break but it'll be
a little bit more longer than normal i
believe we're ready to proceed mr chief
justice
uh
the chair recognizes mr manager bryant
on behalf of the managers
the manager will send the motion to the
desk
and the clerk will read the motion
motion of the united states house of
representatives for the appearance of
witnesses at a deposition and to admit
evidence not in the record
now comes the united states house of
representatives
by and through its duly authorized
managers
and respectfully submits to the united
states senate its motion for the
appearance of witnesses at a deposition
and to admit evidence not in the record
in connection with the impeachment trial
of william jefferson clinton president
of the united states
the house moves that the senate
authorize and issue subpoenas for the
appearance of the following witnesses at
a deposition for the purpose of
providing testimony related to the
impeachment trial
one monica s lewinsky
two vernon jordan
and three
sydney blumenthal
further the house moves that the senate
admit into evidence the following
material not currently in the record
one the affidavit of barry ward
law clerk to the honorable susan webber
wright
u.s district court judge for the eastern
district of arkansas
to the sworn declaration of t wesley
homes and attachments there too
and three certain telephone records
which document conversations between
monica s lewinsky and william jefferson
clinton including a 56-minute exchange
on december 6
1997.
additionally the house petitions the
senate to request the appearance
of william jefferson clinton president
of the united states at a deposition for
the purpose of providing testimony
related to the impeachment trial
pursuant to senate resolution 16 is
modified by the order of january 25th
the managers on the part of the house of
representatives and the council for the
president each have two hours to present
their arguments on this motion
the chair recognizes as mr manager
bryant
mr manager mccollum
mr chief justice and members of the
senate
we're here today to argue for the
presentation of witnesses
and i want to state at the outset a
couple of observations of mine regarding
this
the house managers have always
understood the senate sets the rules on
these matters and
and we don't question that fact
but i think it's important to set the
record clear here today to say at the
outset that we have always believed and
we still do believe that 10 or 12
witnesses are what we should have and
should have been permitted to call to
prove our case
we've estimated that this could be done
in a matter of two weeks at the outside
including all cross-examination
that's what we think the normal order
would have been it's what we think it
should have been but we've been told
again and again and we believe it's true
that if we made such a request it would
not be approved
and a few weeks ago we thought maybe
even a few days ago that we could submit
a list of maybe five or six witnesses
and there would be a reasonable chance
that
for deposition they would be approved
and maybe two or three of them could
actually be presented here live on the
floor
now we have been led to believe and we
think that it's an accurate assessment
that in order to get a vote to approve
the opportunity to take depositions
alone
whether or not anyone's called that we
cannot submit more than two or three
witnesses to you and that's what we've
done today
we have submitted a motion
for simply three witnesses monica
lewinsky vernon jordan and sydney
blumenthal
the two people who know the most about
this are monica lewinsky and president
william jefferson clinton
and while we have not submitted to you
today the name of president clinton in
our motion
we strongly urge
that if you allow us to have witnesses
which we believe you should that you in
addition or even if you don't on your
own
call president clinton here to testify
we think that it is exceedingly
important that you have an opportunity
and we have an opportunity for you to
examine him and these other witnesses to
get at the truth of this matter and to
end all the speculation that is resolved
around this matter and let you draw the
proper inferences and conclusions
i will simply say that i'm going to
to make a brief outline of of the matter
of why we should have witnesses for you
the three we are asking for uh and i'll
be followed in order so you can get some
sequence to this
by manager bryant who will discuss
in detail the reason why we think that
it's appropriate to call specifically
monica lewinsky
manager hutchinson who will discuss mr
jordan as a witness and manager rogan
who will discuss mr blumenthal
if our emotion is granted i want to make
this very very very clear
at no point
will we ask any questions of monica
lewinsky
about her explicit sexual relations with
the president either in deposition
or if we're permitted on the floor of
the house they will not be asked that of
course assumes that white house counsel
does not enter into that discussion and
we doubt that they would
secondly we do not see why the entire
process
of deposing and calling
all of these witnesses right here live
would have to take more than just a very
few days two or three four five maybe
early next week at the latest
there's no reason why that has to be
longer than that
we absolutely reject the argument that
some have been making and i don't know
why they've been making that somehow if
we have a single witness out here it's
going to take weeks and weeks of
protracted delay in this trial and
that's just not so and certainly not so
with the three witnesses we're asking
you to permit us to present today
i also want to
address the
argument that's been made by some
that
witnesses should only be permitted if
there is new evidence
now
we believe
we managers that we will present to you
new evidence with the witnesses that we
have asked you to bring and let us
depose
but think through this with me for one
moment
under the rules you set up if we take
depositions which we are required to do
of every one of these witnesses at the
end of the day when those depositions
are completed all the new evidence that
we could imagine will certainly be from
those three witnesses in those
depositions and the argument would then
be made i'm sure
that there's no reason to have alive
witnesses out i witness out here at all
that had to be a preconceived notion by
somebody who thought of that in the
first place if that is the argument that
should not be the standard
it should be one of the standards but
not the standard not the soul standard
there's a lot more to a witness
and the reason why you need to have a
witness out here than simply new
evidence in real criminal trials
virtually all witnesses are deposed
before they're brought to trial
and then the council on each side
decides
which witnesses they'll call they're
called they're examined they're
cross-examined
and unless a witness is deceased or laid
up or there's some other extraordinary
reason why that witness isn't there
especially a key witness
then the witness normally is here live
it's especially true in a case like this
where much of the evidence not
necessarily all of it there are quite a
bit of direct evidence but much of the
evidence is circumstantial and requires
you to draw as many finders of fact do
all across this country every day
inferences and conclusions that involve
the credibility of a witness that
involved the way it's said that involve
inflections and spontaneity of the
witness the exchange between the council
asking the questions and the witness and
a description that the flavor of which
you simply can't get
without having the person here to
observe that's what jurors do all the
time
i think it's especially important as
well because there's conflicting
testimony
now i don't suppose we have a stand here
today but i want to you've got in front
of you
a credibility of witness instruction i
think we've passed out we'd like for you
to keep it it's a credibility witness
instruction that
here it is over here on this side
credibility of witness instruction is
longer than this i just excerpted a part
of it and put it up up here on this
board and i know you can't all see that
but you should have this sheet if you
don't please ask for it this is a jury
instruction that's given in the
districts of columbia
it's something that's given here as a
part of our federal system
and it's important i think for this
particular paragraph to read it to
understand it because it's
you wouldn't even write this jury
instruction if you didn't expect to have
live witnesses
in reaching a conclusion as to the
credibility of any witness you may
consider any matter that may have a
bearing on the subject that's part of
the instruction you may consider the
demeanor and the behavior of the witness
i think that's important it's the third
paragraph if you're looking at it it's a
bolded paragraph you may consider the
demeanor and the behavior of the witness
on the witness stand
the witness's manner of testifying
whether the witness impresses you as a
truthful person
whether the witness impresses you as
having an accurate memory in
recollection whether the witness has any
motive for not telling the truth whether
the witness had a full opportunity to
observe the matters about which he or
she has testified whether the witness
has any interest in the outcome of the
case or friendship or hostility towards
other persons in the case
meaner
man demeanor manner
truthfulness howard the witness
impresses you if you don't have that
witness here
and it's a critical witness
is no way as a trier fact you can make
those judgments fairly there just isn't
any way and we think
that it is terribly critical not only
that we are permitted to depose these
witnesses but with respect particularly
to monica lewinsky and perhaps all three
of them that we be permitted to bring
those witnesses here at the end of the
day and examine them and let the
president's council examine them
the arguments of the president's council
have been to some extent to you and to
me and i've heard it repeated several
times
that somehow circumstantial evidence is
not
that important
that it's somehow inferior to direct
evidence i didn't pass out a jury
instruction on that again you've already
heard us talk about that the reality is
the jury instructions if i passed one
out today to you would say exactly what
we've seen before
circumstantial evidence is given the
same weight the same weight as direct
evidence inferences have to be drawn i
don't know of any case in this country
in a criminal matter or rarely i
shouldn't say any i suppose there's the
confession that always you get once in a
while and you read about in the paper
but in almost every criminal case
you have to draw inferences there has to
be circumstantial evidence of some sort
and there's nothing wrong with that
president's council has said that
somehow the nature of the evidence means
you should automatically acquit him
i just don't buy that at all what what
are inferences let's put inferences up
for a second so you can look at that
inferences are on this side this is
another jury instruction i don't know if
you've got this one but we'll give it to
you this is another one that is given
out an inference is a deduction or a
conclusion which you
as finders of fact are permitted to draw
from the facts which have been
established by either direct or
circumstantial evidence in drawing
inferences you should exercise your
common sense
you are permitted to draw from the facts
which you find to be proven such
reasonable inferences
as would be justified in light of your
experience
a few days ago one of the white house
counsel mr kimball
attempted to make you think it was very
difficult to prove a crime by
circumstantial evidence you may remember
mr kendall told the story about
a fellow who came out of his house one
morning and
he saw his driveway was wet
and he immediately thought it must have
rained last night
but mr kendall said this man
noticed
right after that
that his neighbor's water sprinkler was
dripping
and he thought well maybe the water
sprinkler caused it to be wet
and he used that illustration into the
story right there
of how difficult circumstantial evidence
is and how likely you might draw the
wrong conclusion from inferences
mr kendall didn't
allow you to proceed with the next
common sense step that shows how
powerful circumstantial evidence can be
let's suppose
the man got up in the morning he walked
out of his house
he saw that his driveway was wet
he thought maybe it arranged he
immediately observed the water sprinkler
was dripping
he thought well maybe the water
sprinkler caused it and he looked down
the street then and looked at not only
his neighbor's sidewalk where it was wet
as well as his and the driveway but he
looked at his neighbors
and he looked at the several others all
around in his neighborhood and they were
dry
the obvious conclusion from
circumstantial evidence is the
neighbor's water sprinkler caused his
sidewalk in his or his his driveway to
be wetted it didn't rain
it's a kind of a reasonable common sense
inferential circumstantial conclusion
you're allowed to draw
you're the finders of fact and i think
that that uh that suggestion was wrong
but this is why we need witnesses
you need to be able to see the
temperament you need to be able to have
the background you need to be able to
have the feel and the flavor to draw
those inferences
properly in the impeachment case before
you have both direct and circumstantial
evidence that the president engaged in a
pattern of obstruction
perjury and witness tampering designed
to deny the court in the jones case what
judge wright had determined
that jones had a right to discover in
order to prove her claim
you have to use your common sense to get
at this seeing hearing observing those
live witnesses is important if you
remember at the outset of this case
at the outset of these proceedings i
tried to draw you
and your attention
to a nutshell of what this was about
some have said it's a theory of the case
white house counsel wants to call it
speculation
it's not speculation
it's what from all the evidence
especially once you've heard monica
lewinsky and vernon jordan and sidney
blumenthal i think adding the flavor
that you need to have adding the body
language you need to observe adding the
credibility that you need to establish
in this
i think that's
the proper inference and the proper
conclusion you need to draw what was
that nutshell
and i won't bore you with going into
every detail again but i want to remind
you what the record we think shows that
this additional witness presentation
would augment and be very important to
it shows the president had a well
thought out scheme
he resented
the jones lawsuit he was alarmed when
monica lewinsky's name appeared on the
witness list and even more alarmed when
judge wright issued her order signaling
the court would hear the evidence of the
relationship
to keep his relationship with monica
lewinsky from the court once it was
apparent to him he was going to have to
testify he knew he would have to lie to
the court to succeed at this he decided
he had to get monica lewinsky to file a
false affidavit to try to avoid her
testifying he needed to get her a job to
make her happy to make sure she executed
the affidavit and then stick with their
lies if questioned
then the gifts were subpoenaed
he had to have her hide the gifts
the only tangible evidence that could
link him to her
she came up with the idea of giving them
to betty curry and the president seized
on that who would think to ask betty
then he would be free to lie to the
court in the deposition
but after this he realized he had to
make sure betty would lie
and cover for him
he got his aides
convinced to repeat his lies to the
grand jury and to the public and all of
this worked until the dress showed up
then he lied to the grand jury to try to
cover up and explain away his prior
crimes
the president knowingly
intentionally
willfully set out on a course of conduct
in december 1997 to light of the jones
court to hide his relationship and to
encourage others to lie and hide
evidence and to conceal the relationship
with monica lewinsky from the court now
that's the straightforward
case that we've presented
it's there
but it's very important that you
recognize this is not speculation that
it is supported by the evidence but it
needs to have the witnesses here
now i'm not going to go into every one
of the articles i'm not going to go over
all that again you've got them in front
of you but you know there are four
provisions four different provisions of
the perjury article and there are seven
counts in the obstruction article
and in addition to the seven counts we
believe you have the right to consider
the lies the president
made in the civil paul jones deposition
as a part of his obstruction of justice
as written in that art body of that
article
now why do i raise what is there on the
table
well you can find the president
guilty of any one of the perjury
obstruction of justice charges in our
judgment if you find him guilty of
anyone
you can convict him and you can remove
him from office we think
that's appropriate we think that you
should that every one of them rises to
that level
we now and i want to make a point to you
too for example about the first one in
persia about the nature and details of
his relationship with monica lewinsky
let's just say for a minute so you will
get this one clear if i could
beg your indulgence there were a lot of
questions raised out here about
particular statements that might be for
juries some of which may have sounded a
little bit stretched to you and then
others did
but the body and the graviment of that
is they're all grand jury perjury about
that relationship cumulatively that's
what you're voting on you're not voting
on you know as each and every one of
these
particularly the
singular lie that hangs the president of
the united states
and therefore there are three more in
addition to that to look at so please
look at all of them
we also strongly believe that each of
these constitute high crimes and
misdemeanors it's very hard for us to
conceive
that there's a different standard for
impeaching the president and impeaching
a judge we know that's been argued to
you out here but it's very hard for us
to conceive of this on the other hand
i'm aware that many of you believe and
i'm sure some of you at least do i hope
it's not many but i said many that no
matter whether or not the president is
guilty of the perjury and the
obstruction of justice everything that's
in here in great detail
everything we've told you there are some
of you believe that none of that
rises to the level of a high crime and
misdemeanor and that the president
shouldn't be removed from office
on the other hand i think that the
majority of you do believe
that if the president committed all of
this
surely it would rise to the level of
high crimes and misdemeanors how can you
leave a man in office who's president
united states who has so intentionally
through his scheme that he's concocted
denied a court justice denied
information to a person who is trying to
plead their case gone through it
systematically and lied again and again
and again and then when intentionally
calculatingly and lied to the grand jury
about it again it's very hard to
conceive of that
but i also suspect
that most of you at the end of the day
will question some of these
and as i said earlier you don't have to
conclude that he committed all of them
to convict him certainly not to find him
guilty of the charges
but somewhere in between
is it 50 of them is it 7 8 of them is it
how many of them does it take what's the
weight for some of you each one of you
will be judging this differently
but in that process
there is no doubt in my mind that you
need to go through the process of
looking at and hearing from these
witnesses to make that decision and if
you have a doubt not about in your own
mind maybe some of you have no doubt at
all
that he's guilty of any and all of these
crimes but if you think one of your
other colleagues does have that doubt at
this moment for god sakes let's let the
witnesses come here and let us have the
chance to erase that doubt in the way
you normally would in a trial
for a few of the criminal charges under
articles of impeachment
under both of them
it's our judgment that
the president's guilt is so clear
and convincing
and compelling
that we don't think that any witnesses
are needed to be called in deposition or
in person
first contrary to the impressions that
the white house counsel would like to
leave you it should be clear to anybody
reading the record
that the president committed perjury
before the grand jury
when he told him that he never touched
certain body parts of ms lewinsky when
touching the president admitted would
clearly be with within the definition of
sexual relations in the jones case
ms lewinsky testified that he touched
these parts on a number of different
occasions in a manner clearly within the
president's understanding of that
definition
the record contains testimony from at
least six different friends and
counselors with whom ms lewinsky spoke
and described these details
contemporaneously
as they occurred
white house counsel has repeatedly tried
to dismiss
this
absolutely clear perjury
by claiming that ms lewinsky's testimony
is uncorroborated and therefore you
couldn't prove perjury to the court they
say again and again and again it's a he
says
she says situation
this is a gross misstatement of the law
even if there were no corroborating
witnesses and there are
in this case
a person could be and would be convicted
of perjury before any court in this
country based on the evidence that's in
this record now we don't have to bring
anything else in here and we're not
planning to do so to prove that the law
covering grand jury perjury that's been
on the books since 1970 does not require
a corroborating witness does not require
corroborating evidence and there are
more than a hundred people serving in
federal prison today who've been
convicted under this 1970 grand jury
statute for perjury where it's one
person's word against another several of
them for lies about sexual relations
all you need to convict is to accept
monica lewinsky had no motive to lie
about this the president did and you
have to draw the inferences you
logically can from the chain of events
that are in this record but even though
you don't need any corroborating
testimony there is corroborating
testimony they're the six people friends
and counselors with whom she talked
about this contemporaneously again the
white house counselors have tried to
persuade you wrongly
that you should not consider this that
this would not be admissible these
corroborating witnesses in any courtroom
in the country they say and that's not
true there are at least
three exceptions to the hearsay rule
which would in all probability permit
those prior inconsistent statements the
prior consistent statements i should say
to come in to corroborate that testimony
so
the bottom line is the perjury
of the president in this case is as
plain as day on the record and we don't
need to call any witnesses on this
matter and we also believe that there
are a number of other perjuries in that
grand jury that i'm not going into in
detail that are just as plain on the
record we don't need to call witnesses
to prove he purged himself when he told
the grand jury it was his goal to be
truthful
in the jones deposition that's what he
told the grand jury was his goal to be
truthful the record is replete
with many lies
that he told in that deposition
and in the face of telling the grand
jury that his goal to be truthful he
committed perjury nor do we believe that
any witness needs to be called to
further establish the president's guilt
of the crimes of obstruction of justice
and witness tampering in the case where
he met betty curry
on the day after
his jones deposition
and suggested to her all those false
declaratory
statements
that we've been over so many times in
here
betty's curry's testimony in this matter
is undisputed on the record
the white house counsel's argument that
the president was just refreshing his
memory is absurd
on its face
the same is true of the obstruction of
justice and perjury charges related to
allowing his attorney during the jones
deposition to make false and misleading
statements with regard to ms lewinsky's
affidavit and then lying about not even
paying attention to the attorney's
exchange with a judge on this matter the
record's clear
you watch the videotape on it inferences
are perfectly appropriate to be drawn
from body language there you saw it on a
videotape you saw it
no more witnesses are needed the
president committed these crimes on the
other hand
we believe that you do need
we need to bring in witnesses to resolve
conflicting testimony to give you a true
picture of the president's scheme to lie
and conceal evidence for the other
obstruction of justice charges and
certainly for the last perjury charge
they are more complex they're more
depending on circumstantial evidence and
inferences that you logically have to
draw and that's why you need to hear
from monica lewinsky vernon jordan cindy
blumenthal to tell you about these
things themselves
when you do you're just plain going to
get a different flavor you're going to
feel the sense of this
we believe that you would find at the
end of the day once you've done that
even though you don't need to use this
standard
that the president is guilty of the
entire scheme we presented to you in
every detail beyond a reasonable doubt
remember you don't need to convict him
to find him guilty of all of the crimes
we've suggested by any stretch of the
imagination you don't need to use the
beyond a reasonable doubt standard
that's not required of you but we can
understand why many of you or some of
you might the reality is
that
we are in a position you are in a
position where you need though to make
these determinations and to make them
you need to have the witnesses any
courtroom where you're going to
certainly judge something beyond a
reasonable doubt you need to assess the
credibility of the witnesses where you
have conflicting testimony and one point
in that regard too is
we've heard white house counsel say a
number of times
that somehow the fact that there is so
much conflicting testimony that makes
our case weaker
that's not so
i don't again unless the
bad guy admits he's guilty
you go to trial in a criminal case you
always have conflicting
testimony at least you certainly have
the accused denying it and very very
frequently most often you have a lot of
other people who conflict
the fact there are conflicts is simply
something for the triers of fact to
resolve but again resolve by
listening to the witnesses
checking their demeanor
watching their body language determining
their credibility
feeling the case flow seeing how it fits
together
watch it i'm not going to be the one
describing what monica lewinsky is going
to show you if she comes in here but i
want to tell you even if you depo we
depose her
having had the
opportunity to talk with this
intelligent and very impressionable
young woman the other day i can tell you
that
she herself will convey this story to
you in a way that it cannot be conveyed
off a piece of paper it just cannot be
i suppose that's why the white house
counselors are so afraid of our calling
any witnesses
they don't want you to have the
opportunity to see that
an opportunity you can only get the full
flavor of if not only you let us take
the depositions but you let us at least
call her alive here on the floor
preferably with all three of our our
other two witnesses as well
they know that the written record
conceals this there's no way to lift
that out there's no way for you to see
the relationship how she responds to the
questions how she answers how she
conducts herself in making it very
apparent what the president's true
meaning and intent was if you remember a
lot of this is his state of mind in the
not too distant future monica lewinsky
is going to be free of the gag order and
she's going to go out and she's going to
talk to people and freely she should at
that point in time
she's going to have the public judging
her
and they're going to be judging this
case as will history and i would suggest
that the public at that point and
history as well will be judging
you and not judging the senate well if
it doesn't let her come here and testify
now let me briefly turn to the last
thing i want to do
i want to describe so you know what it
is the three
additional pieces of new evidence we'd
like admitted in this motion first is
the affidavit of barry w ward who's been
a law clerk to judge wright during the
consideration of the jones case none of
this i think should be controversial but
we do have it and i want to cover it
briefly
in his affidavit he attested the fact of
the president clinton's deposition in
the jones case
that mr ward was sitting at the
conference table next to judge wright
that he was able to observe the colloquy
between the judge and mr bennett
if you recall mr bennett was engaged in
this colloquy about the affidavit of
monica lewinsky and that's what you saw
the film footage of with the president
and the questions ben has the president
been observant was he watching was he
keen and that affidavit goes to that
point and is the testimony of mr ward
with regard to the fact the president
was observant
secondly
we have a piece of new evidence and that
is the declaration of the jones attorney
t wesley holmes and the attached copies
of the subpoena in that case
the subpoena in that case to betty curry
dated january 22 1998 along with proof
of service dated january 27 1998 the
chair recognizes the senator from
vermont mr chief justice parliamentary
inquiry
it's my understanding
that senate resolution 16 says
the senator from vermont advised that it
takes unanimous consent to allow a
parliamentary inquiry to be stated well
then i the mr chief justice i object to
the references
uh the managers making to new
information
uh
is my understanding the senate
resolution 16 the material outside the
record may only
be presented in connection with a motion
to expand
the record
this new information
we've skirted already with the lewinsky
interview this weekend but now the
latest that mr manager mccollum
states i would say respectfully expands
that record and we are not at that point
yes i think the motion
that the managers have made
is a motion to authorize presentation of
evidence that is not in the record
and so i think that is fair comment i
overrule the objection all right thank
you
thank you mr chief justice the uh the
attachments to mr holmes
the declaration
is the proof of of the subpoena being
issued to betty curry in january on
january 22 1998 along with service in
the jones case on january 27 1998 and a
copy of the supplemental witness list
including the name of betty curry which
was served on january 23 1998 and in his
declaration mr holmes explains that mrs
curry was subpoenaed because of
testimony given by president clinton in
his deposition
and because of reliable information uh
which the attorneys had received to this
effect that mrs curry was an
instrumental
person in facilitating monica lewinsky's
meetings with the president and central
to their quote cover story unquote as mr
holmes refers to it he explicitly denies
that any washington post article played
any part in the decision of the jones
attorneys to subpoena mrs curry and then
the third and final piece of new
evidence that we ask you to
take in and accept is a declaration and
accompanying
documents with regard to a telephone
conversation
showing that a conversation occurred on
december the 6th for 56 minutes between
the president
and
ms lewinsky at least we believe that's
what it shows that obviously the
telephone records show the phone records
and they state what they are but we
suggest to you that that is relevant
information because it confirms what we
think the testimony in the record
otherwise would lead you to believe
at this point in time having given you
an overview and having given you this
amount of the new evidence we want to i
want to turn the microphone over and
yield to my colleague mr bryant
the rest of the time
right
the chair recognizes mr manager brian
manning
just under 90 minutes
thank you mr chief justice
distinguished senators a recent letter
from manager hyde to senator daschle
stated that is always been the position
of the house managers that a trial with
the benefit of relevant witnesses
is in the best interest of the senate
and the american people
the defense attorneys for the president
as well as others
in this body have publicly stated that
they do not want witnesses
through the question and answer session
that we have just participated in over
the last few days
some in this body have made it clear
that they would prefer
a few sharply focused witnesses limited
only to the most relevant witnesses
we heard this
and as a result of our submission this
morning you will see that
we have proposed three witnesses now as
background we have brought this down
from some 15 witnesses that we initially
thought we would like to call
we eliminated obviously many witnesses
that we would still like to call
but with
respect for this body and and certainly
the sensitivity that
we feel
we
heard that three witnesses would be
probably the best situation i think from
the again the tone of the questions the
the directness of many of your questions
that we we did get that message clearly
and from these three witnesses we feel
that we have
the broadest coverage of the the two
articles of impeachment
uh within the obstruction
article there are in essence seven
so-called counts seven instances that we
allege
and with these three witnesses we
managed to cover six of those seven with
with the one that we we don't quite
cover being the the tampering with with
betty curry as you will know she is not
on that list but again bringing this
down to three
we had to eliminate again some witnesses
we would have preferred to call
also based on what we have read and what
we have heard it is clear that a very
few have already determined that even
assuming the truth of the articles of
impeachment that's perjury and
obstruction of justice
that
there are insufficient to convict this
president of high crimes and
misdemeanors
and since each of you as senators must
consider this magi this matter
and vote your own conscience
with impartial justice that is
apparently your individual decision
although with all due respect i would
suggest a premature decision before all
the proof and all the arguments are made
one example of not having heard a
complete case
is miss lewinsky
she is probably the most relevant
witness
that is aside from the president himself
who
so far has indicated through his council
that he would not testify and
i might add has also not answered the
questions that this
at least some senator sent to the white
house
for his answering
uh
based on his attorney's statement that
he would be willing to answer questions
so
with with that aside ms lewinsky is
probably the most important witness left
and wouldn't you at least like to see
and hear
from her on this as as triers of fact
wouldn't you want to observe the
demeanor of miss lewinsky and and test
her credibility as i say look into the
eyes and test the credibility of these
witnesses
compare her version
of the testimony to the contested
events and remember the president's
attorneys
in
numerous ways in their vigorous defense
of the president have challenged miss
lewinsky's version
of the facts
i believe the majority of other senators
have not yet reached a final
determination
and is to you now that i make this
further proposition
if there's one witness you and the
american people honestly do need to hear
it's ms lewinsky
now as you probably read in the
newspapers
her lawyers don't want her to testify
they're good lawyers and they don't they
don't want to have her out here and
despite the protestations of the white
house
and their attorneys during the
house hearings that they wanted to hear
fact witnesses we now know absolutely
and whether without a doubt
the white house does not want to hear ms
lewinsky does not want you to hear ms
lewinsky
and ms lewinsky if truth be known
probably does not want to come in here
and testify these are not our witnesses
we
didn't get this case in a brown envelope
but we certainly didn't have any choice
in selecting the witnesses
the witnesses are all out there are
basically white house employees friends
of the white house or former employees
these are not going to be our friends if
they come in and testify they're not
going to be sympathetic to us although
we would anticipate that they would tell
the truth
and that certainly
would be our belief with ms lewinsky if
she were called we believe she
understands her responsibility despite
any feelings that she might have about
the president or the job that he's doing
as president that she understands this
responsibility to tell the truth
and senator she does have a story to
tell
and given the link
that she has that common thread that she
is and most of the charges of these
articles of impeachment
i would suggest that she should be
permitted to testify
i would go further to say that a closure
of this case is is somehow necessary
and without the direct presentation by
miss lewinsky
we all
political
and public would be denied the complete
picture that she should be able to give
us
to better sort this out
as manager graham said yesterday
please don't leave us all hanging
for the answers we so dearly need
is this good is it bad or is it ugly
we managers believe that it's bad
ugly
and illegal
you know we all like to talk about the
constitution
and it's a great document
the opportunity to confront
witnesses
is present in that constitution
and it can be argued that this principle
of confrontation of witnesses against
you
should apply to these proceedings while
we realize the confrontation right is
tech is is one that belongs to a
criminal defendant in the constitution
and in this case apparently
any right to confront ms lewinsky and
other witnesses is being waived by the
president and his lawyers since they
don't want to call witnesses in these
proceedings
isn't it a time though for the rest of
us to make that choice that we do want
to see and hear some witnesses
her testimony in particular would be
extraordinarily enlightening
in resolving factual disputes about
the very charges for which we ask you to
convict
the president of the united states for
the felonies of perjury and obstruction
of justice
these particular charges go to the very
heart of our co-branch of government the
judiciary
and members of the senate in terms of
impact on our judicial system and the
search for truth there is no difference
between
a person lying which is perjury and a
person paying another person to lie
which is bribery the bribery is in the
constitution and the perjury is not
specifically mentioned
and in terms of this proposition of
proportionality
is the 106th senate prepared to have as
its record on sexual harassment laws
that perjury about sex is not illegal
after all that's what this whole
proportionality argument's about that if
it's about sex it's okay to lie
because senator bumper says that upwards
of 80 percent of his divorce cases from
his arkansas practice of law involve
lying
that does not legitimize perjury
nor should it provide any authority for
this senate to somehow legitimize
perjury
if it's just about sex
we allege that the president is a reason
in a reasoned and in a calculated manner
prevented paula jones from attaining
from obtaining truthful testimony and
evidence that might have helped her
lawsuit
at that time the president attempted his
cover-up efforts he obviously felt the
disclosure of that information in the
paula jones case would be material and
helpful to her
the president not only committed himself
to illegal actions but he enlisted
others to assist
some knowingly
and others perhaps unknowingly
and mrs lewinsky is one of these who
interestingly enough
might fit into both categories of
knowing and unknowingly at different
times
and she would be able to share with this
senate the so-called
tone and tenor of her conversations with
the president i mean who else who else
can do that but she or the president
and this
this tone and and tenor and and
observing her demeanor and and listening
to her talk about that that
that
filing of the affidavit and those things
and how the president talked to her
and and how she read what he said and
exactly what he did say these are all
very important because
as we know in in washington and so many
other places where there's a lot of
power and prestige and so forth their
their actions that can be prompted
without even a direct specific order
things can get done
even without it being said to get done
just by
the tone and tenor the the the gestures
the appearance and so forth of certain
things
often these direct words as i said are
not necessary and ms lewinsky can tell
you
about some of these
occasions an appropriate examination
and an appropriate cross-examination i
might add let's don't let's don't limit
the white house attorneys here
of ms lewinsky on the factual disputes
of the affidavit
and their cover story
wouldn't that be nice to hear that
the concealment of the gifts what what
really happened there and the job search
why did she get the job within 48 hours
of the affidavit after months of
unsuccess
wouldn't it be nice to hear miss
lewinsky's version of this when it's so
important to the overall overall case of
obstruction of justice
these are just a few examples where the
senate could be helped by her testimony
and it very well it very well could be
dispositive
and even
it's even possible that that she could
help the president in some ways
but i assure you
that she is an impressive young lady
and i suspect that she still very much
does admire the president and the work
that he is doing for this country
yet she would be a person who in all
likelihood would be forthcoming
if you've not made up your mind and
indeed if you have further interest in
resolving many of the facts here i do
commend ms lewinsky for your
consideration
it would be my intent to
lead her through
direct examination
the perjury charge
as it's alleged with the president
by having her simply affirm those
provisions of her written testimony
which are the ones that are generally
generally referred to as salacious
without specifically mentioning those
words
beyond
on the more complicated obstruction of
justice the the pattern of obstruction
of justice
which does not involve these salicious
details and matters
they will be dressed more specifically
it would be my intent for the needed
clarification and and to resolve
discrepancies in different inferences
from this evidence that have been drawn
by house managers and defense counsel
for the president
to ask her about the december 28th
transfer
of ms lewinsky's gifts from the
president
the transfer to ms curry
particularly the cellular telephone call
that has been put into issue by the
defense team
another about her conversation with the
president and
her offer to
allow him to review this false affidavit
before she submitted it to the to her
lawyer and eventually to the court
and and his comment that he didn't need
to review it because he had seen 15
others just like it
would you like to know what are we
talking about 15 others there are 15
drafts or 15 other type affidavits in
other cases
she would also be asked about her job
interviews
and her discussions with the president
about these job interviews over a period
of time which are very important her
discussions with vernon jordan
and specifically why she felt that
the interview that she did with revlon
the day after she signed the affidavit
her impression that it went poorly
and whereas we've heard
uh not testimony but statements in in
the presentation of white house lawyers
that in fact it didn't go poorly it went
very well
but she felt it went so poorly that she
went immediately out to call vernon
jordan why
why not hear her come in and tell us why
she did that
there will of course be other matters of
record
that she can clarify
and certainly being available to the
white house defense team
she will be
vigorously cross-examined i'm sure that
may also clarify some other matters
it is my feeling that a fair and
comprehensive direct examination without
interruption could be conducted of ms
lewinsky in in two to four hours
and depending on the length of
cross-examination by white house
attorneys
we may not need any redirect examination
while defense counsel for the president
and others for the president i've heard
it so many times i'm not sure exactly
who has said this so i don't want to
just attribute it to defense counsel and
maybe they haven't even said it but they
have they have
has been word out of the white house
that if we call one witness
we might might as well settle in for the
siege here in the senate we're going to
be here for months and months and months
and i suggest that's an outrageous
statement
that we will need that amount of time to
pursue this case if witnesses are called
we're confident that
that basically in its in its best case
is an attempt to discourage you from
calling witnesses
and in its worst case unfortunately is a
veil threat that they will
be dilatory and drag this out for months
and months if the senate would allow
house managers are establishing a
good faith effort to cut our witnesses
as i said down to three people and to
commit to
reasonable times of examination
with the assurance that we will finish
as quickly as we can
and we would hope and perhaps the senate
would give similar similar direction
to the white house and their defense
team witnesses can be called and a fair
trial could be accomplished if all
concerned
would agree
would the senate consider requesting the
president's defense team to also select
three or fewer witnesses in an effort to
move this process along
and we think too that the depositions
while they're important if they are
solely
for the purposes of discovery
i would ask why would the white house
need to discover what vernon jordan has
to say what betty curry has to say
sidney blumenthal john podesta any of
these witnesses
they would have to take monica
lewinsky's deposition i would think but
any other discovery deposition it would
seem to me they have complete access to
already
as i close i want to leave you with
some words that have been of some
comfort to me and i think we've all
needed some type of comfort at times uh
during these proceedings but certainly
have been comforting to me and and they
are the apart and it's a very short
quote
of the opening remarks of judiciary
committee chairman peter rodino in 1974
again in part he says that we know that
the very real security of this nation
lies in the integrity of its
institutions
and the informed confidence of its
people
talking about the nixon hearings we will
we will
conduct our deliberations in that spirit
it has been said that our country
troubled by too many crises in recent
years is too tired to consider this one
in the first year of the republic thomas
paine wrote
those who expect to reap the blessings
of freedom must like men
undergo the fatigue of supporting it
now for almost 200 years back to peter
rodino
americans have undergone the stress of
preserving their freedom
and the constitution that protects it
it is now our turn
and ladies and gentlemen of the senate i
would respectfully ask you to permit
house managers to call these three named
witnesses and add this additional
evidence now thank you and it would
bring up uh mr manager hutchinson
the chair recognizes mr manager
hutchinson
mr chief justice
ladies and gentlemen the senate
my responsibility is to address the
testimony of vernon jordan and the need
to call him as a witness in this case
before i go into the details of that let
me just reflect for a moment
on the senate trial process
and i said many days ago that i had
confidence in the united states senate
and i thought at this particular
juncture it might be good if i reassured
you that i still have confidence in the
united states senate
and i think about the trial process that
we're going through
and i've complimented you on the fact
that you structured a bipartisan process
and i think that's important because you
gave this process credibility
and so you did the right thing and i for
one am pleased with what you're able to
accomplish in that endeavor
now
whenever you achieve a bipartisan
process you have to make compromises
along the way
and the result is a format that is not
particularly helpful to the trial
managers the house managers who wish to
call witnesses
and we've struggled through that
but notwithstanding the present
difficulty i still compliment you and
thank you for what you have done in
achieving that bipartisan consensus
but
i think back to that meeting that i had
early on and some other managers with
the bipartisan group of senators from
this body i look at some from both sides
of the aisle and
i went in there with this high-minded
thought
that
we can make a case for witnesses because
of what the other managers have
described as the tone and demeanor of
witnesses
well that was quick quickly brushed
aside
uh by saying no no no we want to hear
about what conflicts exist
in the testimony just tell us what the
conflicts are because that is a strong
case for calling witnesses
well that threw me back on my heels
and so i went back and as you know in
the question and answer session i
addressed the issue of conflicts i think
we did a pretty good job of outlining
the conflicts between various witnesses
well then i was informed that
well we really are not as interested in
the conflicts because the conflicts
exist in the current transcript
therefore really we want to know what
new information what new dynamic these
witnesses can add
well that really threw me back for a a
curve and so we looked at this again and
we tried to make a case and i'm going to
show you what new dynamics and questions
can be asked but ultimately when you
take the depositions
many of those questions are going to be
answered
and so you come back full circle to
where we started the beginning
that ultimately i hope that witnesses
are called but so that you can evaluate
their credibility determine their
demeanor and make an assessment of the
truth in this case and i think that that
is important
and i i know people talk about me as
being a former federal prosecutor
actually i one time
i confess i represented a defendant in a
murder case
and
this gentleman was charged with murder
and the prosecution in logan county
arkansas
near senator bumper's hometown
decided they wanted to
handle the key witness one of the key
witnesses by a deposition who was out of
state and i objected i objected
and because i thought that witness ought
to be in the courtroom and the judge
overruled and said you go take the
deposition and the defense counsel will
be there and cross-examine so we
traipsed off to the other state took
this witness's deposition and she made a
lousy witness
i said she wouldn't be believed for
anything
the way she appeared
well we brought it back the transcript
back to the courtroom the prosecution
over my objection put the transcript
into the record and all of a sudden that
cold transcript was believable
particularly when they had it read by
another witness that didn't look
anything like the original lady
and so
my client was convicted
but that case was reversed by the
arkansas supreme court because the court
said it was important that the jury that
the jury look into the eyes of the
witness see the demeanor that witness
and determine the credibility
and so ultimately ultimately we come
back to that same point that somehow
you're going to have to resolve the
conflicts and i know of only one way to
do it we have tried to be
extraordinarily
helpful cooperative with the united
states senate i came in with this idea
that if i was going to present this case
14 to 15 witnesses that's off the table
clearly we have narrowed this down to
three witnesses that is tough to decide
but we believe represents the basic
heart of the obstruction of justice case
and gets to at least six of the seven
elements so that you can evaluate that
but we want to assist you clearly in
getting to the truth but also to bring
this manner to a conclusion
in
as fairly and expeditiously manner as
possible now let's look to mr vernon
jordan
should he be called as a witness in this
case his testimony
goes to the heart of one of the elements
of obstruction of justice and that is
the job search and the false affidavit
and the connection the interconnection
between those
i have tried during my presentation of
this case
to present portions of his testimony
excerpts if you will from his testimony
but if you will see
he has testified
five times before the federal grand jury
i've read all of this and i'm not going
to ask for a show of hands but how many
of you have read of all of this
and so you have had to rely upon a trial
an ordeal by lawyers rather than a trial
by witnesses because i've had to present
the testimony of vernon jordan in
excerpt fashion
limited quotes here and there as defense
the defense counsel has done likewise
now
that makes it difficult because the
problem is one you're hearing it from me
but secondly it's not a story
it is excerpts and there's no way you
can assess the truth because of that now
if you look at the times that mr jordan
has testified before the grand jury
march 3 of 98 march 5 may 5 may 28 and
june 9th the last time he testified was
june 9 1998 but let's look what has
happened since then
since mr jordan last testified for the
grand jury i believe these charts are in
front of you
july 22 ms curry testified before the
grand jury
so any of the facts we gained from ms
curry was not utilized in the last
examination of vernon jordan
august 6th
what happened on that date miss lewinsky
testified before the grand jury and she
revealed some new facts during that time
that mr jordan has never had an
opportunity to explain respond or answer
and i'll go into that one of them about
disposing of notes uh the second one
about drafting the affidavit and uh of
course by that time the the dna on the
dress had been revealed and then the
next thing that happened was the
president's revelation to the nation
that this relationship did exist and
then he testified before the grand jury
all of the facts revealed from those
incidences were not available at the
time vernon jordan last testified before
the grand jury so obviously any lawyer
would understand there are naturally
questions that would arise from each of
those incidences that could be posed to
mr jordan why has that not been done i
quite frankly i have talked to as i
mentioned the other day the attorney for
mr jordan i have not talked to mr jordan
personally i think that clearly the
senate does not want us to do that until
we get past this next hurdle but
those are things that need to be
resolved
now let me redress briefly about three
areas of conflicts the testimony between
mr jordan and miss lewinsky
that points up other areas of
questioning that would be appropriate
that he should have the opportunity to
explain
i've been accused of being harsh on mr
jordan and i don't mean to be that there
have been certain things that have been
stated by witnesses in this case that
ought to be explained that ought to be
questioned mr jordan but he might have
good answers to these questions we need
to know those
answers the first conflict let me see
what the next one says
uh and i'm not going to get to that yet
but the first conflict is
uh
mr jordan's testimony and miss
lewinsky's testimony about whether mr
jordan knew the true nature of the
relationship with the president
and in mr jordan's testimony of may 28th
he was asked the question you're saying
no one to your recollection ever
suggested or alleged a sexual
relationship prior to the 18th of
january between monica lewinsky and the
president the answer that is correct
now that was on may 28th
miss lewinsky was asked the same series
of questions months later in august of
1998 and
she indicated
she testified and i remarked that i
didn't really look at him as the
president that i saw him more as a man
and reacted to him more as a man and got
angry at him like a man and just a
regular person and mr jordan asked me
what i got angry at the president about
so i told him when he doesn't call me
enough or see me enough
the answer
another statement and so after we had
the conversation
i was just talking about with mr jordan
he said to me well you know what your
problem is and i said what he said don't
deny it and i said
you're in love that's what your problem
is this is monica olenski referring to
what mr jordan had said and so clearly
uh there those are relevant questions
that need to be readdressed to mr jordan
because they were raised by miss
lewinsky in a subsequent
testimony that have never been asked to
him in that fashion there's a conflict
in the testimony between mr jordan miss
lewinsky about whether the subpoena was
discussed at the december 22nd meeting
mr jordan testified in march
that we did not talk about the subpoena
she wanted to know about her job that
was the purpose of her coming
and the question was anything beyond
that the answer was no
and that's in march 3 of 1998 but miss
lewinsky contrary testified
question let's turn your attention then
to december 22 which is the day that you
met with frank carter and i think that
you said you were going to meet with mr
jordan
answer so i came to see mr jordan
earlier and i also wanted to find out if
he had in fact told the president that i
had been subpoenaed
and that
and so that was her testimony which is
in direct conflict that the subpoena was
discussed discussed on the same day that
she went to see
mr carter about the representation and
where is the relevance in this
if you recall
mr jordan said it didn't take a einstein
to figure out that whenever you combined
whenever she got the subpoena that it
changed the circumstances here you've
got three problems you've got a job
search you've got a witness in court and
if you combine that with a knowledge of
a relationship those are three dynamite
issues combining together that should
cause anyone not just one change of
circumstances but it elevates it to a
higher level of danger because of the
the correlation between each of those
three separate facts and each of these
conflicts and the testimony of monica
lewinsky goes to those key fundamental
issues and mr jordan has never been
asked sufficiently about those areas the
third conflict is and this is key and
this is the that chart there on the
gifts
is the testimony of monica lewinsky
mr jordan testified that he never talked
to ms lewinsky about linda tripp that's
his march 598 testimony
but miss lewinsky testifies
in her august 6 testimony about a
meeting with mr jordan on december 31
this is the third exhibit
and i'll just read that
and i met mr jordan for breakfast on the
morning of december 31st at the park
hyatt hotel
and in the course of the conversation i
told him that i had this friend lend a
trip and i was a little bit concerned
because she had spent the night at my
home a few times and i thought i told mr
jordan i said well maybe she's heard
some i mean maybe she saw some notes
lying around
and mr jordan said notes from the
president to you
and i said no
notes from me to the president
and he said
go home and make sure they're not there
this is ms lewinsky's testimony of
august 6 before the grand jury
and before anything is said i'm not
accusing anyone of anything
but let me tell you it would be
significant
if mr jordan is asked the question if
that is a true statement and he says yes
it is significant to the case if he says
no that's significant because there's a
clear conflict in the testimony of miss
lewinsky and her testimony goes to the
heart of the issue
if he says i don't remember which is the
third alternative
and by the way i hate giving these
prospective witnesses all my questions
but if he says i don't remember that
does not put
the issue in dispute with ms lewinsky
and establishes really her recollection
of the incident and so i could go
through more
i could go through more
uh conflict with ms lewinsky about
whether mr jordan saw the unsigned draft
copy of her affidavit a key issue in
this case miss lewinsky testifies one
way mr jordan did not have the benefit
of ms lewinsky's testimony when he was
asked earlier in the
grand jury and so that needs to be
readdressed with him
there's a conflict with ms lewinsky on
whether they discuss the contents of the
affidavit not just where they saw the
signed affidavit whether the contents
were discussed
the question to mr jordan was did you
ever discuss with miss lewinsky what she
was going to include the affidavit
answer i was not ms lewinsky's lawyer
the answer to that is no
but and he goes on and elaborates on
that but miss lewinsky testified that
she and jordan did have a conversation
about deleting a certain sentence of the
affidavit and re-working that
what's the next one here
and that's the
uh what i just covered on the contents
of the affidavit and let me just go to
one other on the conflict where the
affidavit was discussed at their last
meeting uh mr jordan testified in march
that she came to the office she gave me
a tie i said monica i'm real busy thank
you she thanked me and said she's gone
any substantive conversation the answer
was no mr lewinsky's testimony is i
stopped in to see him for five minutes
to thank him for getting me the job to
thank him for giving me a job and i gave
him a tie in a pocket
an answer and she further testified i
believe i showed him a copy of the
affidavit clear conflict very important
once again showing a connection between
the job the false affidavit and of
course if you tie in the other aspect
about the relationship it gets
very significant and something that
needs to be further inquired about and
so there are some of the conflicts
between the testimony
what new areas do we need to inquire to
mr jordan about the notes to the
president that mrs lewinsky said
she had a conversation with him about
and that has never been addressed to mr
jordan whatsoever
the december 19 meeting we need to
explore more with mr jordan this is the
meeting when miss lewinsky was
subpoenaed
she called mr
jordan he says come over she goes over
there
to meet with mr jordan
and during that meeting according to the
telephone logs mr jordan received a call
from the president of the united states
mr jordan has testified that he told the
president that miss lewinsky
got subpoenaed
now that appears to be
exactly during the meeting the
conversation he is having with ms
lewinsky
i think appropriate questions to mr
jordan is
did you excuse miss lewinsky from the
meeting
did you have the private conversation
with the president about the subject
that you were talking to ms lewinsky
about and when you re nude your
conversation with miss lewinsky did you
in fact
tell her about your conversation with
the president
if miss lewinsky was not told about that
conversation i think there's some
significance there that things were
going on that people were
compartmentalizing and not sharing with
the other interested parties and i think
that's significant and that needs to be
explored
in his involvement with reviewing the
affidavit needs to be developed and the
conflicts his knowledge of the nature of
the relationship with miss lewinsky
and so all of these needs to be further
explored there are a number of
unanswered questions
one final area i obviously have a number
but i don't want to belabor this point
there was testimony i had mentioned
about mr isikoff and how betty curry
felt compelled to go see mr jordan
about
uh messifica mr isakoff inquiring about
the courier records on the gifts from
miss lewinsky to the president
there is some indication that if that
information might have been shared with
mr frank carter because mrs lewinsky
testified that she received
a page from mr carter her attorney about
the issikov call
the issakov
request
how did that information get to mr
carter i think there's some legitimate
questions that should be asked there
and so we would respectfully ask the
senate to permit us to call
mr jordan as a witness to depose him
but further we hope that we'll be able
to call him
so that you can evaluate the conflicts
that i'm sure exist now but very likely
will exist later on as well
the story needs to be told
the truth should be determined
justice should be accomplished
that is done not through lawyers up here
talking but it's done not through
transcripts but through witnesses
edmund burke
said that to fail to hear the evidence
is to fail to hear the cause
and i know that you have transcripts but
i would continue
that to fail to hear the testimony is in
essence to fail to hear the cause
mr chief justice could i uh inquire uh
about the balance of the time remaining
for the house managers
yes the managers have
52 minutes remaining do they intend to
use more of their time uh now
well uh mischief justice uh
i asked consent that we take a 30-minute
break at this point
in the absence of objection it's so
ordered
the senate now standing in recess for
half an hour it's now 123 coming back
at
the uh 1 53 taking a half hour break we
are going to take this opportunity to
again open our phone lines we're
interested in your thoughts on what
you've seen
this is the tenth day in the impeachment
trial of the president of the united
states
and the arguments today on whether or
not that's uh really consistent with a
previous letter that was submitted by
the house managers uh to the senate that
that's a decision they have to make but
we're still expressing
uh
chair recognizes the majority leader
mr chief justice i have a unanimous
consent request of a pound uh we have
discussed this with senator daschle and
it's been cleared um i ask unanimous
consent that following the conclusion of
the arguments by the managers and the uh
white house counsel today on the motion
spin subpoena witnesses it'd be an order
at that point only for senator harkin or
senator wellstone to make a motion to
open that debate pursuant to his motion
time
timely filed and that the senate proceed
immediately to the vote pursuant to the
impeachment rules
i further ask that following that vote
if defeated it be in order to move to
close the session for deliberations on
the motion to speak of witnesses as
provided under the impeachment rules in
the senate proceed to an immediate vote
if we have any change in either one of
these uh certainly we would have to uh
ask for consent on that and would notify
members to that effect i further ask
that if the senate votes to proceed to
closed session those deliberations be
limited to three hours equally divided
between the two leaders notwithstanding
the five-minute uh allocation of time
under the impeachment rule i further ask
unanimous consent that when the senate
concludes its business today it's
standing in german until 1 pm on
wednesday january 27th and finally i ask
unanimous consent that pursuant to rule
s to s res 16 the votes occur
immediately upon convening on wednesday
first on the motion to dismiss and if
defeated the motion to subpoena
witnesses without intervening action or
debate
in the absence of objection it is so
ordered
and i believe mr chief justice uh we are
uh ready to uh proceed with white house
counsel
the chair recognizes mr council kendall
uh i'm
yes
very well
thank you mr rogan mr kendall
oh oh you you you're you're going to use
it now very well
you have 52 minutes remaining
the chair recognizes mr manager rogan
thank you mr chief justice members of
the senate
when i was a trial judge back in
california there was something i had to
do in every single case whether it was a
civil or criminal case
and that was to advise the triers of
fact
in that particular case the jury
that what the lawyers say
is not evidence
this is a universal warning
that is given in courtrooms throughout
the country
to the triers of fact
because the law prefers that those
people who have to make the
determination as to what the facts are
make that determination based not on the
interpretation of the evidence
but based upon what the evidence
actually is
and that has been the underpinning of
our argument before this body from the
very first day
as to why witnesses are needed
not to accommodate us
but for the senate to be able to make
the ultimate conclusion as to what is
the truth a perfect example
of why
the evidence should come from witnesses
rather than lawyers
can be seen from the fact that
throughout these proceedings lawyers on
both sides have tried to characterize
what is the evidence and try to
characterize the interpretation that
this body should
adopt
i'm reminded of when we were before the
judiciary committee
just before we voted articles of
impeachment
white house counsel suggested to our
committee
as they do before this body
that the president's state of mind
during his various statements under oath
were intended to mislead people
but to be truthful
they say the president didn't lie
instead they say he carefully crafted
these hypertechnical definitions to
protect himself from any perjury charge
we believe the evidence will show that
by so doing
paula jones was denied the information a
federal judge said she was entitled to
have and thereby perjury and obstruction
of justice lie
before the judiciary committee
mr ruff reaffirmed this was the
president's strategy this is what mr
ruff told our committee
question to mr ruff
i do want to make sure i understand your
position
from the beginning
the president takes the position that he
never lied to the american people or
while giving testimony under oath
essentially he simply misled them with a
different definition
and he was sending the same message both
to the american people and the court
answered by mr ruff i think that is fair
congressman yes
question
and he did that intentionally because in
his own mind he drew a distinction
between the technical definition of
sexual relations and the definition of
improper relationship or something along
those lines which is how he now
characterizes his relationship with
monica lewinsky answered by mr ruff yes
i think that's correct
question you suggested earlier in your
testimony
this is a distinction that he has drawn
since the jones deposition
my notes indicate you said the
definitions are ones that he held in his
mind in january and in august and he is
so testified answered by mr ruff yes
question
in determining whether the president
either perjured himself or lied under
oath in this matter you are asking this
committee to look at his state of mind
from the beginning of this whole episode
and make that determination
answer
yes
members of this body we suggest that the
evidence has shown and the evidence will
further show by the calling of the
witnesses that we propose
that the president denied under oath
specific facts that were relevant to the
case relevant to the jones case relevant
to perjury and obstruction
the perjury obstruction investigation of
the grand jury
and in so doing among the other lies
that my colleagues have pointed out
we will show that he lied to his aides
and this is important
because he admitted he knew
the president admitted he knew
that his aides were potential witnesses
in a criminal investigation before the
grand jury
this is the portion of the grand jury
transcript where the president testified
about his conversations with key aides
once the monica lewinsky story became
public
question to the president
did you deny to them or not mr president
answer
i did not want to mislead my friends but
i wanted to find language where i can
say that i also frankly do not want to
turn any of them into witnesses because
i and sure enough
they all became witnesses
question
well you knew they might be witnesses
didn't you
answer
and so i said to them things that were
true about this relationship
that i used in the language i used i
said there is nothing go on between us
that was true
i said i have not had sex with her as i
defined it that was true
and did i hope that i would never have
to be here on this day giving this
testimony of course but i also didn't
want to say to do anything to complicate
the matter further so i said things that
were
true
the president's position
is they were misleading
but they were true
no lies and that is precisely what mr
ruff told the judiciary committee and
that is the position that white house
counsel takes before this body
now remember
the grand jury was conducting a criminal
investigation
they were seeking evidence of possible
perjury and obstruction of justice and
the white house contends before this
body that the president did nothing
to obstruct their investigation the
evidence shows that he did and one of
those witnesses
who will demonstrate that to this body
is the president's own aide sidney
blumenthal and that is why we request we
request this body
allow mr blumenthal to be deposed and
further we hope that you will allow him
the opportunity to testify before you so
that you can gauge his credibility in
his demeanor as he presents the answers
that we expect he will give
mr blumenthal's testimony puts him in
direct conflict with the claims of the
president and shatters the myth of the
president's truthful but misleading
answers given under oath now just for a
quick
way of background mr blumenthal on
january 21st 1998 was an assistant to
the president that was the day the
monica lewinsky story broke in the
national press through the washington
post
that story broke in the morning
later the same day mr blumenthal met
both with the first lady and then with
the president to discuss these news
revelations
one month later
mr blumenthal was called to testify
before the grand jury his testimony was
not particularly helpful during that
time because to most of the questions
that involved conversations
that he had at the white house mr
blumenthal claimed executive privilege
that issue was apparently litigated and
then he returned in june to testify
before the grand jury twice on june 4th
and on june 25th 1998
when mr blumenthal was free to share his
recollections of the events
this is how mr blumenthal characterized
his meetings with president and mrs
clinton before the grand jury and it's
interesting to note by the way that
there was a dual lie going on here from
the president the president was lying to
his wife who could never be called as a
witness against him but he was also
lying to his aides whom he admitted he
knew could be called
this is from mr blumenthal's testimony
on june 4th
the first lady said that she was
distressed that the president was being
attacked in her view for political
motives
for his ministry of a troubled person
she said that the president ministers to
troubled people all the time
and he does so out of religious
conviction
and personal temperament
and the first lady said he had done this
dozens if not hundreds of times with
people
the president came from a broken home
and this was very hard to prevent him
from trying to minister to these
troubled people
so i related that conversation to the
president
and i said to him that i understand that
you want to minister to troubled people
that you feel compassionate but that
part of the problem with troubled people
is that they are troubled
i said however your president and these
troubled people can just get you in
incredible messes
you have to cut yourself off from them
and he said meeting the president
he said
it's very difficult for me to do that
given how i am
i want to help people
then mr blumenthal testified the
president said dick morris suggested
that the president go on television and
admit in a national address whatever he
may have done wrong
once again mr blumenthal testified
and i said to the president
what have you done wrong
and he said
nothing
i haven't done anything
wrong
and i said well then that's one of the
stupidest ideas i've ever heard why
would you do that if you've done nothing
wrong
and it was at that point that he gave
his account of what happened to me and
he said that monica
and it came very fast
he said
monica lewinsky came at me and made a
sexual demand on me
he rebuffed her he said i've gone down
that road before i've caused pain for a
lot of people and i'm not going to do
that again
she threatened him
she said that she would tell people they
had an affair that she was known as the
stalker among her peers and that she
hated it and if she had an affair or
said she had an affair then she wouldn't
be the stalker anymore
and i repeated to the president that he
really needed never to be near people
who were troubled like this that it was
just he needed not to be near troubled
people like this and i said you need to
find some sure footing here some solid
ground
and he said i feel like a character in a
novel i feel like somebody who is
surrounded by an oppressive force that
is creating a lie about me
and i can't get the truth out i feel
like the character in the novel darkness
at noon and i said to him i said when
this happened with monica lewinsky were
you alone
he said well i was with an eyesight or
earshot of someone
i said you know there are press reports
that you made phone calls to her and
that there's voice mail
did you make phone calls to her
he said that he remembered calling her
when betty curry's brother died and that
he left a message on her voice machine
that betty's brother had died
and he said he was close to betty and
had been very kind to betty and that's
what he recalled
and then at his june 24th deposition mr
blumenthal expanded on this uh theme he
was asked the question in your
conversation with the president when he
stated that monica lewinsky threatened
to disclose an affair or fabricate an
affair in a public disclosure did you
understand him to be saying that if the
president didn't concede or didn't agree
to have some type of sexual contact with
her she would report the affair
answer
my understanding was that she demanded
to have sexual relations he rejected her
and she said that this is i recall him
saying
that they call me the stalker that's
what lewinsky said and if i can say we
had an affair then they won't call me
that something like that
question now you previously
characterized ms lewinsky's comments to
the president as a threat if you will
answer right
yeah i would interpret that's my
understanding
then mr blumenthal told the grand jury
about the impact the president's
emphatic denials had upon his state of
mind the mind of a potential grand jury
witness
question
in response to my question how you
responded to the president's story about
a threat or discussion about a threat
from ms lewinsky you mentioned you
didn't recall specifically do you recall
generally the nature of your response to
the president
answered by the president
i'm sorry answer by mr blumenthal
it was generally sympathetic to the
president and i certainly believed his
story
it was a very heartfelt story
he was pouring out his heart
and i believed him
question did the president explain to
you what monica lewinsky's trouble was
that he was helping answer no and did
you ever ask him no
did anyone else including the first lady
tell you what monica lewinsky's trouble
was that the president was ministering
about
answering no
question what did you understand the
president to mean
why he had done nothing wrong
answer my understanding was that the
accusation against him which appeared in
the press that day was false that he had
not done anything wrong
questioned that he had not had any sort
of sexual relationship answer he had not
had a sexual relationship with her and
had not sought to obstruct justice or
suborn
perjury
mr blumenthal then went on to say that
he asked the president about some of
these reports that there were phone
calls between him and monica lewinsky
question did the president say anything
to you about telephone calls with monica
lewinsky answer as i testified
i had said to him that there were
reports of that his voice was on her
voicemail her tape machine at home to
take message
message machine
and he said to me that he could recall
that after betty's brother died he may
have called monica because monica had
been very close to betty and betty
didn't have a way of relating to her
that her brother had died
so that he had called and left a message
that betty's brother died question did
he suggest to you
that that was the only call he had ever
made to monica lewinsky answer that's
the only one he told me about question
did you ask him if there were any more
calls than that answer
he said that's the only one
he could remember well we now know
certainly from white house logs
that the only one the president can
remember isn't quite true that in fact i
believe it was over 50 telephone
conversations between the president and
monica lewinsky
and it begs the question why was the
president on the day the story broke
pulling his aides in to relay
information that the president knew was
patently false when he knew that they
were potential witnesses before the
grand jury
now it's important to remember that this
testimony from mr blumenthal was given
one month before monica lewinsky decided
to opt to cooperate with the office of
independent counsel
thus these questions were asked of him
in a vacuum without the benefit of ms
lewinsky's extensive testimony as well
as the president's own grand jury
testimony and the house managers agree
that these in other areas need to be
more fully explored
with mr
with the gentleman under oath in light
of the later revelations that occurred
surrounding this case
now we know a couple of things we know
that the
that the monica lewinsky story broke on
january 21st we know that the president
spoke to sidney blumenthal the very same
day we know the president said he knew
his aides could be potential witnesses
before the grand jury and we also know
that mr blumenthal was called three
times before the grand jury once in
february twice
in june there's an important question
that was never asked mr blumenthal
during his testimony it could not have
been asked because at the time he
testified
the revelation that the president shared
with america in august and monica
lewinsky's revelation had not yet been
aired
if the president knew that mr blumenthal
was going to be a witness a potential
witness before the grand jury
if six months after this story broke the
president presumably knew that his aid
had gone down not once but twice to the
grand jury i'd like to know from mr
blumenthal
did the president ever come up to you
and say something to you did he ever say
to you do you remember that story i told
you back in january
well now that you're actually going to
be a witness now that you're going down
to testify before the grand jury
i don't want you to give the grand jury
a false impression i don't want you to
give false information to the grand jury
i don't want you to be a cog in the
wheel of an obstruction of giving the
grand jury the opportunity to hear the
truth
i need to recant for you what i told you
there's no evidence of that
and we'd like to find that out
and the only way we can do that is by
deposing mr blumenthal and hopefully
bringing him in and sharing that
information with this body
another area we would like to inquire
about
is the area of a potential plan to
destroy monica lewinsky if she ever
decided to cooperate with law
enforcement authorities
mr blumenthal told the grand jury that
following the monica lewinsky news
revelations
white house aides held twice a day staff
briefings briefings at 8 30 in the
morning and at 6 45 in the evening every
day
to discuss among other topics the media
impact of the lewinsky scandal and how
to deal with it in the press
mr blumenthal testified that the primary
purpose of these meetings was to discuss
press strategy
in making his presentation at the
judiciary committee last month chief
investigative counsel david shippers
related
some of the quotes that emanated in the
press
following the lewinsky story i just want
to read a few paragraphs from mr
shipper's presentation
worst of all in order to win it was
necessary to convince the public and
hopefully the grand jurors who read the
newspapers that monica lewinsky was
unworthy of belief
if the account given by monica was
believed then there would emerge a
tawdry affair in and near the oval
office moreover the president's own
perjury and that of monica lewinsky
would surface
how do you do this
congressman graham showed you you
employed the full power and credibility
of the white house and its press corps
to destroy the witnesses
mr shippers then quoted from several
news sources now this is just a few days
after
the president told mr blumenthal that
monaco is known as the stalker
inside the white house the debate goes
on about the best way to destroy that
woman as president clinton called monica
lewinsky should they paint her as a
friendly fanaticist or as a malicious
stalker
again
january 30th
it's also very easy to take a mirror's
eye view of this thing look at this
thing from a completely different
direction and take the same evidence and
posit a totally innocent relationship in
which the president was in a sense the
victim of someone rather like the woman
who followed david letterman around
from another source
one white house aide
called reporters
one white house aide called reporters
to offer information about monica
lewinsky's past
her weight problem and what the aide
said was her nickname
the stalker
just hours after the story broke
one white house source made unsolicited
calls offering that lewinsky was the
troubled product
of divorced parents
and the reference goes on and on you can
find the complete reference in the
committee report
now the question is was this a mere
coincidence that the president's false
statements to mr blumenthal about monica
lewinsky being a stalker
quickly found their way into press
accounts even though those accounts are
attributed by the press to sources
inside the white house
the answer to the question is yes it's a
coincidence according to white house
counsel and we heard that from them just
three days ago mr ruff said in his
presentation and i'm quoting
the white house the president the
president's agents the president's
spokespersons
no one has ever trashed threatened
maligned or done anything else to monica
lewinsky
no one
mr blumenthal needs to be questioned now
under the light of the facts as we now
know them all we have from mr blumenthal
are the facts as he testified
before the revelations saw the light of
day and he needs to be questioned for
the benefit of those who most who must
make the determination of credibility
and the determination of guilt or
innocence this is the reason we've
included mr blumenthal
on our proposed list he is just one
example of several aides whose testimony
is already before you in the record but
we feel it would be beneficial not only
for the body to hear him but certainly
to question him in light of the
revelations that occurred following his
grand jury testimony mr chief justice
with that we reserve the balance of our
time
very well the chair recognizes mr
manager kendall for the white house
council
mr chief justice
ladies and gentlemen the senate
house managers
the purpose of the manager's motion
and what i'm going to address
is whether you need to add any evidence
to the record before you
and that's all i'm going to address
today now i'm tempted and it's like
waving a red flag at the bull
to take on the substantive arguments
that have been presented here as to why
the president is guilty i'm going to
refrain from doing that but my
refraining from doing that is not
because i agree with them but we've
already addressed them and i think here
that the proper procedure is just to
address the need for new evidence to add
to the record before you
the manager's case is in no way
no way
harmed
by being unable to call witnesses at
this point the independent council
conducted a wide-ranging investigation
it was intense it was comprehensive of
every conceivable
allegation against the president after
the lewinsky publicity erupted on
january 21 1998
in the record of the publicly available
materials
which the senate asks
has asked the house managers to certify
the actual number of pages is somewhat
understated because as i've mentioned
before frequently four or six pages of
transcript are reproduced on a single
page of the bound volume but in fact
there are over ten thousand pages of
grand jury testimony over 800 pages of
other testimony such as depositions 3
400 pages of documentary evidence
1800 pages of audio transcripts and 800
and some pages of fbi interviews
the office of independent council has an
unlimited budget
with unlimited investigative resources
ranging from the fbi to private
investigators its agents interviewed
people all over the country
used several different grand juries
conducted hundreds of interviews even
called people back from abroad
if the oic could have turned up anything
that was negative or pub or prejudicial
it would be in those volumes
so you can rest assured that they did
their best to find that evidence and the
star team has been fully supportive
of the pro
impeachment forces in the house of
representatives indeed so supportive
that the independent council's ethics
advisor professor sam dash resigned to
protest mr starr's zealous advocacy
of the impeachment of the president
just this weekend mr starr and his staff
have aggressively continued to support
the house managers during these senate
proceedings some commentators have
commented that the independent council
is perhaps the honorary 14th house
manager
now i rehash this all not to cast
aspersions uh at mr star but to remind
the senate that after five years and 50
million dollars president clinton may be
the most investigated person in america
i will certainly say this for mr star he
is thorough
he is thorough
after all the work that has been done
for them
by the indica independent council
there's simply no way that the house
managers are prejudiced by not being
able to add to this record at this point
now
mr manager mccollum
repeated
this morning that we are afraid of
witnesses
we are not
we have reviewed in detail in our
presentations what the evidence shows
about both the perjury and the
obstruction of justice
allegations
we are not at all afraid of what the
witnesses would say indeed we know what
they're going to say because it's all
right there in the volumes before you
we think that you have everything there
on the basis of which you can make a
fair judgment and achieve a fair
resolution
the managers
hope to call more witnesses is simply a
product of their desire their hope their
prayer that something will come to
rescue their case
let's be clear about one thing
any delay in the process
necessary for us to have fair discovery
is on their heads
our point here is that there's simply no
need to go outside this record because
what you have before you is voluminous
and it's a completely adequate basis for
your decision as i pointed out the other
day in the questioning period the only
thing left out of this record is
evidence that might be exculpatory or
helpful to the president and if we must
we will as conscientious lawyers seek
out that helpful
additional evidence through discovery
this body
has been scrupulously fair
in these proceedings and i am confident
it will be fair
if
concerning our need for discovery if the
genie of discovery is let out of the
bottle and live witnesses are deemed to
be appropriate
then we're going to need a fair period
of time for our own discovery
but again the point is today on this
motion
that the managers have simply identified
no particularized need for witnesses no
specific areas of testimony that might
contribute to what is already
in the record and indeed no questions no
material questions you can always think
of questions they're unasked but no
material questions given the allegations
in the two articles that are not in the
record before you
just recall in the house
the managers believed that this was an
adequate record
to come to you and urge removal of the
president
they rested on that record in the house
and they impeached an elected president
on the basis of that record
they cannot now complain
that it is for some reason unfair to
submit this same record to you for
judgment at this point
uh we're not afraid of or reluctant to
call witnesses but we think at the end
of the day
the addition of more testimony from the
three witnesses you've heard about
won't affect any evidentiary judgment
you've got to make
mr manager barr
declared during his presentation a week
ago friday on january the 15th that this
was in fact a relatively simple case
although we the white house lawyers
would try to nitpick the evidence he
told you what we have before us senators
and mr chief justice is really not
complex
critically important yes but not
essentially complex
the able house managers have kept
insisting on their need for witnesses
but they haven't asked they haven't
indicated what substantial material and
relevant questions the witnesses
would be asked which haven't already
been asked or why such questions are
essential or even relevant to the
resolution of this proceeding
frankly i think this is because there
just aren't that many more questions to
ask of these witnesses and mr manager
mccollum
kind of let the cat out of the bag on
this one when a week ago friday he told
you i don't know what the witnesses will
say but i assume if they're consistent
they'll say the same thing that's in
here
i was surprised at some of the
statements the managers made during the
questioning period on friday and
saturday mr bryant said we would very
much like to talk to some of these
witnesses and he added it was very
critical that you talk to the witness
before having that witness testified
mr just mr manager mccollum stated as a
matter of fact we think we would have
been incompetent and derelict as
presenters of the evidence if we hadn't
talked to them first just this sunday mr
manager hyde on meet the press
observed that the purpose of the
court-ordered office of independent
council chaperone interview of ms
lewinsky uh last sunday was to get a
sense of what kind of a witness she'd
make
i say this respectfully
but i am duty-bound to observe that it
is in fact
a dereliction of duty to have come this
far in the process
to have made this serious set of charges
as have been made against the president
to seek his removal and not to have
talked to the witnesses on whom they
purport to rely
how can they have come this far and now
tell you oh yes we now need to meet face
to face with the witnesses we don't know
what they sound like we don't know how
credible they'll be we've we've rested
our judgment on this
we we need to see them personally
this procedure i submit to you is just
backwards first they file the charges
which have been spoon fed by mr star
they don't bother to check these out
they take them at face value
now they finally want to talk to the
witnesses and they again use mr starr
to threaten ms lewinsky with
imprisonment unless she cooperates with
him now it's no answer to say that the
witnesses didn't want to talk to us
there was a way to talk to them in the
house of representatives and that was
through the subpoena power that the
house could have used
if they had wanted to talk to their
witnesses if they had fulfilled the
obligation they had
before they proffered these charges to
you
this has been a partisan process
on the part of the house managers
in the house they had the votes they
didn't think they needed to talk to
witnesses
when you have the votes and the
independent counsel on your side you
don't need to independently develop the
evidence indeed sunday on cnn mr manager
cannon
provided some insight mr chief justice
yes the chair recognizes the senate from
arkansas i would object to the white
house council's continual reference to
comments made on television programs
outside of the record that is before the
senate
uh
this this is on a motion to call
additional witnesses and because the
argument has been very
uh
free-form and kind of far-ranging i
think this is permissible comment and so
i overrule the objection
thank you mr chief justice
i think mr manager cannons
comments did provide some insight into
the need for witnesses or the
justification for witnesses here
he noted that the republicans had lost
five seats in the november election and
he went on to say accordingly the
republicans felt a need to speedily
complete impeachment in the lame duck
session before the 106 began its session
uh he said that the republicans on the
judiciary committee would be were
committed to be done by the time we got
done and that's where we got on that
track with no witnesses
now they're trying to take a different
track
uh
and i think it comes from desperation
you've had the case analyzed before you
you've had the case the the evidence in
the case assessed and i think it's been
demolished in an adversary proceeding
the house managers are like
the character in david copperfield mr
micawber who was always hoping that
something would turn up
they continue to hope that something
will turn up for them they don't know
what it is but they believe they'll know
it when they see it and they hope if for
the first time in these proceedings they
actually talk to the witnesses on whom
they've relied they'll find something to
persuade you to overcome the evidence in
the record
now
the managers have said well
we told the white house that it could
have called witnesses they could have
called witnesses in the house if they
want to and they chose not to do so so
it's really their fault
i respectfully submit to you however
that only in the world of franz kafka
do you have to present evidence of your
own innocence before you even hear the
charges or the allegations against you
it was the burden of the house to
establish by an adequate
evidentiary basis a case for impeaching
the president
they failed to do that i respectfully
submit and they're a little like a
blackjack player who sees
20 on the table and has 19
and is going to try to draw that to
hoping against the odds
here they're simply gambling and
gambling may have its place as a
recreation i think it has no place in
the impeachment trial here in the
when when the fate of the president is
at stake now
i don't want to be uncharitable
to the house managers and they are able
but i think it is perhaps appropriate to
remind you as my partner miss seligman
did in her argument yesterday
that in their own chamber
in their own chamber the house managers
sang a very different song about the
need for witnesses
and to be fair this was not just one
manager they sang as kind of a
barbershop chorus
[Applause]
most of them are on the record to this
effect and i think the very best
witnesses
you have about the need for witnesses
are the house managers themselves
let's listen to some of the comments of
the of the managers on whether live
witnesses needed to be heard to
supplement the evidence in in the many
volumes already gathered by the
independent council
for example
on
november the fifth
mister manager hyde said
we believe the most relevant witnesses
have already testified at length about
the matters an issue and in the interest
of finishing our expeditious inquiry we
will not require most of them to come
before us to repeat their testimony
he added that monica lewinsky and linda
tripp have already testified under oath
we have their testimony we don't need to
reinvent the wheel
the very the very next day on november
the 6th mister manager geekes testified
or stated uh bringing in witnesses to
rehash testimony that's already
concretely in the record would be a
waste of time and serve no purpose at
all
on december the 1st
during a hearing before the house
judiciary committee at which the
committee received testimony concerning
the consequences of perjury and related
crimes mr manager chabot
stated
we could call more and more and more
witnesses we are trying to get this
wrapped up as expeditiously as possible
i think both sides want to do that if we
call more witnesses and drag this on
into next year then they are going to
scream because they say we are on a
fishing expedition we have already got
enough evidence
at that same hearing uh mr manager
kennedy
said of the need for witnesses
now we do have a responsibility to make
certain we act on a solid basis we
should not move forward with articles of
impeachment on the basis of
insubstantial evidence i think all of us
agree on that the fact of the matter is
that we have a mountain of sworn
testimony
on december the 9th congressman kabul
who was a member of the house judiciary
committee told us during our
presentation on behalf of the white
house
mr ruff i want to address a couple of
myths
and one myth is that we have no evidence
because there have been no fact
witnesses called
five volumes sit alongside me these are
the same five volumes that are at our
table
that contain sworn testimony before a
criminal grand jury fbi interviews
depositions and other materials
mr manager hyde made two statements uh
on the floor of the house of
representatives during
the debate over the articles of
impeachment which i think bear quotation
here
uh on december the 18th
mr manager hyde stated
we had the facts and we had them under
oath
we had ms lewinsky's heavily
corroborated testimony under a grant of
immunity that would be revoked if she
lied we accepted that
and then the next day
on saturday december the 19th
mr manager hyde stated no fact witnesses
i've heard that repeated again and again
look we had sixty thousand pages of
testimony from the grand jury from
depositions from statements under oath
that is testimony that we can believe
and accept we chose to believe it and
accept it why reinterview betty curry to
take another statement when we already
had her statement why interview monica
lewinsky when we had her statement under
oath and with a grant of immunity that
if she lied she would forfeit
why interview monica lewinsky when we
had her statement under oath and with a
grant of immunity that if she lied she
would forfeit
now after the house voted
it's two articles of impeachment
the house managers still
saw no need for live witnesses
on december 29th mr manager geekis
stated we're going to have to make the
case that there is already enough
testimony under oath in grand jury
testimony and affidavits and then again
a week later mr manager geeker stated in
my judgment there might not be any real
rationale for calling linda tripp or
betty curti or vernon jordan if the
testimony of monica lewinsky is accepted
as being what she offered on grand jury
terms
roll call
reported on january the 7th that mr
manager cannon stated regarding calling
ms curry as a witness in the senate
trial
i am reluctant to call miss curry
because it's a rotten nasty thing to do
to a public servant
when confronted with this
inconsistency
the managers who are talented
attorneys and successful congressmen
have all argued well the forum has
changed as if it's no big deal for the
house to impeach a president without
witnesses but it would be unconscionable
for the senate to acquit the president
without first doing some rotten nasty
things mr manager cannon sprays to some
witnesses
how can you have a trial they protest
without witnesses
one might ask how can you have a hearing
without witnesses but the house did
how can you impeach a president without
witnesses well the house showed us
finally it's instructive to note that
when the managers
were presenting their case in the house
when the judiciary committee did they
did not declare that they would insist
on witnesses when they got to the senate
they did not tell their colleagues we
won't need witnesses in the house
because we'll have them in the senate
nope they rushed this through the house
because they had the votes and now they
want to delay in the senate because
they're afraid they don't have the votes
there is no reason we respectfully
submit to delay in this chamber to drag
out these proceedings and defer doing
the business of the american people now
i'd like to discuss
each of the five categories i'll call
them categories there are there are
three witnesses and then there is the uh
there the two affidavits and then the
telephone records they're really six i'd
like to discuss these in terms of
whether
they add anything or whether the
managers have made a proffer that they
had anything to their record is now
which is now before you because i think
that's the question you've got to
determine on this motion you're not
voting whether substantively to convict
the president you're simply determining
is the record adequate
let's first take ms lewinsky
on sunday
the house managers with the general
assistance of the independent council
prosecutors were able to interview miss
lewinsky after schlepping her across the
country from california
they did so despite the fact that the
senate had established by a 100 to zero
vote a procedure for the orderly calling
of witnesses after discussion and debate
they did so after declining to interview
ms lewinsky at any time during the house
proceedings when they could have
compelled her appearance by the house
subpoena power
and they did so without providing us
here any reliable record for what that
talk fest on sunday may have produced
now newspaper reports indicate that the
managers did not
take notes you'll recall of course that
during the questioning period on
saturday
they explicitly rejected a request they
received during the question period that
they provide either an unedited
transcript or a videotape of that
interview to be sure that the interview
would be open to scrutiny for fairness
and ascertain whether miss lewinsky in
that interview really did add anything
to the record
they declined to do that
but when they emerged from the mayflower
hotel on
sunday afternoon for their sidewalk
press conference we heard from them
general statements
generally commending ms lewinsky
mr manager bryant called her an
impressive person mr manager hutchinson
praised her intelligence and poise and i
thought to myself where we heard that
before about ms lewinsky and it was deja
vu all over again of course we heard it
from mr jordan
from ambassador richardson and from the
people who interviewed miss lewinsky for
a job in new york it's helpful that the
house managers have now at least
confirmed those observations in the
record
at their press conference we heard the
managers make some abstract
pronouncements about what ms lewinsky
was going to add that she'd be a
valuable witness she'd be a helpful
witness
uh
and it was a productive meeting of
benefit to our case that was what we
heard
but miss lewinsky's lawyer
mr plato cacheras
threw if i may if i may say some cold
water on those happy and optimistic
pronouncements
it could have not been clear
in his comments that
not surprisingly nothing new whatsoever
had emerged from that session you really
didn't hear that uh the the the i think
the house managers were quite honest
about the session because you heard
nothing about what had emerged from that
today
mr caceres told the press conference
that some of you may have seen it
ms lewinsky answered all their questions
there was nothing new she added nothing
to the record that is already sitting
before the senate she shouldn't be
called to the senate
to testify
the new york times reported yesterday
that after the interview
ms lewinsky told a friend it went really
well i feel positive about it but i
didn't have anything new to say
now according to the washington post the
managers were focused on making sure ms
lewinsky had no intention of changing
her testimony
the washington post went on to confirm
that she did not
indicate any uh
desire to change her testimony in any
way and the post article continues that
in fact lewinsky reaffirmed her grand
jury statement that no one ever asked
her to lie or offered her a job in
exchange for a false affidavit in the
jones case
now as you are well aware
ms lewinsky was interviewed
extensively by the office of independent
council she testified twice before the
grand jury she gave a lengthy deposition
to the prosecutors
uh she was extensively interviewed by
the agents there are over 20 interview
reports i should also add that a great
deal of this comes after the president
was examined in the grand jury on august
the 17th
ms lewinsky has given detailed
an explicit testimony particularly in
her
august 26th deposition
as to her account of the physical
relationship she had with the president
nothing at all will be added by further
interrogation of her uh nothing could be
gained by
repetition in a senate deposition or in
the well of this body by that
a repetition of that testimony
i confess i don't fully understand i i
seem to hear mr manager bryant and mr
manager mccollum say slightly different
things about what they intended to
present uh in the way of of ms
lewinsky's testimony the record on that
is what it is but whenever i hear
somebody tell me as mr the very able mr
manager bryant did
you know they don't need to
cross-examine really
i'm reminded of what senator bumper said
and he got it from h.l mencken who
probably got it from somebody else the
more they say you don't have to
cross-examine the more need i feel to
cross-examine
i don't know what they intend to do
there but in the grand jury the
president plainly acknowledged an
improper relationship with miss lewinsky
he declined to answer further questions
about that the office of independent
counsel did not seek either to compel
him or it didn't seek to issue a new
grand jury subpoena which would cause
the president to come back and go
through those explicit details
the testimony is what it is and i don't
think anything further from ms lewinsky
is gonna in any material way affect it
or even add to it
with regard to some of the conflicts
that are there i think we've addressed
those in the question period i'm not
going to go over them again in full
did the improper relationship began in
november or did it begin six or seven
weeks later
that conflict is utterly immaterial i
respectfully submit in view of what the
parties have acknowledged
uh mr manager hyde indeed stated in a
house judiciary committee hearing on
december the first that that particular
point did not strike him as a terribly
serious count and i agree with that
the managers have claimed mr manager
hutchinson claimed this morning that
there is a contradiction in the
president in the testimony of the
president and miss lewinsky with regard
to cover stories
this is not true we've gone over that uh
again and again there's nothing that
links this testimony to any uh
deposition in the jones case these were
discussed the record shows in a
non-legal cons
context
i don't think that there is anything
further to be gained from ms lewinsky's
testimony that is not already there in
the record now
mr vernon jordan let's take him
mr manager hutchinson was kind enough to
leave up here his uh
copies of mr vernon jordan's five
appearances before the grand jury he
held them up on a chart
and it's i think proper
to point out that mr jordan's testimony
runs to over 900 pages
on march 3rd the transcript is 196 pages
two days later on march 5th
with the transcript running to 212 pages
mr jordan emerged from the grand jury
and he made the following statement
which i'd like to play for you
first of all
it is a fact
that i
helped
mana lewinsky
find
private employment in new york secondly
it is a fact that i
took monica lewinsky to a very competent
lawyer
frank carter here in washington dc
and thirdly is the fact that i kept the
president of the united states
informed about my activities
i want to say two further things
one is
i did not
in any way
tell her encourage her
to lie
and secondly
that my efforts to find her job
were not
a quid pro quo
for the affidavit
that she signed
mr jordan testified a third time before
the grand jury on may 5th
and that transcript runs to 285 pages
finally testified two more times
on may the 28th for 128 pages and he
observed as he exit as he exited the
grand jury room if we could have the
video again
for the fourth time
i have answered
every question
over
and over
and over again i suspect that i will
have to answer
the same questions
over
and over and over again
and guess what mr jordan was clairvoyant
because he was called back to the grand
jury for a fifth time on june 9 and he
said as he exited
when i came here on march early march
i said that
i helped ms lewinsky get a lawyer
i helped her
get a job
i had assurances that there was no
sexual relationship
and i did not tell her to lie
that was the truth then
and that is the truth today
and i have testified five times over and
over again
to those truths
one of the justifications mr manager
hutchinson
offered for calling mr jordan was to
explore an alleged conflict between mr
jordan and ms lewinsky over whether mr
jordan had told her to go home and make
sure that notes she had been keeping
were not there
here i think
mr manager hutchinson is referencing a
statement that ms lewinsky made in her
proffer
to the office of independent council
describing her recollection of a
breakfast she believed she had with mr
jordan
it's in the appendix
volume at page 716. now the thing to
note ladies and gentlemen about this
statement is its date ms lewinsky said
this on february 1st 1998.
she'd written then that she'd expressed
concern about mr miss trip to mr jordan
and that miss tripp may have seen notes
when she was in ms lewinsky's house
according to the proffer mr jordan asked
if the notes were from the president ms
lewinsky said that they were notes to
the president mr jordan suggested to ms
lewinsky the proffer says that she
checked to make sure they were not there
or something to that effect close quote
from ms lewinsky
now
contrary to this supposed conflict
mr jordan was never asked in the grand
jury on any of the five occasions he was
there
all of which i remind you were after
this february one proffer about this
matter
he wasn't asked about it
it doesn't concern the president in any
event and i think most importantly it's
nowhere alleged if you look in the
actual
articles if you look at article 2
nowhere is this conversation alleged in
any way as a basis for impeachment a
basis for charging the president with
obstruction
i think in fact it is a gratuitous smear
of mr jordan and it certainly does not
provide a basis
for
extending this proceeding to ask him
questions about it
now mr manager hutchinson also claimed
that there is a conflict between the
testimony of ms lewinsky and mr jordan
on the issue of whether they discussed
specific changes
that were subsequently made in her
affidavit he he said to you that he
thought that was a basis for calling
them as witnesses
however the record is clear it could not
be clear that the idea of certain
deletions in the affidavit uh came from
ms lewinsky's lawyer mr frank carter as
i mentioned in my presentation on
thursday ms lewinsky discussed that she
had she had talked to mr jordan about
some
affidavit changes and he told her go
talk to your lawyer in any event ms
lewinsky's lawyer mr frank carter
testified unequivocally to the grand
jury
i don't recall vernon ever asking me the
substance of what monica told me
or trying to talk about what the
substance of what monica told me he
clearly never told me how i should
proceed or what i should
do mr carter further testified
that paragraph six of the affidavit uh
in its draft form as the last part of a
sentence has certain words about a
private meeting that paragraph
mr carter ms lewinsky's lawyer testified
was modified when we sat down in my
office on january 7th
uh he further testified that it was his
idea before that meeting to take it out
because he didn't want to give miss
jones lawyers any hint of a one-on-one
meeting
there is simply no basis
to call mr vernon jordan
once again to have him go through the
things he's testified about a great many
times already now
we come to sydney blumenthal
mr manager rogan
very ably argued
that there was a need
to call mr blumenthal
because of mr blumenthal's testimony as
to what the president had told him
sidney blumenthal in the aftermath of
the explosion of publicity over the
lewinsky matter in january a year ago
well first of all there is no conflict
here that is material because the
president has never
disputed
mr blumenthal or his aids accounts of
this conversation
the
any dispute is wholly immaterial as to
the two counts of the the two articles
of impeachment
the president was examined extensively
about this subject in his own grand jury
testimony and he testified as to what he
tried to say but he also added that in
this period things were a blur
the term he used one time a blizzard was
a term he used another time
that he'd had discussions with a number
of his aides including mr blumenthal
he tried to be careful in what he said
he thought he was technically accurate
but he would not dispute and did not
dispute their characterizations of what
they recalled of the conversations with
him
again mr blumenthal mr rogan pointed
this out testified three times before
the grand jury
his recollection of his conversations
with the president has been analyzed in
detail and a further round of deposition
would add nothing of substance to that
testimony
indeed in the president's speech
to the nation the day of his grand jury
speech
his grand jury testimony when he spoke
to the nation the evening of august 17th
also represented an acknowledgement by
the president that he had misled his
aides
such as sydney blumenthal
as i indicated last thursday however any
statements to the white house staff
could have had no impact whatsoever on
the paula jones case as article 2
alleges each of the seven grounds has
because mr blumenthal had no firsthand
knowledge of the president's relation
with ms lewinsky he could only report to
the grand jury what the president had
told him however misleading
those statements of the president may
have been at the time
there is no dispute here there's no
material reason to call mr blumenthal
except to try to embarrass the president
by the presentation of testimony from a
member of his senior staff
now the next two
things that the
managers would seek to add to the record
or not
they tell you live witness testimony but
don't let that fool you
they want to put in two sworn deficits
two sworn uh declarations it's like an
affidavit
from two people
one of them is a mr wesley holmes a
lawyer for miss paula jones
and the other is mr barry ward
now i don't have the pleasure of knowing
mr wesley holmes but i do know
mr barry ward he is a very intelligent
very hard working and knowledgeable
young lawyer in little rock arkansas who
works as a law clerk for chief judge
wright he's got an encyclopedic
knowledge of razorback athletic lore
he has a lot of
fine characteristics he's very helpful
as a law clerk he gets information to
you and back very officially but there
is one thing
mr ward is not and i'm sure he would
agree with that he's not a mind reader
he's not a mind reader there were a
number of people in the room at the
deposition
none of them were mind readers they
could all give their testimony about
what they thought was going through the
president's mind the president has
addressed that a number of times you've
seen the videotape now the second
witness is exceedingly interesting
and that is mr holmes and mr holmes
would give a sworn declaration to among
other things say what he had in mind
when he issued the witness uh subpoena
to betty curry which was several days
which days after the president's
conversation with her on december the
18th
well
this would be he would be a very
interesting witness to depose let me
tell you
this is one of paula jones lawyers
talking about offering a declaration
about his litigation strategy and i
think that the opportunity to depose him
would uh provide a great deal of
information about what really motivated
the events of january uh 1998 i think we
could show
that there were a number of connections
between the independent council linda
tripp and the paula jones lawyers but i
don't think you need to get into that
briar patch because mr holmes is not a
mind reader any more than mr ward is
you simply don't need
that testimony to illuminate the record
now
the
last category
and let me let me just before i leave
that make the point that while the
managers would like very much to throw
in a couple of sworn declarations
uh
if
you you you should be assured of our
need to take discovery and in mr holmes
case take comprehensive discovery i
don't think anything in s res 16 i don't
know that you've gotten to this but i
don't read the resolution as authorizing
simple hearsay evidence we would need to
depose the paula jones lawyers in some
detail and i think they've now waived
significant
legal protections that would make that
possible
finally there was a category of
telephone records it's a little hard to
address that category those are just
documents i don't think the record need
be expanded by their edition and i'll
tell you why
telephone records as i said the other
day really tell you nothing unless there
is it's very important to time to date a
particular call
they really are inscrutable you've got
to have the witness to testify about
what they mean i don't see anything in
there that would justify opening the
record to add certain telephone records
finally i want to be candid with you i
don't want to be alarmist i want to be
honest though about what opening the
door to discovery will mean for this
process
i said before that the senate had been
fair in these proceedings and it has
been fair i think the identification of
a specific record
which the parties could agree on have in
the sunlight talk about argue about was
the fair thing to do and the right thing
to do i think if discovery is inevitable
we will
anticipate and believe that you will be
fair in
in allowing us the discovery we're going
to need now i would ask you if you would
to read our trial memorandum because at
pages 124 to 130 we've set forth there
our need for discovery it's not a new
invention
uh should the the senate decide to
authorize
the house managers to call additional
witnesses
live in this proceeding or have their
depositions taken we will be faced with
a critical need for the discovery of
evidence useful to our defense i made
the point that the discovery of evidence
in the office of independent council
proceeding was not to put too fine a
point on it not aimed at getting us
exculpatory or helpful evidence we need
to be able to do that we've never had
the kind of compulsory process kind of
ability subpoenaed documents and
witnesses that you would have in in a
garden variety civil case
we have not had access
to a great deal
of many thousands of pages of of
evidence which is first of all in the
hands of the house managers that they
got from the office of independent
counsel but did not put into the public
record did not print up we also
need
discovery of those
other documents
witness testimony transcripts interview
notes other materials which may be
helpful or exculpatory that are in the
hands of the independent counsel
our dilemma is this we do not know
what we do not know that's what
discovery means you've got to get
discovery so you can find out what is
available it may not necessarily prolong
a trial but it makes you available to
defend your client in the way you've got
to be able to do as a lawyer
it doesn't turn on the number of
witnesses
the calling of these witnesses uh
you know
produces a need in us to be ready to
examine them to cross-examine them it
initiates a process that leaves us
unprepared and exposed unless we have
adequate discovery this is a proceeding
i need not remind you i know everyone
recognizes its gravity to remove the
president of the united states you have
got to give us and i believe you will
the discovery that will enable us to
represent the president adequately
competently and effectively
now the sequence of discovery is also
important i want to be clear about that
it's all very well and i recognize how
it happens for one side to say well
we're going to put on three witnesses
and they can put on three witnesses well
ladies and gentlemen the senate we don't
know right now how to make a reasoned
choice because we haven't had the
discovery you would normally have to do
that we would first need to obtain and
review the relevant documents i've
indicated where those are
uh we then need we would then need to be
able to depose relevant witnesses we
need to know whether the witness
depositions that the house managers
had taken would need to lead to other
depositions there
only at that point when we've had
discovery of our witnesses will we be
able to identify the witnesses we might
want to call
this is a logical procedure and and i
think those of you who've tried cases
will recognize it as such
it's simply impossible from where we now
are to see how a witness designated by
the house managers can be fairly
rebutted without ourselves having
uh access to all of the available
evidence
given what is at stake i think
fundamental fairness
requires
fair discovery we will be expeditious
but in the event the genie is out of the
bottle
we need time we need access to defend
the president in the way any client
ought to be defended now i think the
senate has wisely elected
to proceed on a voluminous record a
record that is available for public
scrutiny that was assembled by people
not favorable to the president i think
you have enough evidence to make your
decision on the basis of that record
but in the event you decide to expand it
affording us adequate discovery is
essential if we're going to really
practice the rule of law as i believe
the senate would intend for that rule of
law to be practiced in its proceedings
but let me conclude
by saying that
i don't think and i respectfully submit
to you that there is a need to prolong
this process
we hope
that you will render
your dece decision in a manner that is
speedy and we're confident that you'll
decide you'll make that decision in a
manner that is fair
and this body will so often it's done in
past times of crisis
be able to bring to the country both the
closure and reconciliation
that the country wants so very much
thank you
does counsel for the president have any
more presentation
mr chief justice i would reserve the
remainder of my time no you can't
reserve it it's uh uh open uh respond
and rebuttal
i will then quit claim the rest of my
time very well
do
mr chief justice may i inquire as to how
much rebuttal time we have remaining
30 minutes
thank you mr chief justice i will
be brief and and ask other managers to
come up to follow me i have four
uh quick points to make and
before i get into that i want to thank
my distinguished colleague from d.c mr
kendall
over my practice of law for several
years i've received a number of
jabs before in the courtroom but never
so gentle and ever so eloquently and i
thank you
i think his
presentation was very good but probably
makes the best
illustration of why witnesses are needed
in that he has chosen to use selective
quotes he likes to use those quotes and
point to the managers over there where
we were quoted without a real context
there and certainly that's what this
hearing has been about so far both sides
picking and choosing among quotes that
best illustrate the point we want to
make at the time but really what we need
is the is the big picture the entire
complete picture of witnesses that only
witnesses can provide in this case but
let me go back to a couple of the
selective quotes and that is
the quotes that we made back in the
house when we were involved in the
proceedings which i would remind each
one of you involve these very same
stacks of books here the record that
they have so
uh shown you in the past and in a very
uh
i guess very often form that this is the
record here why do we need to go outside
the record well that very same record
was there in the house and it was at
that time that mr lowell the minority
council uh
was representing the president's
interests but also mr kendall was there
and in fact both together examined uh mr
starr
that was when they were making the
request for the witnesses based on this
very same record notwithstanding that we
need witnesses
uh i simply point that out to you to
show you
that
mr kendall and his uh very talented
staff do not have a monopoly on
consistency
another example of selected quoting
has to do with quotes made about our
occasion to visit ms lewinsky to talk to
her this is the one witness we've not
been able to talk to and
he pulled those quotes out as if we need
to talk to all the witnesses we don't
need to talk to all the witnesses but we
needed to sit down and talk with her
and and i might tell you that she was
very able represented by three attorneys
she had as many lawyers there as we did
and perhaps more so she was not imposed
upon
the um and i think in terms of my
statement about discovery
i i think i perhaps was misunderstood
but i certainly conceded that the white
house might want to discover to pose
miss lewinsky but i still have a hard
time
determining why they would need to
discover what miss curry might want to
say who sits right outside the
president's office every day or what mr
jordan might say who plays golf with mr
clinton practically every day or mr
podesta his former chief of staff i'm
just trying to save
this senate some time and question why
we would need to go through discovery of
those types of people
and my last point i'd like to make
before i bring mr hutchinson in
mr kendall mentioned a point and i'm not
sure where he was going in terms of
perhaps trying to worst case the this
situation in terms of it taking forever
and a day to conclude
discovery of all kinds of witnesses and
alluded to needing to take all the
lawyers for paula jones
and questioning her motivation
i would suggest to you that a real clue
to her motivation for this lawsuit was
the
we could say the 850 000
reasons motivation that she received the
other day
but let me end with that note and and
bring up mr hutchinson who will continue
this process thank you
the chair recognizes mr hutchinson
thank you mr chief justice
i'll just take a moment
mr kendall did an outstanding job as he
always does in making his case for not
calling witnesses
i thought the most compelling example as
to why we need witnesses was the fact
that he called a live witness vernon
jordan
mr jordan
testified
here in this
chamber
why did they not present a transcript
why did he want to bring a live witness
because it was real
it was alive he was more meaningful than
a transcript he told the story in short
concise ways that i have not been able
to do
during my
presentation during the last week we
would like to have the same opportunity
not through video but to present a live
witness so that he could cross-examine
so that we could question i think that
is a fair proceeding
now mr kendall raised the point that
the
statements about
the notes
that miss lewinsky testified she
discussed with mr jordan were referenced
in her february 98 proffer
when i was making my point i was
referencing her august grand jury
testimony not the february proffer
because my recollection is that february
proffer that was submitted by mr
ginsburg had subsequently become a
subject of litigation because they were
not able to reach an immunity agreement
and so perhaps that was the reason that
that subject was not inquired into
with by the independent council for
whatever reason my review the
transcripts is that that subject was
never broached with mr jordan i don't
profess perfect knowledge of it but that
is
my understanding of it
and then
finally i want to also look at the
discovery that mr bryant
uh referenced uh there was a gambling
illustration that mr kendall used
uh about blackjack well another part of
poker is bluffs
and i don't know whether they're
bluffing i don't know whether they're
serious
about all the discovery that they need
to have
but i know that lawyers do that
sometimes to intimidate to scare you
away but i think even most more
importantly
is that the house managers have
submitted to the rules of the senate
we weren't particularly happy about all
of them
but we recognized it was important to
have legitimacy this process we accept
that we move on i would hope that
whatever rules on discovery whatever
limitations you wish to put whatever
time frames you wish to put
that the white house counsel will be as
amenable to the desire of this senate
and this nation to conclude this as we
have been in adopting what our desires
are to your schedule i yield to mr
mccullum
the chair recognizes mr manager mccollum
mr chief justice thank you very much
i want to make a couple of observations
and one of them seems pretty apparent mr
kendall says they're not afraid and that
i was wrong in characterizing
them as being afraid the white house
counsel of calling witnesses but i'm
going to tell you i can't rationalize
any other way why he be out here making
the pitch as hard as he is against
witnesses especially
the sort of threat that this is going to
go on and on and on if you open the door
and we call three witnesses
you know we're down from thinking we
ought to have 10 12 maybe 15 witnesses
to three monica lewinsky vernon jordan
and sydney blumenthal
and we've introduced three or proposed
introduced three
very simple pieces of new evidence that
can't take a lot of discovery to need to
go further than that you know if he
wants to produce witnesses that's fine
but but i just can't imagine why that
opens that door mr holmes he talks about
the attorney
what's the significance of that
declaration or affidavit that sworn
declaration that we'd like you to take
in that he says well we've got to depose
mr holmes about
that was put in very simply because the
council on the other side
i don't accuse them of doing it
intentionally but the other day they
misled us our i think unintentionally
misled you
uh on the idea that the president at the
time that he left the deposition
in the jones case and went over to talk
to betty curry the next day
uh didn't and couldn't have had any idea
that that she was going to be called as
a witness in fact i think they said
there she never was on a witness list
and she never was subpoenaed what mr
holmes declaration does as i said
earlier is bring into the record
the subpoena that in fact was issued
within a day or so of of that time
of when betty curry was talked to
remember we talked to her twice
the notice about it and her name being
put on the witness list that's what
that's all about and a general
explanation of why they chose as
attorneys to make that
case why they chose to put her name out
there and subpoena her so that it's
clear on the record very simple if you
look at it and i'm sure you'll have it
for you to consider his declaration is
very short it's like three paragraphs
and it goes straight to the point and it
encloses these accompanying documents so
i don't think you should for one minute
think that opens the door to some great
big gigantic long new discovery period
that is simply an idle threat
to intimidate in my judgment with a
proper intimidation effort proper tactic
i don't accuse them anything improper
uh you to try to discourage you from
letting us have these three witnesses
second i want to point
out that with respect to some of the
things that i said uh one thing i did
say earlier is i don't know what all the
witnesses would say if we call them i
don't know what they all will say
certainly
but i would expect them all to be
consistent with what they've already
said in their sworn testimony and
there's nothing inconsistent with my
expecting them to be consistent on the
facts we already know
since that sworn testimony in the case
of monica lewinsky she has immunity that
if she deviates and
and goes off of it she could get herself
in trouble
but by no means does my expectation that
the testimony you already have will
remain true mean that i don't think
there are new things to be brought out
or that you shouldn't have live
witnesses here and i thought it
interesting that mr kendall totally
ignored
the one thing that was most significant
in my mind
and that is the whole idea
that
there is a need for witnesses out here
to determine their credibility
to check their demeanor to see that how
they respond to questioning to do all of
those things that i described earlier
that any reasonable attorney in any
courtroom setting in this country in a
criminal case and you do have to decide
whether the crimes are committed or not
would expect to do so you can as my
colleagues have said look them in the
eye
and make that determination yourself
he didn't even address that and i think
that that alone is sufficiently good
reason to have a live witness here as i
said before to you so with that in mind
i will yield to mr robin
the chair recognizes mr rogan
members of the
senate kendall made a very able
and strong presentation it was
particularly effective when he brought
up a series of quotations from house
members and house managers talking about
the need for witnesses or the lack
thereof
it would be more effective
if it were presented in context but it
could not be
because the context of every single one
of those quotations was in reference to
the distinction between the house's
function as the accusatory body
versus the senate's constitutional
function
of being the body where an impeachment
case is tried
there he blurs the distinctions
that's why in the constitution
a president is impeached
solely on a majority vote
but removal requires at the trial
a two-thirds vote
now mr kendall's presentation begs the
question
did the founders get it wrong
when they designed this process
did the founders simply intend
to intend for us to waste our resources
rather than conserve them and simply do
the very same thing first in one body
and then in the other with the sole
distinction that the only difference
would be the ultimate vote
that was not their intent that was not
the procedure established by the
constitution and it is not the procedure
recognized throughout the country in
court proceedings there is a reason
why courts of inferior jurisdiction
will be able to hold a defendant in a
criminal case
to answer for trial at a preliminary
hearing based on hearsay testimony based
on transcripts based solely on police
reports
but that defendant at a trial
has a constitutional right to come
forward and the right to confront and
cross-examine witnesses is supreme and
guaranteed in the constitution because
the framers understood the difference
even if white house counsel refuses to
acknowledge the difference
now the argument they have really isn't
with the house managers their argument
is with the precedence of the house
their argument in fact is with people
like the venerable barbara jordan our
late distinguished former colleague she
understood the difference between the
house's function in an impeachment role
versus the senate's function
she said during the rodino
hearings in establishing the division
between the two branches of the
legislature the house and the senate
assigning to one the right to accuse
and to the other the right to judge
the framers of the constitution
were very astute
they did not make the accusers and the
judges the same
person
now
in the words of yogi berra i feel that
we're going through deja vu all over
again with mr kendall's able proceeding
because what he has accentuated
in this presentation has been
accentuated by white house counsel ever
since they first rose to address this
body at the lectern
and that is the complaint
that no witnesses were called
before the house judiciary committee
and how wrong it is for members of the
house managers now to assert the need
and the right to have witnesses before
this body when in fact no witnesses were
called before the judiciary committee
once again he mistakes the function
of the two houses
but i would invite the members of this
body if that is an issue concerning them
to go back and review the voluminous
transcripts during the judiciary
committee
where chairman hai did everything but
get on his knees and beg the members of
the president's defense team beg our
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle to identify for us which witnesses
they wished to dispute what facts they
wanted to challenge let us know who the
witnesses are where there is a
contention
in the evidence
and despite their complaining
and despite their griping and describe
despite their their anger over a
supposedly unfair process they never
once identified in the factual record
whose testimony they wished to challenge
what we heard repeatedly day after day
in the hearing and outside before the
cameras was an attack upon the process
rather than an identification of the
issues where there are factual disputes
in fact they refused to identify
despite the repeated pleas of chairman
hyde who those witnesses are that they
felt were appropriate because the
chairman said tell us who they are we
will call them
they champion the cause of witnesses and
word
but they do not champion the cause of
witnesses indeed at least
not in the house
because the same people who were
complaining of the unfairness in the
house for not having witnesses suddenly
have an allergic reaction
to the concept of witnesses being called
before this body where it counts the
most where the ultimate decision is to
be made where the triers of fact have to
make the constitutional decision whether
the case is sufficient for removal of
the president
and mr kendall's repeated hints and
statements that somehow they were denied
some form of due process in the house by
not being able to call witnesses is
patently unfair
and does not withstand the test of the
record
chairman hyde alluded to it a couple of
days ago and based upon mr kendall's
presentation i feel it's worth a minute
or two of this body's time
mr kendall has stated in these
proceedings and i'm quoting
we have never had the chance to call
witnesses ourselves to examine them to
cross-examine them to subpoena
documentary evidence at no point in this
process
the record is to the contrary on october
5th
the house passed a procedure by voice
vote which included the right to call
witnesses on october 21st the house
judiciary committee staff met with mr
ruff kendall and craig
at that time judiciary committee staff
asked the white house to provide any
exculpatory information and provide a
list of any witnesses the president
wished to call
on november 9th the house judiciary
committee staff wrote to missouri's ref
kendall and craig and again informed
them of the president's right to call
witnesses on november 19th independent
council star testified before the house
judiciary committee
the president's council was given the
opportunity to question the independent
council the president's council did not
ask a question relating to the facts of
the independent council's report and
allegations against the president
on november 25th chairman hyde wrote a
letter to the president asking the
president among other things to provide
any exculpatory information
and inform the committee of any
witnesses he wished to call
on december 4th two working days before
the presentation of the president to the
judiciary committee counsel for the
president requested to put on 15
witnesses the white house was allowed to
present all 15 witnesses and not a
single one of the 15 witnesses that they
wished to call that they asked to call
were factual witnesses
and so the complaints of unfairness
are unfair
one other point i want to make
because again i see a reversal in rules
is that mr kendall
can't seem to decide
what type of ogre role he wants to
portray us
because he said in his presentation just
a few minutes ago
that we were somehow at least he alluded
to the fact that we were somehow tools
of judge star and the office of
independent council and i was a little
surprised to hear him suggest
that judge starr
spoon fed us the charges
and that judge star spoon fed them to us
to the point where he didn't know
whether judge starr should be deemed an
honorary member of the house management
team
well that's an interesting proposition
because it seemed to me just a day or
two ago
the same lawyers who are now making this
allegation
were claiming constitutional unfairness
before this body and asking that this
body dismissed the articles of
impeachment why
because the house judiciary committee
and the managers
didn't present the exact same charges
that the independent council suggested
you can't have it both ways
you can't fashion the argument
depending on what the result is being
sought and yet that is exactly what the
man with the white house counsel are
attempting to do
yesterday we were renegades who didn't
follow the strict rules of judge star
and didn't give them proper notice now
of course
he is the marionette and we are the
puppets doing his will
members of this body it is the job of
the house of representatives it is the
constitutional obligation of the house
of representatives to act as the
accusatory body in an impeachment
proceeding
the constitution gives the authority to
this body
the right to try that case
this is the place for trial this is the
place to determine guilt this is the
place to determine credibility
this is the place for witnesses
mr mr chief justice i yield the balance
of our time to our distinguished
chairman of the house judiciary
committee
the chair recognizes mr manager hyde
remaining mr knight mr chief just
i won't use the entire nine minutes uh
mr chief justice distinguished counsel i
and and and senators um i'll be very
brief uh just a mr rogan and my
colleagues have handled this very well
but just a couple of things i want to
talk about
it is disturbing it's annoying
it's irritating
when i hear that
the
counsel for the president have been cut
off from information and data we've
sequestered things on them
i pleaded with them to produce witnesses
made the subpoenas available to them
they have a positive allergy to fact
witnesses
oh they'll come up with academics we saw
a parade of professors
you know what a what an intellectual is
it's someone who's educated beyond their
intelligence
and
i certainly don't mean that of some of
those harvard professors that they
paraded out even though we disagreed
with them but you would you would get
eye strain looking for a fact witness
and it is remarkable the flexibility
they have
they complained that we called no
witnesses in the house now they're
complaining that we're calling witnesses
in the senate
as though they don't understand the
difference in the threshold
there we had to prove we had enough to
submit to the senate for a trial but not
try it over there and a majority vote
prevails over there here
you have an extraordinary mountain to
climb a two-thirds vote and the trial is
here
and that's the difference and witnesses
help you
they won't help me
i know the record i'm satisfied a
compelling case is here
for
removal of the president
but they will help you
and we aren't dragging this out we have
been
as swift as decency will let us be in
throughout this entire
uh situation
their defense has never been on the
facts
if they can come up with a good fact
witness that has something to say
we will see a reenactment of the indian
rope trick
it seems to me we will see professors
though
uh if passed is prologue i don't know
but the threat of
the threat of prolonged hearings i
suppose is supposed to make you tremble
it doesn't to me but then
different things different strokes i
guess for different folks but
their defense has been to demonize
mr starr
to a fare thee well and to yell about
the process that has been their defense
and i'll i'll be frank with you i'm not
sure i could stand a lot more of that
but uh that's what they will do
um as far as the information not
available to them maybe not maybe some
of the stuff we got from the independent
council was held in executive session
but it was available to mr conyers it
was available to abby lowell it was
available available to every democrat on
the judiciary committee and they went
through it
i wrote with mr conyers to mr star a
letter saying
show us what you didn't send this let's
look at what you've got over there there
might be some exculpatory material
and mr conyers sent his people over and
they looked
and they looked
and they looked
and i would assume they were in touch
with you folks i would assume they were
if they weren't they should have been
that's a breakdown in communication
now we can we have a good case we have
an excellent case without the witnesses
but the witnesses help you
we have narrowed it down to three a
pitiful three
and i should think you would want to
proceed
with that minimum testimony and mr
kendall can try his
cross-examination skills on them and
that i want to watch thank you
uh the the the time of both sides has
now expired the chair recognized the
majority leader mr chief justice uh in
view of the time that we've been in
without break
the next pending business is that we
would be in order to have
a motion by senator harkin or senator
wellstone
but before we do that i would suggest
that without objection we take a
15-minute break in the absence of
objection it's or the senators please
stand and wait until the chief justice
leaves the chamber
careers on the line by opposing what
they call the popular vote of the people
i would like to remind everyone that the
president cannot push his any agenda
forward without votes in the senate and
in the in the house of representatives
and he has done everything good
with the aid of a republican majority
congress
mr chief justice um i ask unanimous
consent that during each day that the
senate seats sits as a court of
impeachment it'd be an order for
senators to submit to the desk
statements and introduce legislation
in the absence of objection it's so
ordered
now uh mr chief justice i believe uh at
this point it would be an order uh for
uh a motion to be made that we go into
open debate uh if any and then when that
is dispensed with we would go to uh the
move to close and and would deal with
that issue and then we would begin the
closed session and so i believe we're
ready for a motion to be offered if any
at this time
the chair recognized the senator from
iowa mr harkin mr chief justice and
according with rule accordance with rule
5 of the senate standing rules
i found a motion of intent to move to
suspend the rules
to open debate
on this motion to subpoena witnesses
the emotion is at the desk and it's
numbered number five i believe the clerk
will report the motion
the senator from iowa mr harkin for
himself and mr wellstone moves to
suspend the to suspend the following
portions of the rules of procedure and
practice in the senate when sitting on
impeachment trials in regard to debate
by senators on a motion
to subpoena witnesses during the trial
of president william jefferson clinton
won the phrase without debate in rule 7
2 the following portion of rule 20
unless the senate shall direct the doors
to be closed while deliberating
upon its decisions a motion to close the
doors may be acted upon without
objection
or if objection is heard the motion
shall be voted on without debate and by
yeas and nays which shall be entered on
the record
and three in rule 24 the phrases without
debate
except when the door shall be closed for
deliberation and in that case
and to be had without debate
senator from iowa i asked the a's and
these
is there a sufficient second
there is
the clerk will call the roll
mr abraham
mr abraham no mr akaka
mr akaka i
mr allard
mr allard no
mr ashcroft
mr ashcroft no
mr baucus
mr baucus no
mr bai
mr bai
i
mr bennett
mr bennett no
mr biden
mr biden i
mr bingaman
mr bingaman
aye
mr bond
mr bond no
mrs boxer
mrs boxer
i
mr bro
mr bro i
mr brownback
mr brownback no
mr brian
mr brian
i mr bunning
mr bunning no mr burns
mr burns no
mr bird
mr campbell
mr campbell no mr chafee
mr chafee no
mr cleland
mr cleland aye
mr cochran
mr cochrane no
ms collins
ms collins i
mr conrad
mr conrad i mr coverdale
mr coverdale no mr craig
mr craig no
mr crapo
mr crapo no
mr daschle
mr daschle i mr dewine
mr dewine
no
mr dodd
mr da
i
mr dominici
mr dominici no mr dorgan
mr dorgan aye mr durbin
mr durbin aye mr edwards
mr edwards aye mr enzi
mr nz
no
mr feingold
mr feingold i
mrs feinstein
mrs feinstein
i
mr fitzgerald
mr fitzgerald
no
mr frist
mr frist no
mr gorton
mr gorton no
mr graham of florida
mr graham of florida i
mr graham of texas
mr grahams of minnesota
mr grahams of minnesota
no
mr grassley
mr grassley no mr greg
mr greg
no mr hegel
mr hegel no
mr harkin
mr harkin aye mr hatch
mr hatch no mr helms
mr hollings
mr hollings i
mr hutchinson of arkansas
mr hutchinson of arkansas no
mrs hutchison of texas
mrs hutchison of texas i
mr inhofe
mr inhofe no
mr in nowhere
mr inouye aye mr jeffords
mr jeffords no
mr johnson
mr johnson
aye
mr kennedy
mr kennedy
i
mr kerry of nebraska
mr kerry of nebraska aye
mr carey of massachusetts
mr cole
mr cole
i
mr kyle
mr kyle no
ms landrieu
ms landrieu no
mr lautenberg
mr lautenberg i mr leahy
mr leahy i
mr levin
mr levin i mr lieberman
mr lieberman i
mrs lincoln
mrs lincoln no
mr lot
mr lot no mr luger
mr luger no
mr mack
mr mack no
mr mccain
mr mccain no
mr mcconnell
mr mcconnell no
ms mikulski
mr moynihan
mr moynihan aye mr murkowski
mr murkowski no
mrs murray
mrs murray i mr nichols
mr nichols no
mr reed of rhode island
mr reed of rhode island i
mr reed of nevada
mr reed of nevada i
mr rob
mr rob i
mr roberts
mr roberts no mr rockefeller
mr rockefeller no mr roth
mr roth no
mr santorum
mr santorum
no
mr sarbanes
mr sarbanes i
mr schumer
mr schumer aye mr sessions
mr sessions no
mr shelby
mr shelby no
mr smith of new hampshire
mr smith of new hampshire no
mr smith of oregon
mr smith of oregon no
miss snow
miss snow
no
mr spector
mr specter i
mr stevens
mr stevens no
mr thomas
mr thomas no mr thompson
mr thompson no mr thurman
mr thurman no
mr torricelli
mr torres selly aye
mr vornovich
mr warner
mr warner no
mr wellstone
mr wellstone i mr wyden
mr wyden i
mr helms
mr helms no
mr bird
mr byrd no
mr graham of texas
mr graham of texas no
uh the chair recognizes the senator from
massachusetts
mr kerry of massachusetts
mr kerry of massachusetts no
on this vote the yeas are 41 the nays
are 58.
two-thirds of those senators voting a
quorum being present not having voted in
the affirmative the motion is not agreed
to
the majority
the chair recognizes the majority leader
mr chief justice uh
that motion being defeated i believe
it's now in order to move to close the
session so that we can have debate on
the question of the motion subpoena
witnesses the
the majority leader is correct
i shall move uh mr chief justice
the question is on the motion
all in favor say aye
those opposed no
the motion carries
mr chief justice uh i'd like to ask that
the senators remain at their place but
we'll put in a request for a quorum just
momentarily so the appropriate
arrangements can be made for the uh
closed session and mr chief justice i
would suggest the absence of the court
the clerk will call the roll mr abraham
the public portion of today's session of
the senate is now over that was the
arguments on a motion for witnesses the
motion the arguments made by the
president's council and also the house
managers acting as prosecutors in this
case the senate now moving to go into
closed session there'll be three hours
in the session equally divided it'll
also be a dinner break of about an hour
and once the closed session is over
senators will adjourn for the evening
right now in a quorum call preparing for
the closed session which is expected to
come up momentarily
once senators have gone into that closed
session we will again be opening our
phone lines and i believe that the
president should be acquitted first of
all i don't believe that he committed
perjury because i believe that his
values and his um views on
sex
are different than the people that were
questioned that he had gotten questioned
by
um for instance my view on sex
what constitutes sex
is different than the person across the
street from me
and if i was underneath those and i said
something that i didn't believe was sex
and i said that
then
that is what i believe but i believe in
i don't bel you know it's it's a matter
of like perception of what something is
and i don't believe that he was he was
conscience
consciously trying to lie
to the grand jury
i don't believe that he is he is guilty
of obstruction because monica lewinsky
has said numerously in 23 other
instances that
she had
i went to center
the senate will convene as a court of
impeachment
the chaplain will offer a prayer
dear god
leadership has its defining days
in which crucial decisions must be made
you know that this is an important one
of those days
in a few moments votes must be cast
now in the quiet
the senators wait to be counted
it's a lonely time
beyond party loyalties
those on both sides of the aisle
long to do what ultimately is best for
our nation
debate has led to firm convictions
give the senators the courage of these
convictions
and the assurance that
if they are true to whatever they now
believe is best
you will bless them with peace
we intercede for them
and the heavy responsibilities they must
carry
imbue them with your calming spirit
and strengthen them with your gift of
faith
to trust you to maintain unity
once the votes are tallied
we commit the results to you
our times
are in your hands
through our lord and
savior amen amen
the senators will be seated
the sergeant-at-arms will make the
proclamation
hear ye hear ye
hear ye
all persons are commanded to keep silent
on pain of imprisonment while the senate
of the united states
is sitting for the trial of the articles
of impeachment exhibited by the house of
representatives against william
jefferson clinton
president of the united states
if there's no objection the journals of
proceedings of the trial are approved to
date
the majority leader is recognized
mr chief justice
in a moment we will begin two
consecutive votes the first will be on
the motion to dismiss
and that would be followed by an
immediate vote on the motion to subpoena
and following those votes
there will be an opportunity to describe
how we would go forward from there
with the
depositions i've discussed this with
senator daschle and
it is uh
likely that we would
take a break at that point so that we
could have further discussions with our
conferences is make sure we understand
how that subpoena and deposition process
would go forward
i have a resolution prepared we have
some simpler ones that we can consider
but we would want to discuss those with
each other during the vote and perhaps
even after the two votes occur depending
on what the results are
the idea is that we have
now before us s res 16 which has brought
us to this point to these two votes
we need to give some consideration to
making sure we understand how the
process will go forward
to a conclusion
after that
i thank my colleagues for their
attention and i believe that we're ready
for the votes mr chief justice the
question occurs on the motion to dismiss
the impeachment proceedings offered by
the senator from west virginia mr burr
the yeas and nays are required the clerk
will call the roll
mr abraham
no
mr abraham no
mr akaka
mr akaka
i
mr allard
mr allard
no
mr ashcroft
mr ashcroft no
mr baucus
mr baucus aye
mr bai
mr bai
i
mr bennett
mr bennett no
mr
biden mr biden i
mr bingaman
mr bingaman aye
mr bond
mr bond no
mrs boxer
mrs boxer i
mr bro
mr bro
i
mr brownback
mr brownback no
mr brian
mr bunning
mr bunning no
mr burns
mr burns no mr bird
mr bird
aye
mr campbell
mr campbell no
mr chafee
mr chafee no mr cleland
mr cleland i
mr cochrane
mr cochran no
ms collins
ms collins no mr conrad
mr conrad aye mr coverdale
mr coverdale
no
mr craig
mr craig
no
mr crapo
mr crapo no
mr daschle
mr daschle i
mr dewine
mr dewine no
mr dodd
mr dodd i
mr dominici
dominici no
mr dorgan
mr dorgan
i
mr durbin
mr durbin i
mr edwards
mr edwards i
mr enzy
mr nz
no
mr feingold
mr feingold no
mrs feinstein
mrs feinstein i
mr fitzgerald
mr fitzgerald no
mr frist
mr frist no
mr gorton
mr gorton no
mr graham of florida
mr graham of florida i
mr graham of texas
mr graham of texas no
mr grahams of minnesota
mr grahams of minnesota no
mr grassley
mr grassley no
mr greg
mr greg
no
mr hegel
no
mr hegel no mr harkin
mr harkin aye mr hatch
mr hatch no
mr helms
mr helms no
mr hollings
mr hollings i
mr hutchinson of arkansas
mr hutchinson of arkansas no
mrs hutchison of texas
mrs hutchison of texas no
mr inhofe
mr inhofe no mr in no way
mr noah aye
mr jeffords
mr jeffords no
mr johnson
mr johnson i
mr kennedy
mr kennedy i
mr carey of nebraska
mr kerry of nebraska i
mr carey of massachusetts
mr kerry of massachusetts i
mr cole
mr cole i
mr kyle
mr kyle no
ms landrieu
ms landrieu
i
mr lautenberg
mr lautenberg i mr leahy
mr leahy i
mr levin
mr levin
i
mr lieberman
mr lieberman i
mrs lincoln
mrs lincoln aye mr lott
mr lot no
mr lugar
mr luger no
mr mack
mr mack no
mr mccain
mr mccain no
mr mcconnell
mr mcconnell no
ms mikulski
ms mikulski no
mr moynihan
mr moynihan
aye
mr murkowski
mr murkowski
no
chair recognizes the senator from
maryland every time i wish to state i
made an error in my vote i went to vote
yes may i do that now or wait to the end
the record may so show
i vote yes
ms mccall
miss mikulski
i
mrs murray
mrs murray i
mr nichols
mr nichols
no
mr reed of rhode island
mr reed of rhode island i
mr reed of nevada
mr reed of nevada
i
mr rob
mr rob i
mr roberts
mr roberts
no
mr rockefeller
mr rockefeller i
mr roth
mr roth no
mr santorum
mr santorum no
mr sarbanes
mr sarbanes aye
mr schumer
mr schumer
mr sessions
mr sessions
no
mr shelby
mr shelby no
mr smith of new hampshire
mr smith of new hampshire no mr smith of
oregon
mr smith of oregon no
miss snow
miss snow
no
mr specter
mr spector no
mr stevens
mr stevens no
mr thomas
mr thomas no
mr thompson
mr thompson
no mr thurmond
mr thurman no
mr torricelli
mr torricelli i
mr vornovich
mr vornovich no
mr warner
mr warner no
mr wellstone
mr wellstone i
mr wyden
mr wyden i
they're from nevada
you reported his voting eye
mr brian mr brian i
okay
on this vote the yeas are 44
the nays are 56
the motion is not agreed to
now the question occurs on the motion
requesting the appearance of witnesses
at a deposition to admit evidence
offered by the managers on the part of
the house of representatives the yeas
and nays are required the clerk will
call the roll
mr abraham
mr abraham aye
mr akaka
mr akaka
no mr allard
mr allard
i mr ashcroft
mr ashcroft
i
mr bacchus
mr bacchus
no
mr bai
mr bai
no
mr bennett
mr bennett
i
mr biden
mr biden
no
mr
bingaman mr bingaman
no mr bond
mr bond
i
mrs boxer
mrs boxer
no
mr bro
mr bro
no
mr brownback
mr brownback
i
mr brian
brian
no
mr bunning
mr bunning
i
mr burns
mr burns i mr byrd
mr bird
no
mr campbell
mr campbell
i
mr chafee
mr chafee i
mr cleland
mr cleland
no
mr cochran
mr cochrane
i
miss collins
ms collins
i
mr conrad
mr conrad
no
mr
coverdale mr coverdell
i
mr craig
mr craig
i
mr crapo
mr
crapo i
mr daschle
mr daschle
no
mr dewine
mr dewine
i mr dodd
mr dodd
no
mr domenici
mr domenici
aye
mr
dorgan mr dorgan
no
mr durbin
mr durbin
no
mr edwards
mr edwards no
mr nz
mr nz
i
mr feingold
mr feingold
i mrs feinstein
mrs feinstein
no
mr fitzgerald
mr fitzgerald
i
mr frist
mr frist
i
mr gorton
mr gorton
i
mr graham of florida
mr graham of florida
no
mr graham of texas
mr graham of texas
i
mr grahams of minnesota
mr grahams of minnesota i
mr grassley
mr grassley
i
mr greg
mr greg
i mr hagel
mr hagel
i
mr harkin
mr harkin
no
mr hatch
mr hatch
i
mr helms
mr helms
i
mr hollings
mr hollings
no
mr hutchinson of arkansas
mr hutchinson of arkansas
i
mrs hutchison of texas
mrs hutchison of texas i
mr and hoff
mr enhoff
i
mr noah
mr noa
no
mr
jeffords mr jeffords
i
mr johnson
mr johnson
no
mr kennedy
mr
kennedy no
mr carey of nebraska
mr carey of nebraska
no
mr kerry of massachusetts
mr kerry of massachusetts no
mr cole
mr cole
no
mr kyle
mr kyle
i
ms landrieu
ms landrieu
no
mr lautenberg
mr lautenberg
no
mr leahy
mr leahy
no mr levin
mr levin
no
mr lieberman
mr lieberman
no
mrs lincoln
this is lincoln
no
mr lot
mr lot
i
mr luger
mr luger
i
mr mack
mr mack
i
mr mccain
mr mccain
aye
mr mcconnell
mr mcconnell
i
miss mikulski
ms mikulski
no
mr moynihan
mr moynihan
no
mr murkowski
mr murkowski
i
mrs murray
mrs murray
no
mr nichols
mr nichols i
mr reed of rhode island
mr reed of rhode island
no mr reed of nevada
mr reed of nevada
no mr robb
mr robb
no mr roberts
mr roberts
aye mr rockefeller
mr rockefeller
no
mr roth
mr roth
i
mr santorum
mr santorum
i
mr sarbanes
sarbanes
no mr schumer
mr schumer
no
mr sessions
mr
sessions i
mr shelby
mr shelby
i mr smith of new hampshire
mr smith of new hampshire
i
mr smith of oregon
mr smith of oregon
i
miss snow
ms snow
i
mr specter
mr spector
i mr stevens
mr stevens
i
mr thomas
mr thomas i
mr thompson
mr thompson
i
mr thurman
mr thurmond
i
mr torricelli
mr torres ellie
no
mr voynovich
mr voinovich
i mr warner
mr warner
i
mr wellstone
mr wellstone
no mr wyden
mr wyden
no
on this vote the yeas are 56
the nays are 44 the motion is agreed to
the chair recognizes the majority leader
mr chief justice has
indicated earlier
we're attempting now to
clarify
exactly how this will proceed and to
reach agreement with regard to
the remaining procedure and and the
beginning of the deposition process
we're acting in good faith but we want
to make sure we're at least going to try
to think about all contingencies uh and
uh we're exchanging uh uh
resolutions and suggestions between
senator daschle myself at this time
we may be asked to vote later on today
uh on a procedure
uh we will let you know uh if if that is
necessary today it could happen tomorrow
but we don't want it to go much longer
than that because we need to make sure
this procedure is going forward and of
course if we don't have a resolution uh
i presume it'll begin to go forward
anyway but we'd like to have some
orderly procedure as we have had in the
past
but uh we
my thinking at this time is that we
would just stand in recess subject to
call the chair while we talk this
through it may not be necessary to
do anything further as far as a recorded
vote but it may be so we just want you
to be on notice of that therefore i ask
unanimous consent to mr chief jeffers
that the senate stand in recess subject
to the call of the chair in the absence
of objection it's so ordered
after taking two votes in the
impeachment trial of the president of
the united states the senate standing in
recess subject to the call of the chair
while details are being worked out about
where to proceed next we are going again
to take this opportunity ohio favoring
acquittal
please
we'd like to hear your comments well i'm
favorite acquittal why
uh i just think since president zario
thank you mr chief justice
first i want to thank all the members
and all concerned for their patience
throughout this process
we have had a productive day and i
believe this recess that we've been
experiencing has been very helpful in
allowing further discussions to occur
and to clarify exactly what the
procedures will be
uh from here through
the uh subpoena and deposition process
and and hopefully even to a conclusion
senator daschle and i have uh traded
proposals which outlined those
procedures for the remainder of the
trial and although i don't want to go
into the detail at this time i will say
that both of the proposals bring us to a
final vote on the pending resolutions or
on the pending articles of impeachment
in an expeditious manner
we have
been
narrowing
the questions that are involved and
we're working on what i hope will be the
final draft now but there it's not going
to be possible to complete that this
this afternoon
we hope to be able to do it when we
reconvene at 1 00 p.m on thursday
there will be conferences of the two
parties in the morning so that we can go
over this with all the senators it's not
enough just that the the leaders
understand or agree we have to make sure
every senator understands it and agrees
with the procedure that we would go
forward with and so i now ask unanimous
consent that the court of impeachment
stand in adjournment until the hour of 1
pm on thursday in the absence of
objection it's so ordered
as you heard the senate majority leaders
say they're still working
hi i'm for acquittal
my reason for acquittal is because um in
listening to one of the republicans
testimony on tv he referred to betty
curry and vernon jordan as those type of
people
i i mean will someone please answer that
question for me i i don't understand
what type of people are they
thanks very much for the call
senate scheduled to be in session at one
o'clock it's a couple of minutes past
right now and as you can see senator
lott there at the bottom center of your
screen has just arrived on the senate
floor live gavel to gavel coverage next
here on c-span 2.
the senate will convene as a court of
impeachment the chaplain will offer a
prayer
almighty god thank you for the gift of
vibrant confidence based on vital
convictions
we are confident in your unlimited power
therefore at no time are we helpless or
hapless
our confidence is rooted in your
commandments
therefore we are strengthened by your
absolutes that give us enduring values
our courage is based on the assurance of
your ever-present
guiding
spirit therefore we will not fear
our hope is rooted in trust in your
reliability
therefore we will not be anxious
your interventions in trying times in
the past
have made us hopeful thinkers
for the future
therefore we trust you
you have called us to glorify you and
the work here in this senate
therefore we give you our best for this
day's responsibilities
you have guided our beloved nation
through difficult periods of discord and
division in the past
therefore we ask for your help
in the present deliberations of the
impeachment trial
thank you for the courage
that flows from our unshakable
confidence in you
through our lord and savior
amen
senators will be seated the
sergeant-at-arms will make the
proclamation
hear ye hear ye hear ye
all persons are commanded to keep silent
on pain of imprisonment while the senate
of the united states
is sitting for the trial of the articles
of impeachment exhibited by the house of
representatives against william
jefferson clinton
president of the united states
if there's no objection the journal of
proceedings of the trial are approved to
date
the chair recognizes the majority leader
thank you mr chief justice and
for the information of all our
colleagues obviously they've already
received the word by the fact that
they're not all present but we're still
attempting to reach an agreement with
respect to remaining procedures for the
trial particularly with regard to how
and when the depositions would be taken
taken
we've been making progress but
it is something we need to be careful
about um hopefully we'll be able to
reach an agreement yet today if an
agreement is reached i expect it very
likely that a roll call vote would be
requested on that agreement and
therefore all members
should be aware of that we will notify
them via the hotline system as the the
voting schedule becomes clear
and certainly we will keep the chief
justice informed of our deliberations
and when we anticipate the need to
reconvene but in view the continuing
negotiations and conferences that are
meeting at this time i ask unanimous
consent the senate stand in recess until
the hour of 2 pm today
in the absence of objection it's so
ordered
so
as the senate again stands in recess
without being convicted on any one
argument
the president's
uh
defense is also very vague
in which you know the democrats are
coming out and saying
that they don't think he should be
acquitted because he's not guilty
but because the
the um
the offenses do not come out to the
uh
the chair recognizes the majority leader
thank you again mr chief justice
mr chief justice uh
in an effort to get an agreement to how
to proceed uh it's very important that
all parties are aware of the procedures
that we're
outlining and that does include uh
senators on both sides of the aisle the
house managers the white house the
attorneys for the witnesses and so
it does take
time and just as we were prepared to
come back in two and moved to a
resolution uh questions were raised
about a couple of specific points and we
feel like those questions need to be
clarified with certainty and rather than
continue to
recess uh hour to hour which i know is
not
fair to the chief justice i think it
would be better at this point that
we know to make sure the senators are
aware that we are working to get an
agreement on this procedure
and that
we need to get that done today
so the depositions can uh get underway
with the attorneys consulting with their
clients friday and saturday and
hopefully the depositions begin on
sunday monday and hopefully be completed
by tuesday but we're working on the
details of that this still could very
well require a boat or two
today or even tomorrow
but we will make that announcement once
it's clear that he's going to take a
recorded vote one or more
and exactly how that would work and so
we will uh we will keep the chief
justice notified of the expected time
frame and
as the information comes available about
exactly when we would come back in the
session and whether or not and how many
votes would be required we'll get that
information to senators but in view of
all that i now ask your name sent the
senate stand in recess subject to the
call of the chair
in the absence of objection it's so
ordered
good me
[Music]
you're looking at a live picture of the
us capital from our camera position just
across from the senate steps and the
senate is back in session
thank you mr chief justice uh
i thought we were
ready to proceed i see uh senator
daschle's not on the floor so he should
be back momentarily maybe i can explain
a few details here he's returning now
but we may still need a little more time
we we thank
you for your patience and our colleagues
on both sides for their patients as we
have
tried to work through uh the details of
these resolutions now and and how to uh
proceed with the depositions
there are a lot of details to it and
everybody needs to be relatively
comfortable they understand how that
would work so that's why it's taken this
additional time
but i think we're to the point where
we're ready to proceed
uh i believe the way it would go now is
that
we would have a resolution
that i would send to the desk
followed by a substitute from senator
daschle
and then senator daschles indicated
that
he they may want to have
a motion to go straight to the articles
of impeachment
and that would require three votes
and then we also
at that point
would make it clear that the depositions
would begin on monday the first
and it's our intent
to then go to those uh three uh votes
and uh so uh
i also understand that
uh
both sides are willing to waive the
parties willing to waive the debate time
on these issues now with that
explanation i'd like to begin that
process and i sent a resolution solution
to the desk and then asked that it be
read in its entirety by the clerk
and time for the two parties be waived
the clerk will read the emotion in its
entirety i believe there was a request
for unanimous consent there
without objection the request is agreed
to
senate resolution 30 relative to the
procedures concerning the articles of
impeachment against william jefferson
clinton
resolve that the deposition time for all
witnesses be determined by the senate
majority leader and minority leader as
outlined in senate resolution 16 and the
enclosed documents and that all senators
have an opportunity to review all
deposition material
which shall be made available at the
earliest possible time
when the senate reconvenes on the day
after the completion of the depositions
and the review period it shall be in
order for both the house managers and
the president's council to move to
resolve any objections made during any
deposition
after a resolution of any such motions
it shall be in order for the house
managers
and or white house counsel to make a
motion or motions to admit the
depositions or portions thereof into
evidence whether transcribed or on
videotape provided further
for a presentation employing all of
portions of such tape
and it shall be in order for the two
leaders jointly only
to make motions for additional discovery
because of new relevant evidence
discovered during the depositions
motions may also then be made for orders
governing the presentation of evidence
and or the testifying of witnesses
before the senate
if no such motions are made or following
the completion of any procedures
authorized as a result of the votes on
any motions the white house shall have
up to 24 hours to make any motions
dealing with testimony or evidence that
the white house counsel deems
appropriate as described above
if no such motions are made or no
witnesses are called to testify in the
senate
the senate shall proceed to final
arguments as provided in the impeachment
rules
waiving the two-person rule contained in
rule 22 for not to exceed six hours to
be equally divided
if motions are agreed to renew evidence
of calling of new witnesses this
resolution is suspended at the
conclusion of the final arguments the
party shall proceed in accordance with
the rules of impeachment provided
however that no motion with respect to
reopening the record in the case shall
be in order and provided further it
shall be in order for a senator to offer
a motion to suspend the rules to allow
for open final deliberations with no
amendments or motions to that motion in
order
and the senate shall proceed to vote on
the motion to suspend the rules to
provide for open senate deliberations
following that vote and if no motions
have been agreed to provided in
paragraphs two and three
and no motions are agreed to
following the arguments then the vote
will occur on any pending motions and
amendments thereto
and
then on the articles of impeachment no
later than 12 o'clock noon on friday
february 12
1999
the chair recognizes the minority leader
i have an amendment that
i send to the desk
the clerk will read the amendment
and the resolution amendment number one
in the resolution strike all after the
word
that
in the first line and insert the
following the the deposition time for
all witnesses to be deposed be limited
to no later than close of business
wednesday february 3rd
and that all senators have an
opportunity to review all deposition
material which shall be made available
at the earliest possible time
when the senate reconvenes the trial at
10 a.m on saturday february six
it shall be in order to resolve any
objections that may not yet be resolved
regarding the depositions after these
deposition objections have been disposed
of it shall be in order for the house
managers and or the white house counsel
to make a motion or motions to admit the
depositions or portions thereof into
evidence such motion shall be limited to
transcribe deposition material only
on monday february 8th there shall be
four hours equally divided
for closing arguments with the white
house using the first two hours and the
house republican managers using the
final two hours
that upon the completion of the closing
arguments the senate shall begin final
deliberation on the articles
a timely motion file to suspend the
rules and open these deliberations shall
be in order
upon the completion of these
deliberations the senate shall without
any intervening action amendment motion
or debate
vote on the articles of impeachment
provided further that the votes on the
articles shall occur no later than 12
o'clock noon friday february 12th
where do we go from uh
parliamentary information the
chair recognizes the senator from utah
mr chief justice
does the majority leaders
resolution does that also
keep open the right of senators to foul
the parliamentarian says it takes a
unanimous consent for a parliamentary
inquiry i would ask unanimous consent
that i'd be permitted to ask one
question is there objection
does the
does the majority leaders resolution
allow for the fouling and consideration
of emotions that may not be mentioned in
the resolution itself
yeah
the parliamentarian tells me it is never
the function of the chair to interpret a
resolution
huh
chief justice yeah the majority leader i
believe that the regular order now is
that we would go to a vote uh on the two
resolutions and act just for the
information the senators after that
senator daschle may have a motion again
uh that i indicated earlier just to go
to a vote on the articles of impeachment
and so there could be three uh votes now
in order without intervening debate and
after that senator daschle and i will
formally lock in the beginning time for
the uh the depositions right
yield the floor
the the
the first vote will be on the amendment
uh
from the
minority of the senator from south
dakota
the yeas and nays are required
the clerk will call the roll
mr abraham
mr abraham
no
mr akaka
mr akaka
i
the senate will be in order
mr allard
mr ashcroft
mr ashcroft no
mr baucus
mr baucus i
mr bai
mr bai
i
mr bennett
mr bennett no
mr biden
mr
biden i
mister bingaman
mr bingaman
aye
mr bond
mr bond no
mrs boxer
mrs boxer
i
mr bro
mr bro
i
mr brownback
mr brownback no
mr brian
mr brian
i
mr bunning
mr bunning
no
mr burns
mr burns
no
mr bird
mr bird
aye
mr campbell
mr campbell
no
mr chafee
mr chafee
no
mr cleland
mr cleland
i
mr cochran
mr cochrane no
ms collins
collins no
mr conrad
mr conrad i mr coverdale
mr coverdale no mr craig
mr craig
no
mr crapo
mr crapo no
mr daschle
mr daschle i mr dewine
mr dewine no
mr dodd
mr dodd
aye mr domenici
mr domenici
no
mr dorgan
mr dorgan i
mr durbin
mr durbin
aye mr edwards
mr edwards i
mr enzi
mr nz
no
mr feingold
mr feingold i
mrs feinstein
mrs feinstein
mr fitzgerald
mr fitzgerald no
mr frist
mr frist
no
mr gorton
mr gorton
no
mr graham of florida
mr graham of florida i
mr graham of texas
mr graham of texas
no
mr grahams of minnesota
mr grahams of minnesota
no
mr grassley
mr grassley
no
mr greg
mr greg
no mr hegel
mr hegel
no
mr harkin
mr hatch
mr hatch i
mr helms
mr hatch
no
mr helms
mr hollings
mr hollings i
mr hutchinson of arkansas
mr hutchinson of arkansas
no
mrs hutchison of texas
mrs hutchison of texas
no
mr inhofe
mr inhofe no
mr in no way
mr in no way aye mr jeffords
mr jeffords no
mr johnson
mr johnson
aye
mr kennedy
mr kennedy
i mr kerry of nebraska
mr kerry of nebraska
i
mr carey of massachusetts
mr carey of massachusetts aye mr cole
mr cole
i
mr kyle
mr kyle
no
ms landrieu
ms landrieu
i
mr lautenberg
mr lautenberg i mr leahy
mr leahy
aye
mr levin
mr levin
i mr lieberman
mr lieberman i
mrs lincoln
mrs lincoln
aye mr lott
mr lot no
mr luger
mr luger no mr mack
mr mack no
mr mccain
mr mccain
no
mr mcconnell
mr mcconnell no
ms mikulski
mr moynihan
mr moynihan
aye mr murkowski
mr murkowski
no
mrs murray
mrs murray
aye mr nichols
mr nichols
no
mr reed of rhode island
mr reed of rhode island i mr reed of
nevada
mr reed of nevada i
mr rob
mr rob
i mr roberts
mr roberts no
mr rockefeller
mr rockefeller i
mr roth
mr roth no
mr santorum
mr santorum no
mr sarbanes
mr sarbanes aye mr schumer
mr schumer i mr sessions
mr sessions
no
mr shelby
mr shelby
no
mr smith of new hampshire
mr smith of new hampshire no mr smith of
oregon mr smith of oregon no miss snow
miss snow
no
mr specter
mr spector
no
mr stevens
mr stevens
no
mr thomas
mr thomas
no
mr thompson
mr thompson
no mr thurman
mr thurman
no
mr torricelli
mr vornovich
mr vornovich
no
mr warner
mr warner
no
mr wellstone
mr wellstone
aye mr wyden
mr wyden
i
mr harkin
[Music]
mr harkin i
is
there's
now
mr helms
mr helms no
this
so
mr torricelli
mr torselli
all
i
the senate will be in order
on this vote the yeas are 44 the nays
are 54 and the amendment is not agreed
to
the question now is on s res 30 the
resolution offered by senator law
the a's and nays are called for and the
clerk will call the roll
the clerk will report the amendment
amendment number two and the resolution
strike all after the word that and the
first line and insert the following
the senate now proceed to closing
arguments that there be two hours for
the white house council followed by two
hours for the house managers
and that at the conclusion of this time
the senate proceed to vote on each of
the articles without intervening action
motion or debate except for
deliberations if so decided by the
senate
the question is on the amendment just
read
the yeas and nays are automatic the
clerk will call the roll mr abraham
mr akaka
mr allard
ashcroft
mr bakas
mr bai
mr bennett
mr biden
mr bingaman
the senate will be in order
mr bingaman
mr bond
mrs boxer
mr bro
mr brownback
mr brian
mr bunny
mr burns
mr bird
mr campbell
mr chafee
mr cleland
mr cochran
ms collins
mr conrad
mr coverdell
mr craig
mr cripo
mr daschle
mr dewine
mr dodd
mr domenici
mr
dorgan mr durbin
mr edwards
mr lindsey
mr feingold
mrs feinstein
mr
fitzgerald mr frist
mr gorster frist
mr gorton
mr graham of florida
mr graham of texas
mr grahams of minnesota
mr grassley
mr greg
mr
hegel mr harkin
mr hatch
mr helms
mr hollings
mr hutchinson of arkansas
mrs hutchison of texas
mr inhofe
mr inouye
mr jeffords
mr johnson
mr kennedy
mr kerry of nebraska
mr kerry of massachusetts
mr cole
mr kyle
ms landrieu
mr lautenberg
mr leahy
mr levin
mr lieberman
mrs lincoln
mr lott
mr luger
mr mack
mr mccain
mr mcconnell
ms mikulski
mr moynihan
mr
mr murkowski
mrs murray
mr nichols
mr reed of rhode island
mr reed of nevada
mr rob
mr roberts
mr rockefeller
mr roth
mr santorum
mr sarbanes
mr schumer
mr sessions
mr shelby
mr smith of new hampshire
mr smith of oregon
ms snow
mr spector
mr stevens
mr thomas
mr thompson
mr thurman
mr torricelli
mr voinovich
mr warner
mr wellstone
mr wyden
senators voting in the affirmative acaca
bacchus bai biden bingaman boxer brian
byrd cleland conrad daschle dodd dorgan
durbin edwards feinstein graham of
florida harkin hollings and o.a johnson
kennedy carey of nebraska kerry of
massachusetts
cole landrieu lautenberg leahy levin
lieberman lincoln
moynihan murray reed of rhode island
reed of nevada rob rockefeller
sarbanes schumer torricelli wellstone
and wyden
senators voting in the negative
akaka
abraham
ashcroft bennett
bond brown back
bunning burns campbell chaffey
cochran
collins coverdell craig crapo
dewine domenici enzi feingold fitzgerald
frist
gordon graham of texas grams of
minnesota grassley greg
hegel
hatch helms hutchinson of arkansas
hutchison of texas
inhofe jeffords kyle lot luger mac
mccain mcconnell murkowski nichols
roberts roth santorum sessions shelby
smith of new hampshire smith of oregon
snow specter stevens thomas thompson
thurman voinovich and warner
the chair recognizes the senator from
louisiana mr bro
mr bro ah
okay
on this vote the yeas are 43 the nays
are 55 and the amendment is not agreed
to
the majority leader uh mr chief justice
uh i suggest absence in quorum the clerk
will call the roll
mr abraham
oh
so
so
mr akaka
so
mr allard
mr ashcroft
mr baucus
the senate back in session today after
having been
in recess subject to the call of the
chair most of the day we are going to
open our phone lines while they are in
this quorum call for your thoughts on
what you've seen over these 12 days of
the impeachment trial of the president
of the united states
in the two votes that just happened
the democratic proposal to call
witnesses uh was defeated and then a
there was a proposal to go to a final
vote on the articles of impeachment that
was also defeated we're waiting for next
is a vote on the majority leaders
proposal which would be the
the parameters for taking the
depositions from the witnesses where and
when and who would do those and as soon
as the senators come back from this
quorum call you see that here live on
c-span too but up first is columbus ohio
on the line for acquittal
hello hi go ahead please
yes i'm calling i am very disturbed
about this political part that's being
played in this situation i am for
acquittal
i feel
that this is a situation that never even
should have gotten into
the news
media at all and second of all i don't
see how the republicans and democrats
can control the country in the house or
the senate after this is probably going
to need to go to independent and the
democrats
the right wing they are just way out
left field i'm very upset concerning
this and i only think the democrats seem
to be able to do
every motion they even should probably
put a time limit on the trial they won't
go along with that it's just it's it's
really ridiculous and there was a caller
yesterday real quickly and i'll get off
the air that called in and stated that
since oj
can kill somebody in the country it gets
ev everything goes and i'm appalled at
that because there have been black
people that have been hung and killed
and nobody's paid any time for it or
done any time or paid any price or
anything for it so i think that we
should leave oj out of this situation
new york city good evening
out yeah turn the volume down on your tv
yeah i'm i think i hear myself on the
air right yes you do turn for conviction
uh
yeah i think uh president clinton
new york we're getting a little bit of
an echo so we're going to move on to
virginia beach good evening
uh yes sir uh i think this is a perfect
example for the uh citizens in the
united states to pay attention to
next time we have an election
we need to really think about what we're
seeing here and and put that
uh information that we're experiencing
here to uh to our vote and uh
who knows what will happen after that
and i appreciate your time thank you
thank you for the calls lincoln hills
illinois is undecided
um yes uh i'm undecided the reason is
because i've been listening to both
sides of the dispute
and
my
what confuses me is the fact that this
man has already been tried and convicted
in the media on television and by
everybody who's been calling in i was
led to believe that a person is usually
in is presumed innocent until proven
guilty in the court of law i don't
understand why all of a sudden
everybody's saying he's guilty he's
guilty he's guilty and we're fighting
over that
newberry springs uh california
uh yes i'm for conviction uh
what is really amazing me is all these
people there are saying that uh it's a
private affair uh
it isn't a private affair when he
decided to take his perverted ways into
the oval office which is a state
building
it belongs to the people and secondly
the
people that are saying about
acknowledging and saying what courage he
has they're not seeing courage they're
seeing a man with an ultra ego
arrogance and defiance and he continues
to do this and then i would pose just
one question to
all the senators that are vigorously
defending him
should he be acquitted are they ready to
sit down and write congressional pardons
for everybody that is sitting behind
bars now for perjury and obstruction of
justice or are those people held at a
higher level
of the law than what the president of
the united states is
alexandria virginia undecided tonight
good evening
yes
my name is jim
go right ahead yes
i'm calling because i am undecided but
there are two things
this man has
gone every bit so far is almost admit
that he's admitted perjury number one
number two the subject of
obstruction of justice
he has not addressed
my problem is why is the people's
business not being shown on tv when we
are paying the salaries this is our
country this is our senate our house
why are they excluding the people from
the people's business and i am very
upset about this this is nothing but the
socialism almost at its worst
and
i don't have one way or another uh
what should be done but all i know is
the man has almost admitted perjury or
dang near admitted perjury the uh but
you're so but having said that you're
still undecided about where it should go
well you know
since he's he i mean he's apologized
he's apologized for everything under the
sun except for lying under oath to a
federal grand jury
thanks alexandria atlanta maryland good
evening
sir i'm glad that i finally was able to
get through i want to thank the
cable company and also c-span
for allowing the public to see
just what goes on in in the halls of
congress
um i'm for acquittal
for the president simply because that i
feel
that that there has been too much
hypocrisy
in the republican party uh for them to
sit in judgment of this man i do believe
that henry hyde was exposed and having
an adulterous affair himself
and when he when he considered
resignation that then house speaker newt
gingrich said that oh no don't resign
you know you stick to your guns and
we're gonna get this man and you know i
i heard
by listening to c-span that the founding
fathers used found founded impeachment
for an another polite means of
getting rid of a leader
uh without so-called assassinating him
so
really this is nothing more than a
political assassination of the president
and i'm very disgusted by it and there's
just too much
hypocrisy that's going on and it needs
to stop
sun city california
yes i have so many reasons for
conviction i hardly know where to start
but let me start out with saying i
cannot believe these
people that call in for acquittal and
say we must be about our country's
business if this shouldn't hit the list
of our country's business i don't know
what should i can't imagine those
democratic senators being as deaf dumb
and blind as they appear to be
and if they are so sure that witnesses
cannot offer any new facts
and won't
affect the trial why in the world don't
they say okay come on let's get on with
the witnesses and be done with it
kansas city missouri good evening
hello hi
uh
i'm for acquittal
and
but not without punishment
i think the house and the senate ought
to
uh
abolish the
term length law making serve another
eight years the economy hadn't any been
any better for years
thank you
boston good evening
i'm for conviction
and
i would like to see him out of office
but if he doesn't get out of office i
agree with warren hatch
my punishment thought would be no memoir
book no library
it would hurt him reputation wise and in
the pocketbook and otherwise
that's the only way to hurt them
on the undecided line is washington dc
hello hi tell us why you're undecided
well i was
let me cut the radio down
hello yes um
i'm i'm confused about the fact that i
thought this was a
political type of trial and not a
criminal trial
and it seems that everybody who's
calling in is calling like this is a
criminal trial
and my understanding was that if it was
a senate trial that there they cannot
give punishment to the president and i
find that um
that that's what has me confused i'm not
sure if i should be thinking on a
criminal level or on a
um
political level you know as to what this
trial is about
after being recessed most of the
afternoon the senate came back in
session shortly after five o'clock and
two votes occurred there was a
democratic proposal about where to move
next with the witnesses that was
defeated and another proposal by
democratic leader tom daschle was
defeated that would have moved the
senate on to a final vote on the
articles of impeachment in a quorum call
right now we're anticipating when the
senate comes back there will be a vote
on a republican proposal about which way
to go on the depositions with the
witnesses mckinney texas on the line for
acquittal
i believe that the
republicans
have taken this beyond simply
the matter of removing
president clinton from office
i think this is
turned into a direct attack
and assault on the democratic party
i would advise the senators to beware of
any more republicans bringing in trojan
horses
thank you very much
that last call from mckinney texas on
the line for acquittal on the line for
conviction is amarillo texas
yes uh
i was just listening to man from
mckinney
and these other people
uh
i can't understand why
so many people
are accusing republicans of all of this
when it was
the
cl the uh
democrats mr clinton that brought us
here
and i have
and they also also insinuating that the
results up for 92.
he only got 44 million 900
without objection it's order that the
quorum call be dispensed with
mr chief justice i sent an amendment to
the desk modifying the last paragraph of
page three and ask that it be agreed to
and the motion to reconsider be laid
upon the table
what
the clerk will report the amendment
amendment number three on page three
strike the words any pending motions and
amendments thereto and then on
and insert the following at the end
if all motions are disposed of and final
deliberations are completed
objection the amendment is agreed to
the question is on the resolution as
amended
the yeas and nays are automatic the
clerk will call the role mr abraham
mr abraham i mr akaka
mr akaka no
mr allard
ashcroft
mr ashcroft i
mr bacchus
mr bakas
no mr bai
mr mai
no mr bennett
mr bennett
ah
mr biden
the senate will be in order
mr biden
no
mr bingaman
mr bingaman
no mr bond
mr bond
i mrs boxer
this is boxer
no mr bro
mr brown back
mr brown back
aye
mr brian
mr brian no mr bunning
mr bunning
i
mr burns
mr burns aye mr bird
mr bird
no mr campbell
mr campbell aye mr chafee
mr chafee aye mr cleland
cleland no mr cochran
mr cochran i miss collins
ms collins i mr conrad
mr conrad no mr coverdell
mr coverdell i mr craig
mr craig aye mr crapo
mr crapo aye mr daschle
mr daschle no mr dewine
mr dewine i mr dodd
mr dodd
no
mr domenici
mr domenici
aye mr dorgan
mr dorgan no mr durbin
mr durbin
no mr edwards
mr edwards
no
mr renzi
mr
i mr feingold
mr feingold no
mrs feinstein
mrs feinstein
no
mr fitzgerald
mr fitzgerald i mr frist
mr frist
i mr gorton
mr gorton i mr graham of florida
mr graham of florida no
mr graham of taxes
mr graham of taxes
i
mr grahams of minnesota
mr grahams of minnesota i
mr grassley
mr grassley aye mr greg
mr greg aye mr hagel
mr hegel aye mr harkin
mr harkin no mr hatch
mr hatch aye mr helms
mr helms i
mr hollings
mr hollings no mr hutchinson of arkansas
mr hutchinson of arkansas
i
mrs hutchison of texas
this is hutcheson of texas
i mr inhofe
mr inhofe aye mr inouye
mr noah no mr jeffords
mr jeffords aye mr johnson
mr johnson
no
mr kennedy
mr kennedy no mr carey of nebraska
mr carey of nebraska
no mr carey of massachusetts
mr kerry of massachusetts no
mr cole
mr cole
no mr kyle
mr kyle
i miss landrieu
ms landrieu
no mr
lautenberg mr lautenberg no mr leahy
mr leahy
no mr levin
mr levin
no mr lieberman
mr lieberman
no mrs lincoln
mrs lincoln
no mr lott
mr lot
i mr luger
mr luger i mr mack
mr mack aye mr mccain
mr mccain
aye mr mcconnell
mr mcconnell i'm ms mikulski
mr moynihan
mr moynihan
i
mr murkowski
mr murkowski i mrs murray
mrs marie
no mr nichols
mr nichols i mr reed of rhode island
mr reed of rhode island no mr reed of
nevada
mr reed of nevada no mr robb
mr rob now mr roberts
mr roberts aye mr rockefeller
mr rockefeller
no mr roth
mr roth i mr santorum
mr santorum aye mr sarbanes
mr sarbanes no mr schumer
mr schumer
no mr sessions
mr sessions aye mr shelby
mr shelby aye mr smith of new hampshire
mr smith of new hampshire aye mr smith
of oregon
mr smith of oregon aye ms snow
ms snow
i mr specter
mr
i mr stevens
mr stevens i mr thomas
mr thomas aye mr thompson
mr thompson aye mr thurmond
mr thurmond aye mr torreselli
[Music]
mr torricelli no mr voynovich
aye mr warner
mr warner i mr wellstone
mr wellstone no mr wyden
mr wyden no mr moynihan
mr moynihan
okay
right
mr bro
mr bro
no
on this vote the yeas are 54
the nays are 44 and the resolution as
amended is agreed to
now what do we do the chair recognizes
the majority leader
mr chief gus justice with regard to the
beginning of depositions i ask unanimous
consent that the enclosed document be
the substitute for the document sent
earlier to the desk and the enclosed
consent agreement be agreed to
all of which deal with the taking of
depositions
is there objection
without objection it's so ordered now i
understand uh mr chief justice that uh
the democratic leader is prepared to
agree that depositions will begin on
monday february the first
and uh with uh this having been decided
and the vote we just uh took
we have discussed the schedule for the
balance of the week in view of the fact
that at this point
the parties
will begin to prepare for depositions
and the depositions will begin on monday
members will
not be expected to be here for any
business before
wednesday
but we uh we could be required to have a
session a wednesday afternoon
and i want to emphasize that as the
deposition material becomes available
we will have the sergeant-at-arms
have it in a room for members to begin
to review so beginning tuesday senators
that would
like to begin reviewing
the depositions the material from the
depositions it will be available in
installments as it comes available on
tuesday so you would have that
opportunity tuesday and wednesday
not later than thursday then we would go
to the next phase of
our agreement that we have voted on
but at this time
we're notifying the members that there
would be no further recorded votes and
no further business while we await the
return of the depositions
through friday saturday sunday monday
and tuesday but members should expect to
be here on wednesday and they would need
to be here on wednesday in order to
begin to to make sure they've had time
to review the documents that the
deposition material so that we can
proceed to then on thursday dirty leader
yield for it i wouldn't
i just want our senators allowed to
attend these depositions
under the agreement we just passed there
will be
mr chief justice if i may proceed to
respond to that question without
objection uh there will be a senator
from each side
at the deposition
who
will preside uh over the depositions uh
and uh
senator daschle
also will be uh certain staff there but
a senator other than the two presiding
senators uh would not be in order on
what we agreed to but there will be one
from each side that will uh be presiding
and will actually make determinations
when objections are made
i yield before mr chief justice uh i now
ask unanimous consent that the court of
impeachment stand and adjournment until
the hour of 1 pm on thursday february
5th i further asked and said the senate
now resume legislative session so that
we may attend to several legislative
matters without objection it's so
ordered
ulster abraham
uh
okay
yeah
okay
um
oh
right
foreign
okay
this
up
okay
can
so dave
do you want to tell some of your
sessions that if we're not closed out by
seven i'll go ahead and take care of
whatever
feminism
yeah
he's i think he's worrying about being
up next and i'll just you know the runs
a little over that's okay i'll take care
of it
so he can
if that's what he's waiting around for
so
so
so
the u.s senate now in a transition
period from the impeachment trial they
were sitting as the impeachment trial
jurors earlier in this transition they
are moving on to legislative business
and this is a quorum call that gets them
through that transition we're going to
take this opportunity to take your phone
calls while we're waiting once again for
the senate to be back in session just a
few moments ago there were
several votes on the senate floor
including two proposals on how to
proceed with taking depositions from the
witnesses the democratic proposal was
defeated the republican proposal was
approved we'll have some more specific
details on those proposals for you a
little bit later here on c-span 2. in
the meantime as we're waiting for the
senate to begin an opportunity
to take your calls as soon as the
majority leader is finished
senate will please come to order the
chair recognizes the majority leader
thank you mr president i answer the
quorum call be dispensed with without
objection so ordered and mr president i
ask unanimous consent that the
appointments that are now at the desk
appear separately in the record as if
made by the chair
without objection so ordered
mr president i ask unanimous consent
that when the senate completes its
business today it's standing in german
until 10 a.m on friday january 29th for
a pro forma session only i further ask
consent that immediately after convening
on friday the senate then adjourned over
until tuesday february 2nd at 10 a.m for
a pro forma session only i further asked
that immediately upon convening on two
to the senate then can adjourn
automatically until 12 noon on wednesday
february 3rd
ascendant's consent that when the senate
convenes on wednesday immediately
following the player prayer the journal
proceedings be approved to the day the
morning hour be deemed to have expired
the time for the two leaders be reserved
and then be appeared for morning
business until the hour of 2 p.m with
the time divided as follows 60 minutes
under the control of the majority leader
or his desert knee 60 minutes under
control the minority leader or his
designee
without objection so order i finally
asked unanimous consent that it
notwithstanding the performance sessions
it be in order for committees to file
legislative and executive matters
without objection so ordered as just
announced the senate will be conducting
performance sessions on friday and
tuesday no business will be transacted
the senate will be in legislative
session on monday and may consider any
legislative or executive items that may
be available the court of impeachment
will next meet at 1 pm on thursday if
there's no further business come forward
i i yield uh mr uh president yield four
so that the senator can offer a bill
mr president chair recognizes the
senator from virginia mr president i
thank the majority leader and i send the
bill to the desk and i ask unanimous
consent to occlu include there with an
appropriate statement that be included
in the record that it be appropriately
printed and referred to the appropriate
committee and
i think again the majority leader and i
yield to four
objections
there's no further business come before
the senate i ask the senate standing in
german under the previous order
senator the senate stands the jury hold
on
the senate has adjourned until tomorrow
at 10 o'clock eastern time we'll be back
in a pro-forma session no legislative
business will be conducted tomorrow the
impeachment trial of the president will
continue at 1 pm next wednesday late
this afternoon several votes on the
senate floor about how to proceed with
taking depositions from the witnesses
the democrat